Wir schreiben das Jahr 2012. Die Apple-Gemeinde versammelt sich in San Francisco. Neue Hardware, neue Software, iOS 6 und eine neue Version des besten Betriebssystems der Welt.
Mac OS 10.8 Fucking Herr, wir sitzen hier und in einem Monat kommt ein neues Betriebssystem raus und uns interessiert es nicht?
Mich betrifft echt viel mehr das Mountain-Line mit dem Bloat-Bear, der schon mal an zur Sprache kam, dass der jetzt los liegt und uns das überhaupt nicht interessiert. Keine Features drin sind, die uns kicken, keine Pro-Features. Das ist ja sowieso, das rückt ja immer weiter weg. Je mehr wir es uns wünschen, desto weiter entfernt es sich von uns. Fallsystem haben wir auch nichts gehört.
Es geht den Bach runter.
Du kannst das hören? Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Sehen uns dann in der nächsten Woche wieder.
Ja, das wird, glaube ich, die Mimimi-Mobile-Max-Sendung schlecht hin.
Ein Audio-Hörspiel.
Mobile Max?
Wir müssen reden.
Ja, so geht's echt überhaupt nicht. Also wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird dieser Podcast bald irgendwie sich ein anderes Schwerpunktthema suchen müssen. Worüber könnte man denn sonst noch in dieser Runde quatschen?
S-Bahn.
Also Linux-Distributionen gibt's wie Sand am Meer, ne?
Das stimmt.
Aber hat man ja schon letztens festgestellt, dass uns das nicht so richtig klingt.
Ich glaube, das Bier ist tatsächlich schon rum.
Wann soll das denn eigentlich vorbei sein?
Das Bier? Irgendwas mit Januar. Ich weiß bloß nicht welches Jahr.
Januar, okay.
Dann führ das doch gleich mal in den Abfluss und hol dir ein neues.
Das ist so, wenn man Nerds ohne Handbuch irgendwas schickt, dann geht das halt schief. Ich konnte ja nichts dafür.
Keine Specks beigelegt, klar.
Was kann ich dafür? Auf einmal steht so eine Kiste Bier vor meiner Tür. Also es wurde gebracht, es wurde geschickt.
Wie lange ist das her?
Weiß ich nicht länger. Aber ich meine, stand ja nicht drauf, dass es sich um Bier handelt, was so nicht so lange hält, wie sonst.
Wie so ein Industrie-Bex.
Ja, Bex ist ja kein Bier.
Na gut, die Diskussion will ich jetzt nicht aufmachen. Auf jeden Fall ist es schwierig für mich gewesen. Ich wusste nicht, dass ich da quasi so Frischkäse geliefert bekomme.
Na so schlimm ist es aber nun auch nicht mit Bier normalerweise.
Hast du es gerade als Frischkäse bezeichnet?
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall gibt es heute genug Anlass zur Frustration und allgemein Mimimi.
Deswegen haben wir auch alle, bis auf Tim, schon zum Frustbier gegriffen.
Ja, ich hab dafür die Fruststimme irgendwie.
Na ja, ich hör schon.
Was, was, was? Ja, ja, ist ein bisschen...
Tim hat die Fruststimme.
Das war zu viel Quatsche. Ich mag ja die ganze Zeit ins Netz reden, aber wenn man dann irgendwie parallel auch noch auf der Straße weiter quatscht, dann ist irgendwann Schluss.
Auf der Straße?
Na ja, draußen.
Du warst draußen?
Ich war auf der SIGINT. Ja, war ganz nett. Also man kann da gut quatschen. Das tut man dann auch. Und dann war noch das Wetter gut. Und dann stand man da irgendwie bis nachts um vier. Und hatte halt geredet und geredet und geredet und geredet. Und am Ende des Tages war ich schon etwas heißer. Und dann noch ein Hörer treffen hinterher. Und dann war ich komplett heißer. Und jetzt war ich mal auch echt so dermaßen heißer. Schon Angst hatte ich. Ich fang jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr an zu reden. Und jetzt hält das aber auch schon seit dem zweiten Tag so an.
Heiser wie Melli bist du.
Vielleicht kling ich ja jetzt immer so.
Da könnt ihr euch schon mal dran gewöhnen.
Die ist ja alles durch.
Ja, ich sag ja immer, ich trinke nicht so viel Bier. Aber wenn jemand der Meinung ist, dann müsst ihr mir solche Mengen schicken, die im Prinzip für mein Jahr oder drei.
Wie lange steht das denn hier schon?
Hier steht es jetzt noch nicht so lange. Seitdem es hier steht, merken Leute, dass es schlecht ist. Das war an sich keine schlechte Idee von mir.
Wir fordern hier statt Schokolade, die im Sommer eh nicht so gut funktioniert, mal für die Meta eben eine neue frische Kiste Biersortiment an.
Ja, oder schickt was anderes, schickt Pastellen oder so was.
Fischer Man's Friend.
Ich bin überhaupt ein Freund von praktischen Geschenken.
Geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung tatsächlich.
Ja, ihr seht schon, wir haben auch heute wieder keine Themen dabei.
Es langweilt, es langweilt. Das Intro hat mal wieder genau gepasst, eigentlich zur Stimmung. Ja, wir können uns hier jetzt...
Also ich freu mich auf Mountain Lion. Und auf iOS 6.
iOS 6, wollen wir damit anfangen? Da ist ja noch ein bisschen Lichtblick.
Gibt's da irgendwelche Infos zu? Also ich meine...
Naja, die neuen Maps. Das halte ich für ausgesprochen wahrscheinlich, dass das stimmt. Das hat sich ja schon längere Zeit angekündigt. Und naja, wenn man mal ganz optimistisch ist. Das kann man ja auch mal machen in so einem Fanboy-Podcast, oder?
Aber es fällt mir schwer.
Es fällt mir echt schwer. Früher hätte ich gesagt, so jetzt kommt Apple hier, 3D Maps, kein Stein bleibt auf dem anderen.
Und jetzt denke ich mir noch so, oh.
Hoffentlich verkackt es nicht.
Dann gehen wir mal positiv ran. Schlechter machen als Google können sie es ja kaum.
Was?
Schlechter geht immer.
Aber man kann das definitiv schlechter machen.
Okay, man kann es schlechter machen, aber so Kart-Material technisch war das schon nicht ganz so toll.
Was will Apple dann nutzen für Kart-Material? Das bin ich mal gespannt. Das wird ja dann auf jeden Fall nicht besser. Dann steigt einer aus, weil ihm die Lizenz nicht fällt und halb Berlin fehlt oder was? Und du fährst deinen Kanal?
War das nicht irgendein April-Scherz?
Ich glaube, das geht nicht. Wenn du einmal hinzugefügt hast, hast du hinzugefügt.
Nee, nee, das haben sie jetzt gemacht.
Sie haben ihre Lizenz gewechselt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Scherz oder eine Lizenz gemeint war.
Sie haben alle aufgefordert, irgendwie das zu unterschreiben, dass ihr Material auch unter neuen Lizenz irgendwie okay ist und einer meinte nö.
Ich hab noch nichts unterschrieben. Und?
Ja, da haben sie dann Zeug rausgeschmissen.
Nee, wahrscheinlich hast du einfach...
Da fehlt jetzt halb Jamaika oder was?
Zum Beispiel, guck mal nach.
Na oder du hast halt spät genug angefangen, als die neue Lizenz schon mit drinnen stand. Das gilt nur für irgendwelche relativ alten Accounts.
Das war ein April-Shirt, so wird hier behauptet.
Der kam dann aber ein bisschen spät, oder? Oder ist der... das war dann so ein Nachlauf-April-Shirt. Ich weiß es. Einer hat es am 1. April gelesen und dann aber am 2. April irgendwo anders gepostet.
Sie hatten auf jeden Fall so einen Screenshot, dass Halbwest Berlin fehlt und dass das so aussah, wie auf so einer DDR-Karte auf so einer alten und weil der nicht die neue Lizenz mitmachen wollte. Und irgendwie war das schon ein bisschen fischig, aber irgendwie klang es auch durchaus plausibel.
Naja, das sind die besten April-Scherze, die dann noch hier Ende Mai irgendwie gelöst werden müssen.
Was genau war jetzt der April-Scherz? Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Also der April-Scherz war, dass die Geschichte war, dass Open Street Map irgendwie die Lizenz wechselt und dass sie noch, und das schon vor einer Weile auch gemacht haben, aber dass es halt noch gewisse Karten gab, die unter der alten Lizenz waren. Die wollten irgendwie von Creative Commons zu irgendeiner moderneren irgendwie hin.
Nee, die wollen zu Creative Commons, glaube ich.
Oder so rum.
Und da meinte irgendjemand, dass die für Karten nicht geeignet sei.
Genau, und dann hatten sie aber noch altes Material und meinten zu ihren Usern, die da halt die Urheber sind, dass sie doch mal das sozusagen wechseln sollen, die Lizenz, also erlauben sollen, dass das unter der neuen Lizenz läuft. Und einer wohl hat das nicht gemacht und der hat wohl Halb-Berlin oder West-Berlin halt irgendwie aufgenommen und der hat gesagt, nö, er will das mit der Lizenz nicht wechseln.
Also hier steht im Chat geschrieben, dass es am 1. April ein Scherz bei Heise schon war.
Hat denn jemand mal einen Link?
Verstehe.
Und der war so gut, dass der immer noch durchs Netz gehorxt und meandert wird.
Vielleicht zweimal der Link.
Na siehst du, da haben wir doch schon wieder die halbe Sendung mitgefüllt. Ist doch schön.
Grund. Also, ihr seht, wir haben wirklich keine Themen. Das wär schon April-Scherze von Heiseroll aus der Gistekram.
Ich bin gespannt, dass ihr überhaupt noch am 1.
Ich mach das schon gar nicht mehr.
Ich hab da, wenn es am 1. wäre, dann hätte ich das auf jeden Fall nicht erzählt. Ich hab's wahrscheinlich einen Tag später gelesen, weil irgendwelche anderen Pfeifen es immer noch gepostet haben.
Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass ich das nicht am 1.
und am 2. April morgens um 5 Uhr noch liest und da der alte Scheiß noch drin steht.
Also die Lizenz wechseln sie schon, aber dass man diesem Halb-Berlin fehlt und so, das war schon...
Ja, aber es soll ja nur hingucken, das ist komplett West-Berlin, was da fehlt.
Ich kann nicht so richtig glauben, dass Apple auf Open-Street-Map geht.
Na, haben sie doch aber vom Map. Die haben sie jetzt von iPod und so gemacht.
Das kann nur ein Test gewesen sein.
Was sollen sie das Kartenmaterial denn sonst herkriegen?
Warum sollen sie sonst testen?
Einkaufen.
Genauso wie alle anderen.
Genau.
Also mich würde das jetzt nicht...
Nee, Google hat es auch noch gekauft.
Also es ist wohl sehr offensichtlich, dass das, was bei iPhoto da ist, USM ist. Also das...
Haben sie jetzt ja auch hinzugefügt. Mit dem Credit.
Da gab es ja die Aufregung. So.
Und wenn das schon USM ist, dann würde es mich doch hochgradig wundern, wenn sie dann ein halbes Jahr später mit ihrem richtigen Web-Predi rauskommt, dass es dann wieder auf irgendwas anderem basiert. Ich sage nicht, dass das unmöglich ist, aber highly unlikely.
Na ja gut, dafür sollen diese Foto-Geschichten, da braucht man halt vielleicht nicht so super präzise Maps und so, ne?
Wenn sie ent...
Foto-Geschichten?
Na hier für in iPhoto. Wo war diese Map?
In iPhoto.
Nur so ein paar Kacheln? Wo ist denn das schon dabei?
Ja, die fangen wir jetzt nicht an für jedes Programm, sich einen anderen Kartendienst zusammen zu bauen.
Apple, du weißt es nicht!
Ich kann mir auch so das vorstellen, dass die eventuell noch nicht die Verhandlung über das Kartenmaterial abgeschlossen hatten, wo sie die herkriegen und dass sie darum dann erst mal auf das System-Map trafen.
Oder noch nicht verraten wollten.
Oder noch nicht verraten wollten oder dergleichen mehr, aber die App war schon fertig und sie haben erst mal das genommen. Also ich würde sagen, das ist keine abgemachte Sache, dass das Open-Street-Map ist.
Vielleicht benutzen sie auch nur die Technologie dahinter und kaufen sich ihr eigenes Material zusammen.
Wie schick ist denn das Open-Street-Map eigentlich? Ich weiß es gar nicht so genau.
Ist das dann relativ gut?
Die Daten sind toll.
Die Daten sind genau, wie man es haben will.
Und auch komplette Abdeckungen und so?
Das hängt aber vom Land ab.
Das hängt vom Land ab.
Aber die westliche Welt ist schon relativ gut.
Ist geil, wenn du irgendwie in Wäldern bist oder so was mal unterwegs, wo bei Google Maps einfach nur grüne Fläche ist. Da siehst du da im Idealfall noch jeden Elektromast und so was. Also es ist wirklich kleine Waldwege und so. Das ist echt geil.
Ich erzähle immer gerne die Geschichte aus Italien. Da gibt es so einen Bereich in der Toskana. Da scheinen sämtliche Kartenhersteller, so von Autokarten, von einer Karte abzuschreiben, die irgendwann das italienische Militär mal 1907 oder so aufgenommen hat. Und da fehlen halt einfach Straßen, komplette Straßen. Die gibt es nur bei Open Street Map. Die gibt es nicht bei Google, die gibt es nicht bei irgendeinem Shell-Atlas oder so. Die kriegst du nur bei Open Street Map, weil da halt mal jemand langgefahren ist. Und dann ist die Straße aber schon so kaputt, dass du denkst, also die haben sie auch seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich weil sie gar nicht wussten, dass die existiert.
Ja, steht ja nicht in der Karte.
Sollen wir Straße reparieren?
Na Google mit seinem Monopol geht wahrscheinlich irgendwann dazu, über alle Straßen abzureißen, die sie nicht in der Karte haben, damit einfach Realität und Google in Übereinklang stehen.
Na hier in Berlin waren sie ja etwas vorauseilend. Da haben sie nämlich erst vor kurzer Zeit das überhaupt geschafft, den S-Bahn-Ring zuzumachen. Also da war so der S-Bahn-Ring, da fehlte einfach so zwischen Treptower Park und ich glaube Sonderli, wie heißt die nächste Station da, auf dem Ring hinter Sonnen. Fehlte einfach die komplette Strecke. Genau, die ist das Neue Köln. Bei Google.
Ja, die haben sie ja gestern wieder abgerissen. Genau die Strecke.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum der Flughafen nicht eröffnet. Der ist ja nicht auf Google. Okay, reiß mal wieder ab.
Den kriegen wir auch nicht mehr bis nächste Woche mit in die Karte.
Aber was halt sehr verheißungsvoll ist, ist die Implementierung der Technologie von der Bude, deren Namen ich jetzt schon wieder vergessen habe, die sie gekauft haben. Wie hießen die? C3? Irgendwas?
Diese Maps, dieses 3D Zeug.
Das halte ich ja für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir das sehen werden. Und es gab ja auch diesen Bericht darüber, wo ja auch schon so...
Na ja, aber wenn sie so ein 3D Zeug haben, dann können sie kein Open-Street-Map sein. Dann brauchen sie zumindest noch zusätzliches Material, nämlich die Satelliten-Aufnahmen bzw. die 3D-Aufnahmen, die entsprechenden.
Klar.
Also es sind keine 3D-Aufnahmen, sondern es sind halt...
Komplette Modelle?
Also 3D-Aufnahmen sind das bei Google auch nicht. Wie willst du eine 3D-Aufnahme aus...?
Fotografieren und Laserscannen.
Laserscannen?
Wie machen sie das? Machen sie das mit irgendeinen Laserscanner?
Nee, die stitchen einfach da die Fotos zusammen. Also das ist ja das, was diese Bude besonders gut hinbekommen hat. Dass die halt einfach Vogelperspektive, Schrägfotos nehmen und daraus dann eben 3D rechnen.
Ich dachte, diese Nokia-Autos hätten immer noch 3D-Scanner oben drauf. Da irgendein Laserzeug oder was auch immer. Nee, Mikro, war das nicht Mikrowellenstrahl? Hatte doch jemand ganz ruhig vor der Angst, dass da von der Mikrowellenstrahlung gekocht wird. Das war dann so dieser ganze Google Street View Hysterie. Hat sich da doch einer von irgendeiner Zeitung mit...
Also ich benutze ja nach wie vor Bing Maps mit der Vogelperspektive. Nein, Quatsch.
Stimmt, die haben ja abgeschaltet, ne?
Nee, die gab's. Als letztes, als ich geguckt hab, gab's die noch.
Nee, aber hier dieses, wie heißt das, Street Sight von Google, das haben sie ja in Deutschland abgeschaltet über Nacht und keiner weiß warum.
War wegen der Spießer.
So plötzlich so?
Auch jetzt machen wir doch durch.
Na so plötzlich war das nicht. Irgendwann haben sie es halt abgeschaltet.
Also ich hab ja auch Rumors gehört, dass...
Es gibt keine Stellungnahme von Microsoft dazu und alle fragen sich wieso. Es hat auch keiner bemerkt. Wahrscheinlich wegen massiver Erfolglosigkeit einfach eingestellt worden.
Naja, also heise berichtete, sie hätten das aufgrund von Beschwerden getan.
Was?
Microsoft gibt Datenschutzbedenken deutscher Nutzer als Grund für die Deaktivierung an. Microsoft nehme den Datenschutz und die Privatsphäre seiner Kunden ernst und haben aufgrund geäußter Bedenken einer begrenzten Anzahl deutscher Nutzer zu Verpixelungsanfragen beschlossen, den Street-Site-Beta-Dienst in Deutschland abzuschalten. Heißt es in der Mitteilung aus Redmond, die einzelnen Fälle würden untersucht und an einer Lösung gearbeitet. Ob und wann der Dienst in Deutschland wieder ins Netz geht, bleibt weiter unklar.
Mann, Mann, Mann. Ja.
Ernsthaft?
Das heißt auch nicht verpixeln, sondern vergauschen.
Überrascht dich das jetzt?
Vergauschen.
Ich, naja, also ich mein, das ist irgendwie...
War doch schon vorher das Gleiche mit Google.
Ja, das war mit, aber es war bei Microsoft doch doch keiner mehr überhaupt mitgekriegt, dass das überhaupt stattfand.
Ich wusste auch nicht, dass es das schon in Deutschland gibt.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass es mittlerweile schon auch eine schiere Zahl an Vereinen gibt, deren einziger Lebensinhalt ist, gegen solche...
Die Kategorie von Deutschland zu verhindern.
Ja. Das würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass die einfach, dass sie festgestellt haben, ey, unser Dienst nutzt hier echt keine Sau, lass uns das mal wieder abschalten, haben wir keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Hatten wir das Gerücht hier oder habe ich das woanders gehört, dass es Rumor, dass Microsoft auch Bing generell einstellen will? Okay, habe ich nur gehört irgendwo. Hat mir ein Vögelchen zugezwitschert.
Aha.
Und dieses sinnlose Betriebssystem dann auch gleich mit?
Naja, also ich meine, dieses Bing-Zeug, das zeigt ja zumindest ein bisschen in die Zukunft. Wenn sie das jetzt auch noch abscheiden, das bleibt dann übrig.
Ja, müssen schon ein bisschen, jetzt vielleicht müssen wir schon haben.
Ja, aber bevor wir jetzt wieder den Abgesang von irgendwelchen Firmen hier bekannt geben, sagen wir nochmal kurz beim Thema. Also diese iOS 6 Maps-Geschichte, ich glaube, das könnte das einzige Highlight bleiben dieses Jahr. Also sollte man das auch voll genießen, ne? Was ich ja gerne hätte, ist, das Äquivalent zu Google Earth. Wenn sie diesen Kartendienst haben, und wenn sie diese 3D-Bilder haben, dann will ich das nicht nur auf meinem iPhone oder vielleicht auf diesem Familiencomputer Familienbenutzer haben.
Wisst ihr schon?
Dieses Gerät, das sich alle kaufen, wir nicht. Wenn sie da mal Multi-User einbauen, dann kauf ich mir auch nochmal eins. Also so als Uhr ist es super. Ich hab da eins als Uhr. Macht sich eigentlich gut.
Aber sonst, wie auch immer.
Zu den Maps hab ich noch.
Ich will gerne Apple... Wie würden die das nennen? Apple Earth, würden sie das ja wohl kaum nennen.
Steve's World, Steve's World.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Ich meine, Google Earth gibt's jetzt wie lange?
Ja, weil das nutzt auch kein Schwein, oder?
Ich nutz das.
Wofür nutzt du's denn?
Wenn du näher ranzooms, ist doch eh alles wieder 2D-mäßig. Dann hat's auch gleich Maps.
Was ist dann 2D-mäßig? Da gibt's auch 3D.
Das ist inzwischen nicht mehr scheiße.
Das User-Interface ist immer noch total scheiße. Und die Performance ist auch immer noch total scheiße.
Du hast ja die Google-Updates-Scheiße am Hals und so.
Aber ich bitte dich, was ist die Alternative zu Google Earth, wenn du dir mal anschauen willst, wie es irgendwo aussieht?
Nee, doch nicht. Aber ich hab keinen Bock auf diese Google-Updates-Scheiße.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht das, was jetzt an die meisten davon abhält.
Aber wofür nutzt es denn tatsächlich mal?
Wofür ich das nutze? Um mir von der Geographie von bestimmten Orten einen Eindruck zu verschaffen. Ganz einfach. Wenn von irgendwas die Rede ist, wo gerade mal wieder eine Bombe hochgegangen ist, dann schaue ich mir mal die Stadt an und versuche ein Gefühl dafür zu entwickeln.
Wie es mal gewesen ist.
Oder jetzt hier Japan, Desaster, die ganzen Orte, die da genannt wurden. Ich habe die japanische Küste, glaube ich, zehn, zwanzig Mal abgeflogen. Und auch vorher, nachher Geschichten gibt es da ja dann teilweise auch mit diesen einklinkbaren KML, KMZ-Networklinks etc. Dann hast du Live-Tracking. Du kannst ja da irgendwie Flugzeug- Live-Tracking rein machen. Es gibt Live-Tracking in Google Earth für Satelliten. Der Start von Raketen hier von Space Shuttle haben sie irgendwie live in Google Earth reingepumpt. Also es gibt da eine ganze Menge coole Anwendungen, die ich auch immer mal wieder an denen ich partizipiere. Glaub ich. Google Earth ist eine tolle Idee, aber ich hätte es halt ganz gerne. Ich hätte gerne den Apple. Sie könnten das Big Apple nennen.
Terravision.
Vielleicht die Erde auch gleich so ein Apple-Form. Sie fragen an welcher Stelle sie was rausbeißen.
In Berlin gibt es noch keinen Apple Store.
Aber ich hab hier noch eine Frage an alle. Und zwar ist mir bei meinen Maps irgendwie aufgefallen, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel letztens den Weg nach Köln wissen wollte, und dann hab ich Köln eingetippt und dieses Scheiß Maps hat Köln nicht gefunden, weil mein iPhone ist auf Englisch eingestellt. Und ich könnte schwören, dass es früher funktioniert hat. Aber irgendwie jetzt seit einer Weile findet der, weil mein iPhone ja auf Englisch eingestellt ist, nur noch englische Städte Namen.
Nee, mein iPhone ist auch auf Englisch eingestellt.
Was meinst du, das hat mich dann halt nur bei Köln erwischt, aber ich hab auch andere Sachen nicht mehr gefunden?
Da hast du irgendwas anderes bei deinem Maps verkonfiguriert.
Bist du sicher? Also ich muss jetzt irgendwie mein iPhone auf Deutsch umstellen, weil ich nichts mehr gefunden hab.
Meins hat eben gerade Köln problemlos gefunden.
Deutsch oder Englisch?
Englisch eingestellt und er zeigt es auf Englisch an, also er zeigt Cologne, aber ich hab Köln eingegeben. Und jetzt kann ich dahin, aber was soll ich in Köln?
Also hier, guck mal, ich hab gerade K-O-E-L-N eingetippt und bang, Cologne. Also du machst was falsch.
Naja, ich stell ja wieder um.
Die Stimme aus dem Off.
Wieso kam das aus dem Off?
Weil es zu laut war, der hat sich gleich weggeregelt. Der Kompressor hat gleich...
Der hat seine Arbeit getan.
Da musste dein Mikrofon noch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Seht ihr, dann haben wir das auch gleich wieder geklärt.
Ist doch schön.
Feierabend.
Funktioniert es denn jetzt bei dir auch?
Ich muss erstmal die Sprache wieder wechseln, es dauert.
Was war jetzt der Grund, das hab ich nicht verstanden. Wir müssen mal die Mate aus dem Kühlschrank holen.
Ich hol die mal gleich. Der Grund war...
Ist die Mate über euch gelaufen?
So, iOS6 sagste, also ist jetzt das, worauf wir uns einstimmen müssen, wo wir unsere ganze Euphorie, unsere Angestaute, die wir zurückhalten, sozusagen.
Stellst du vielleicht das Lokale nicht um, oder? Also dieser...
Lass uns nochmal auf iOS6 fokussieren. iOS6.
Ja, aber da gibt's nix zum Fokussieren. Ich meine, wir wissen alle, was wir haben wollen, aber...
Was wollen wir denn alle haben?
Multi-User fürs iPad.
Multi-User fürs iPad will ich gar nicht.
Ich möchte auf keinen Fall Multi-User fürs iPad.
Juni, Anfang Juni?
Am 9. fliegen wir, 10., 11., 12., 12. glaube ich.
10.,
12. fängt sie an und dann 13., bis Freitag.
Du bist unser einziger Vertreter?
Also glaube ich, oder?
Ja, ich bin nicht da. Machen wir eine Live-Schalte?
Ich probiere das mal auf jeden Fall, klar. Können wir Facetime-Mofonieren?
Nehm dir ein bisschen Bier mit.
Hier so richtig, also ich meine...
Du kannst dann den Koch mit dem Schalen Bier, mit dem Essigbier übergießen, falls er keine Sensationen zu präsentieren hat.
Dann berichte ich garantiert nicht mehr.
Zu viel Koch verdirbt den Brei.
Da ist ja auch EM.
Wie interessiert denn sowas?
Ganz ne Menge Leute.
Das sind die gern eh nicht zur Hörerschaft hier.
Aber zum Programm.
Wie zum Programm?
Ich guck Fußball. Ja, wenn es um was geht, kann man schon mal gucken.
So Abviertelfinale oder wie?
Wenn der Schweinsteiger Wein sehen wollte.
Ja, ja, das auch immer.
Hauptsache Blut.
Das geht nicht, ihr Jungs.
So, übrigens, heute vor 23 Jahren.
Ja, Karl Koch und so.
Ja, krass.
Mit?
Das ist 23 Jahre, ja. Was hast du an dem Tag getan, als der Todesstern zerstört wurde? So ist das so ein bisschen für mich.
Am 23.05.
wann denn sonst?
89, ja.
Gab es noch keinen Eikarl, kann ich jetzt nicht nachducken.
89.
Das Facebook hat noch nicht mitgeschnitten.
Ach, sie wissen nicht mehr genau, wann er gestorben ist.
IOS 6 auf jeden Fall hochspannend.
Wir sind alle, wir sind alle sehr immer berichtet.
Gibt es irgendeinen Feature, was ihr euch wünscht?
Außer Multi-User?
Auf dem IOS, außer Multi-User?
Besseres Sharing, so innerhalb der einzelnen Apps. Default Browser wechseln.
Default Browser wechseln?
Default Clients für alles Mögliche. Also Sharing, wie das bei den anderen Telefon-USen überall geht. Dass man so sagen kann, hier, ich hab ein Bild. Kann jemand was mit einem Bild anfangen? Dass man dann direkt auswählen kann, hey, ja. Eine andere App, die dann das Bild aufmachen kann.
Du meinst schon fast schon so eine Art Finder denn auf dem iPhone?
Nee, kein Finder. Nee, eher Services.
Also du hast deine Bilder dann nicht auch so filesystemmäßig, weil das wollen sie nicht, sondern du hast sie halt weiterhin in deiner Bildersammlung und so weiter und so fort. Und da drin kannst du klicken, dann aber jetzt öffnen mit so und so.
Ja, weil es ist ja also dieses total Nervige, dass ich, dass jede App, die irgendwo kommt und die was mit einer URL machen kann, muss dann all die Dienste implementieren wie Instapaper und Pocket und weiß der Teufel was und die ganzen Pinboard und diese ganzen Dienste müssen überall eingebaut werden. Es gibt dieses furchtbare Sharekit, also dieses Toolkit, was das dann irgendwie halbautomatisiert und Spaß macht das nicht. Das soll besser sein, das geht besser. Sollen sie mal besser machen?
Also ich weiß nicht so richtig, was Dringendes gibt's gar nicht mehr. Also sie haben so die wirklich wichtigen Sachen echt abgefeiert. Das einzige, wo echt noch eine Lücke klafft, ist Maps, finde ich. Weil da ist halt auch wirklich wenig passiert.
Ja, Maps ist letztens schon mal ganz schön durch. Also sie haben keine Turn-by-Turn-Navigation nach wie vor. Also das ist ja nun bei Android auch schon seit Jahren dabei, dass man eine Navigation drinne hat.
Als wenn sie eh schon auf Maps unterwegs sind und Directions angeben müssen. Sie müssen ja mindestens das Featureset bieten, was sie jetzt auch haben. Von daher müssen sie ja eigentlich Turn-by-Turn anbieten. Mindestens als textuelle oder 2D-Variante und vielleicht auch 3D-Variante.
Wofür kaufst du so eine 3D-Bude, die so 3D-Darstellung von so einem Zeug machen kann? Es mag natürlich sein, dass sie daraus jetzt irgendeine tolle Maps-Applikation machen, aber ich nehme an, dass der Hauptgrund dafür sein wird, dass sie irgendwie den Kontext vernünftig reinbringen wollen. Dass du irgendwie die Straße auch auf der du bist vor dir und sowas, siehst da die Kreuzung und siehst auch die Häuser und weiß der Teufel was. Dass das eher in die Richtung gehen soll.
Die Apple Stores. Wahrscheinlich kann man nur zu Apple Stores sich irgendwie leiten lassen.
Das wäre praktisch. Mehr braucht man eh nicht.
Ja, wollen wir das Depri-Thema gleich nach vorne holen?
Was ist denn das Depri-Thema? Oder welches Depri-Thema meinst du?
Oder wollen wir erst mal das größere iPhone philosophieren?
Ein iPhone wäre natürlich auch ein Grund, ein iOS 6 rauszubringen.
Ein neues iPhone muss auf jeden Fall dafür Anpassung haben, ist ja klar.
Und für ein altes iOS wird es dann auf dem größeren iPhone nicht mehr geben, also... Was habe ich gesagt? Ich habe Unsinn erzählt.
Nimm lieber eins, was erst seit zwei Monaten abgelaufen ist.
Und hör auf mit dem Elefanten zu sprechen.
Also, es gibt die gerüchte Lage, dass sich der Bildschirm irgendwie vergrößert. Das ist alles etwas widersprüchlich. Manche reden von 4 Zoll in unterschiedlichen Bruchzahlen-Varianten. Und dann gibt es da die von Gruber geleitete Debatte, ob es sich nur um eine Verlängerung des Bildschirms handelt oder auch um eine Vergrößerung.
Der hat ja auch nur den Link von woanders aufgegriffen. Also der Bericht war eigentlich woanders. Und der meinte irgendwie, die Breite bleibt 6,40. Also die bleibt gleich, aber die Höhe geht von, wo sind wir gerade, von 960 oder was? Auf 1136. Deswegen die Anspielung an TAX 1136 hat er geschrieben. Weil es gibt ja den Film TAX 1138, egal. Das macht deswegen Sinn, meinte der Gruber dann auch, nachdem man mal drüber nachgedacht hat, weil wenn man das auf 1136 macht, das ist erstens knapp 16 zu 9 ziemlich genau.
Es ist einfach 16 zu 9.
Und zweitens wäre das dann von der Diagonale trotzdem halt genau 4 Inch, also 4 Zoll.
Man würde im Homescreen, glaube ich, auch noch eine Reihe Icons genau unternehmen.
Ja, was hat er geschrieben? 176 Pixel mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch war ein Pixel? 56 Punkte oder so hast du?
Ach du Scheiße, wie viel ist jetzt die Icon-Größe?
Also wenn es wirklich 176 mehr sind, das ist ja schon ein Fünfte, dann müsste da ja schon noch eine Reihe hinpassen, denke ich. Das könnte sein, ja.
Ja, aber ich meine, davon hängt es nicht ab. Also dann machen sie einen Abstand größer oder kleiner.
Ich denke, das würde auch passen, aber ich glaube, dass der Vorteil für Apple wäre, also eine Menge Programme, auch die ich mal so gekodet habe, und das kennt ihr ja so mit Table-Views und so, da müsste man wahrscheinlich gar nichts machen, sondern die zeigen einfach unten ein paar Rows irgendwie mehr an. Und das wäre schon ziemlich cool. Also ich glaube, es wäre sehr einfach anzupassen.
Also wie viel länger würde denn dann der Bildschirm werden, wenn er genauso breit ist?
Na, da war auch ein Bild dabei und es sah auch echt so aus, als könnte man sich das vorstellen.
Also zwischen einer Fingerbreite und einer Daumenbreite ungefähr.
So eine Reihe bei den üblichen Apps, oder so bei einem Mehl, so eine Mehl mehr und sowas. Also ich bin da nach wie vor eher skeptisch aus dem simplen Grund, dass ich... Also was hätten sie damit gewonnen? Hätten ein bisschen mehr Pixel nach oben hin?
Sie könnten halt mit 4 Zoll werben.
Na ja, gut, wir würden sie werben.
Na ja, aber guck mal, alle hier Samsunger kommen mit diesen riesengroßen Kloppern raus und das zieht bei den Leuten schon, bis sie es natürlich dann in der Tasche haben und dann sagen sie, na ja, war jetzt zwar geil groß, aber meine Tasche hat jetzt boilen. Aber es ist zu spät, weil sie haben es ja schon gekauft. Und Apple kann vielleicht so ein bisschen mithalten, indem sie sagen, na klar, 4 Zoll ist kein Problem, haben wir auch und das Ding ist aber gleich groß wie vorher und du hast nicht irgendwie so einen riesen Klopper am Arsch.
Also ich kann dir sagen, was sie davon, also was auf der Pro-Seite steht, wenn ich mir das so anschaue, jetzt sehe ich das Bild auch. Ja, das kann durchaus hinhauen. Also mehr Platz ist ja in dem Sinne erstmal kein...
Nicht schlecht.
Kein Fehler, so. Was ich lange bezweifelt habe, dass sie was ändern ist, dass sie natürlich einen riesen Vorteil davon haben, dass es derzeit eben nur genau dieses eine Layout gibt. So, jetzt ist der Bildschirm aber 16 zu 9. Ich meine, wofür man 16 zu 9 gut gebrauchen kann, bräuchte ich auch nicht zu sagen. Wenn man sich jetzt Filme darauf anschaut, dann passt es halt genau drauf.
Ja, aber jetzt musst du wieder begleichbrüllen. Ich aber ansonsten, außer dir guckt niemand Filme auf dem iPhone, glaube ich.
Ich habe noch nie einen Film auf dem iPhone geguckt.
Na ja, aber wir gucken schon eine Menge Filme auf dem iPhone, nur halt nicht Spielfilme, sondern YouTube, kleine Schnipsel und all so ein Zeug.
Ja, und wie werden die gedreht? In 4 zu 3 am meisten?
Ne, die Zeiten sind echt vorbei.
Und die werden meistens mit dem iPhone gedreht? Und wie dreht das iPhone in 4 zu 3?
Das ist dann nicht mehr. Also, ich glaube für Spielfilme ist das jetzt nicht so der entscheidende Grund, aber grundsätzlich mehr Bildschirm, glaube ich, ist gut.
Es gibt ja auch genug Momente, wo die Höhe auch in iOS für dich eine Rolle spielt. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Call im Hintergrund hast oder aufnimmst oder Tethering anhast, dann nimmt der der ab von oben, Platz weg.
Hast du letztens mal einen Screenshot gesehen, den ich gepostet habe? Da hatte ich irgendwie Personal Hotspot, dadurch kommt ja dieser grüne Balken oder der blaue oben zusätzlich und alles verschob sich ein Stück und sie haben im Maps, wenn man das so aufklappt, irgendwie einen Button falsch gesetzt, so dass der halt irgendwie, der war oben halt connected und deswegen zu weit unten.
Was ist eigentlich, wenn man Recorded und einen Hotspot anhat?
Dann rutscht alles noch weiter runter und dann wird's noch schlimmer.
Man hat immer nur eine Laster.
Ich pack den Link mal in den Chat, dann könnt ihr damit schauen.
Aber es gibt ja auch, was ja kaum jemand weiß, es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche hohe Tastaturen. Die japanische Tastatur ist ja ein bisschen höher als die anderen. Damit rechnet auch...
Genau, also Tastatur ist auch so ein Ding, immer wenn die Tastatur eingeblendet wird, dann geht einfach extrem viel.
Das stimmt, das ist tatsächlich ein Argument.
Insbesondere in Landscape, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich benutze das.
Vielleicht machen die auch unten so einen Statusbar-Dings dauerhaft hin und wollen den gesamten Space gar nicht für Programme.
Ihr wollt jetzt wirklich darüber reden, warum man einen größeren Screen haben will?
Man will immer einen größeren Screen haben.
Ja, wir reden darüber, wofür?
Es gibt Bros und Cons und das sind alles Bros.
Aber was sind die Cons?
Die Cons sind natürlich grundsätzlich, wenn man jetzt größeres Screen, so wie das in der Android-Welt verbreitet ist, im Sinne von das Ding dehnt sich in X und in Y aus, dann hast du dann irgendwann das Problem, dass du halt mit dem Finger nicht mehr rankommst. Wobei diese Vergrößerung, diese minimale Vergrößerung, würde die Navigation mit dem Finger jetzt kaum einschränken. Also ich komm da oben auch noch eine ganze Zeile weiter nach oben und gut, es gibt auch Leute mit kleineren Händen, aber das ist denke ich noch so im Bereich. Das ist natürlich hart für Entwickler, wobei sie natürlich jetzt, wenn du eine App startest, die noch nicht auf die Größe angepasst ist, ähnlich wie sie das auf dem iPad auch machen, einfach oben schwarz lassen.
Was wie nochmal?
Na das war einfach oben oder unten. Das ist nicht aufblasen, sondern das war einfach letterboxing.
Schwarze Balken, genau.
Also die ganzen Spiele vor allen Dingen.
Damit bestehende Apps.
Ja, wenn du mehr Pixels hast, als dein Programm einfüllen zu können, dann musst du ja mit den anderen was machen.
Also meistens im Emulationsmodus bist du auf dem iPad oder was?
Nee, auf dem iPhone. Wenn du auf einem 16 zu 9-iPhone bist und eine 4 zu 3-App öffnest, was soll dann passieren? Die kann sicher nicht einfach die ganzen...
4 zu 3?
Ja, jetzt bin ich voll raus.
Naja, wenn du auf einem normalen...
Welche 4 zu 3-App?
Eine normale iPhone-App.
Jede, alle.
Jede App, die du derzeit hast.
Alle. Es gibt keine, die für 16 zu 9 gemacht sind.
Wie für 69 x 45?
69 x 46.
Genau, einfach so wie es jetzt ist.
Genau, wenn die dafür gemacht sind, die müssen ja auch weiterhin irgendwie funktionieren. Die werden sie ja nicht einfach oben länger machen.
Das ist schon klar. Ihr meintet, dass es beim iPad irgendwie schon so gemacht wird.
Nein, da machen sie ja mit Spinn und iPhone Apps.
Im Sinne von einer Simulation. Die App befindet sich an einem Ort, von der sie eigentlich gar nicht weiß, dass sie da ist.
Hören sie auch nächstes Mal wieder zu, wenn Obermeck sich gegenseitig probiert, naheliegende Dinge zu erklären.
Genau.
Wie auch immer. Du hast schon alles verstanden, was du verstehen musstest und die Hörer sind ohnehin schon 5 Minuten weiter.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Skip, skip, skip.
So, das heißt, die Developer müssten nicht unbedingt sofort nachziehen. Könnten aber.
Naja, das würde natürlich wieder relativ schnell gehen. Das ist, da hab ich keine Zweifel.
Wahrscheinlich ist das auch der Grund, warum wir das genau jetzt sehen, damit das schon mal so ein Hint ist. Und Apple, Jungs, hier guckt nochmal genau hin. Könnte sein.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn Apple wirklich nur die Höhe vergrößert, dann wird das Bottle-Neck nicht die Developer, sondern der Approval-Prozess vom App-Store.
Naja, außerdem muss man die ganzen Default-Bilder auswechseln, bei Spielen musst du komplett neu denken.
Bei Spielen ja, aber bei allem, was so eine normale App ist, dann machst du die Tabelle länger und fertig ist die Lager. Das ist irgendwie alles kein Thema.
Gäbe es die Möglichkeit, das App sich automatisch anzupassen? Kann man eine iOS-App so schreiben, wenn sie so generisch nur mit Listen und so weiter ist, dass sie sich sogar automatisch anpasst?
Das ist doch jetzt schon so.
Ja, müsste heute eigentlich auch schon sein. Also wenn eine App darauf vorbereitet, dass es ja ganz kleiner wird, ist sie dann automatisch darauf eingestellt, dass sie größer wird?
Du musst ja eigentlich damit rechnen, dass er nach unten kleiner wird. Du nimmst ja das Frame, du hast ja ein View und da packst du dich halt rein. Also bei so einem Table-View machst du ja gar nichts. Da sagst du einfach hier Table-View.
Genau, da ist unten einfach ein Roam Air oder zwei.
Dann ist da ein Roam Air, das wäre überhaupt kein Problem. Und das übliche Zeug mit irgendwelchen Web-Views oder sowas, das würde auch alles gehen. Also von der Anpassung her, so bei den üblichen List Detail-View-Sachen, wäre das wahrscheinlich, falls da überhaupt eine Anpassung notwendig ist, minimal.
Ein Taschenrechner müsste Apple vielleicht was machen, weil der ist halt genau angepasst auf die Größe, aber alles andere.
Und dann gibt es natürlich so Spiele und so ein Zeug, das müsste wahrscheinlich dann je nachdem sehr stark weniger stark angepasst werden. Was ich ja finde, was durchaus gegen eine höhere Auf-… also gegen so ein 16. zum neuen Modus spricht, ist, was machen sie im Landscape-Format? Weil, also im Landscape finde ich, ist das Problem nicht, dass ich zu wenig Breite habe, sondern dass es zu wenig Höhe ist, insbesondere wenn die Tastatur eingeblendet wird, weil wenn die Tastatur eingeblendet wird, dann hat man schon jetzt da so einen total schmalen Streifen dran.
Naja, da ist natürlich links und rechts auch mehr Platz.
Naja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie die Tastatur irgendwie in die Mitte packen würden oder sowas, also dass sie links und rechts noch einen schmalen Streifen machen, den du dann mit Apps befüllen kannst. Also sie würden die Tastatur wahrscheinlich wieder über die gesamte Breite machen, ist meine Vermutung. Weil auf dem iPad gibt es das ja, diese geteilte Tastatur. Und wer das mal ausprobiert, wie viele Apps das tatsächlich unterstützen, das geht gegen Null. Also die damit vernünftig umgehen können mit der gespaltenen Tastatur auf dem iPad.
Also unterstützen im einigen Sinne muss man das nicht.
Nee, das macht die von alleine, aber es sieht mitunter scheiße aus.
Genau.
Also ich meine, genau genommen ändert sich ja auch in der Breite für die Landscape, also schlechter als jetzt ist es nicht.
Na doch, entweder die Tasten bleiben genauso hoch wie sie sind und werden einfach alle breiter, also dass sich quasi das Format der Tastatur ändert, oder sie behalten die Proportionen gleich, dann wird eher noch weniger Platz für den Content da bleiben, weil dann muss sie höher werden.
Oder sie machen noch mehr Tasten dazu, vielleicht eine LUU-Taste.
Ja, das haben sie ja auch schon beim iPad nicht gemacht.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir uns keinen Kopf zabrechen, da wird denen schon was einfallen.
Es gab ja eine iOS 5 Beta, war ja schon LUU drin auf der normal schmalen Tastatur. Da gab es eine German-Tastatur mit Umlauten. Ich hatte mich so schnell dran gewöhnt. Und dann haben sie plötzlich wieder rausgeschmissen.
Die Schweine. Äppelschweine.
Das waren noch zu Steves Zeiten. Also insofern, ich bin da noch nicht so ganz sicher. Und zum Fotos angucken, Fotos sind im Wesentlichen ein 4 zu 3 Format. Das bringt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel, das auf dem Display zu machen. Und wenn, dann könntest du das Display auch gleich komplett ein bisschen größer machen.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, sie müssen was machen. Das bringt nicht viel.
Mehr Platz heißt mehr Platz. Ich meine, das ist auch für ein 4 zu 3 Foto gut, weil wenn du da reinzooms, dann siehst du halt mehr.
Entweder hast du Letterboxing oder du hast halt irgendwas abgeschnitten.
Oder du hast Meta-Information zu deinem Foto unten.
Oder Bilderrahmen. Apple könnte hübsche, geschmackvolle Bilderrahmen drum rum.
Ja, genau so.
Look at these Bilderrahmen, aren't they awesome? Genau, mit einer High Frame ab, wo du dann irgendwie selber deine Bilderrahmen noch gestalten kannst.
Nachdem man sie durch den Review-Prozess durchbekommen hat.
Aber die haben doch immer diese Dia-Shows, die sie immer Stunden zeigen auf solchen Veranstaltungen. Da werden so Bilderrahmen, könnte man auch Stunden zeigen.
Ich bin gespannt, wie spannend diese Keynote wird. Bisher hatten sie noch die Chance, komplett langweilig zu sein, aber jetzt...
Müssen sie liefern, Meise.
Müssen sie liefern. Es muss mindestens so spannend sein, wie Steve eine Stunde beim Alphoto demonstriert.
Ich weiß, das ist ja nicht mehr gerne gehört, aber Peek Apple war schon... Na ja, mal gucken. Der Cook wird das ja nicht selber machen. Der wird hier wieder alle... Wie heißt der Typ? Den Scott Forster irgendwie vorschicken und so?
Ihr könnt ja einen Facebook-Podcast machen.
Der Bertrand Salé oder wie heißt es nicht mehr da?
Wo darüber spekuliert wird, ob in Facebook endlich mal die Notifications vernünftig funktionieren.
Also bisher habe ich ja den Rest der Industrie immer nur bemitleidet. Aber langsam werde ich richtig sauer. Ja, jetzt haben sie irgendwie Apple... Wie lange? Seit wann gehen die irgendwie durch die Decke? Zehn Jahre? Sie haben ja einfach eine komplette Dekade einfach freien Lauf gelassen. Und keiner ist irgendwie nennenswert mit Innovation hinterher getrabt. Und jetzt haben wir das. Jetzt wird Apple langsam bekloppt. Und es ist nichts da, wo man hinwechseln kann. Ich meine damals irgendwie dein Atari war scheiße, naja dann bist du halt auf eine andere Heimcomputerplattform gegangen. Gab ja noch Commodore irgendwie.
War auch scheiße, aber gab's noch.
Na ja, es nahm sich, also es war nicht so, ich meine man kann jetzt viel über Atari ST versus Amiga sagen, aber so jede Plattform hatte irgendwie was und man kann jetzt nicht sagen, die eine war der anderen umwelten voraus. Die Firma hat hundertmal so viel verdient und konnte alles doppelt so billig produzieren. Und in der Situation sind wir jetzt, es gibt irgendwie Apple und Lama.
So war es ja früher, PC und den Rest.
Ja, aber PC waren die Lama.
Ja, aber die haben zumindest aufgeholt irgendwie. Ich meine, ich weiß noch genau, als ich das erste Mal so ein Windows NT vor meiner Nase hatte, irgendwie daneben mein Crashing des Mac OS, was war das damals?
7.5?
5.1, 7.5?
Diese ganzen 7.5 Zustände, ja. Und mein Windows sah zwar scheiße aus, aber es ist zumindest nicht abgestürzt. Also zumindest nicht so abgestürzt. So, und da war wie klar, da ist irgendwie Competition in the Field und Apple wird eine harte Zeit haben und die hatten sie ja dann auch. So, haben sich halt wieder gefangen, aber jetzt fängt sie halt keiner ein. Ja.
Aber es kommt doch bald Windows 8?
Das hatten wir ja schon, das Thema.
Dale hat ja davor gewarnt, mal angenau euphorisch zu sein, was die Windows-8-Verkaufszahlen angeht. Ich meine, es liegt ein schlechtes Jahr vor uns und ne, Windows wird es nicht besser machen. Das ist verbreitet von purem Optimismus.
Immerhin sehen sie die Sache relativ realistisch.
Ein Drama.
Das hat ja alles keinen Sinn.
Wir sollten das ganze Computer-Thema nochmal begraben.
Ich frage mich, welche Firma Apple denn jetzt kaufen kann, damit sie wieder einen CEO haben.
Keiner kann Apple kaufen.
Wir haben doch gut einen CEO.
Nein, nicht wer kauft Apple, sondern wen kauft Apple? Damit sie wieder einen ordentlichen CEO haben, der wieder Visionen hat.
Aber sie kaufen doch keine Firma, um einen CEO zu kaufen. Dann kaufen sie sich den CEO.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es bei Apple derzeit an Visionen mangelt.
Das glaube ich auch nicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass der Cook da in einer falschen Stelle ist. Der sitzt da schon ganz richtig. Er sollte vielleicht aber andere Leute die Keynotes machen lassen. Wir sollten sich vielleicht einen einkaufen, der die Keynote macht.
Ich weiß nicht, also den Teil, den er übernimmt, den hat jetzt Steve auch nicht sehr viel spannender gestaltet.
Zum Schluss zumindest.
Wo er iWorks vorgestellt hat?
Ich meine den Business-Teil. Also das, was der Cook wirklich macht, ist immer nur dieses hier, was wir verkauft haben.
Der Cook macht das einfach zu trocken als echt, als wenn die Milliarden für den so ein Trinkgeld sind.
Also als Steve schon am Krückstock gegangen ist, da hat er nochmal hier irgendwie iCloud präsentiert, als wäre es wirklich gut. Als wäre es gut und wäre die Zukunft und wäre das Beste, was Apple je gemacht hat. Und so bringt der Tim da nichts rüber.
Das kannst du mir nicht vorstellen.
Der ist einfach zu trocken.
Habe ich die damals, die iPad 3 Keynote? Die kann ich mich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so weit erinnern.
iPad 3 damals? Du meinst jetzt vor zwei, drei Wochen?
Na ja, im März war das.
Damals. Damals kurz nach dem Krieg, als iPad 3 rauskam.
Ja, weiß ich nicht mehr. Ach egal, ich glaube, das kriegt er schon hin. Ich glaube, der muss seinen eigenen Stil entwickeln. Der wird halt nicht diese Fokussierung auf diese eine Person haben, das ist sowieso, sondern der wird mehr mit anderen...
Ja, der soll diesen Scott Forster vorschicken und noch ein paar andere da und dann wird es schon...
Und noch ein LSD nehmen.
Und der macht dann quasi im Wesentlichen... Der macht im Wesentlichen den Host, der so ein bisschen am Anfang die geilen Geschäftszahlen verkündet und darüber hinaus sollen die Leute machen, die es gemacht haben. Ich glaube, das krieg ich schon ganz gut.
Ich finde, er ist aber auch besser geworden. Er war noch viel, viel trockener.
Es ist auch kein leichter Job, da irgendwie in die Swoosh-Schlafen zu drücken.
Garantiert nicht.
Gerade denn noch, wenn er den nicht nur ablöst, sondern wenn der Typ auch noch eine Weile vorher verstorben ist und die sich auch noch gut kannten und so weiter. Und das ist wahrscheinlich so easy.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass die... Also ich meine, was sie da gemacht haben, als die Mountainline vorgeführt haben. Also als es dann so kam, da haben sie ja diese Einzel-Keynotes gemacht.
Diese Mini-Presse-Dinger da, ja?
Das waren ja für einzelne Pressevertreter, wo ja auch hier John Gruber dabei war und so. Und wo ja offensichtlich, wer war das von denen? Phil Schiller hier so diese ganzen Keynotes gehalten hat. Und die probieren glaube ich schon ein bisschen, sind da auf der Suche nach ihrem Weg und das wird besser werden. Ich lobe an dich, Tim.
Also entweder brauche ich einen anderen Namen oder so gibt es echt nichts. Ich brauche einen neuen CEO.
Ach, das bist du.
Tja, ich könnte nochmal was eingehen, was Apple tatsächlich mal released hat. Also Abteilung Neuigkeiten, die vielleicht auch keine sind. Oder haben wir da letztes Mal schon drüber gesprochen? Ich glaube nicht. Na die Podcast-Spezifikationen von Apple, die sogenannten iTunes Extensions.
Ach, ich habe das noch gar nicht gelesen.
Die haben sich mal wieder verändert nach fünf Jahren. Und ist jetzt auch echt nicht sonderlich exciting. Aber ich denke, man kann es an dieser Stelle einfach mal erwähnen. Sie haben, also ihr wisst, wovon ich rede, das ist so diese XML-Namespace, die man in den Podcast-Feeds mit rein macht und so. Und sie haben jetzt die Vorschriften da eingehend geändert. Also Vorschriften ist gut, die Spezifikation, dass man doch jetzt ganz gerne bei Apples sehen würde, dass man eine Cover Art hat, die 1400 x 1400 Pixel groß ist.
1400 x 1400 Pixel?
1400 x 1400 Pixel.
Und das war es bisher?
600 x 600 Pixel.
Vormals 300 Pixel.
Naja, es muss jetzt halt auf großes Fernseher auch auf, ne?
Auf die Retina MacBooks.
So sieht es aus.
Musste halt noch vom Sofa erkennen können.
Ich freu mir schon.
Ich hätte jetzt auch 1200 auch irgendwie als normal empfunden, dass wir es nochmal verdoppeln irgendwie.
Dann haben sie halt noch ein bisschen aufgerundet.
Das ist sowieso so merkwürdig. Auch diese Icon Size auf dem iPhone, ist das 57 Pixel?
Das liegt dann nur an der Größe, geteilt durch Platz und so. Das passt halt genau hin. Was willst du da machen?
Aber diese Icon Größen, das ist echt ein großer Spaß. Ich habe jetzt mal alle aufgeschrieben, die da so in Frage kommen, weil ich lasse ja gerade an einem Icon basteln. Und das sind so, was sind das für Icon Größen? Ich kann ja mal alle kurz... Was ist das hier? Also auf dem iPhone, 57 Pixel ist die Normalgröße, 114 Retina, 29 Pixel und 58 Pixel. 29 Pixel ist dann so...
Das kleine...
Zum Beispiel in der Suche bei Spotlight. Auf dem iPad sind 72 Pixel, 144 Pixel, 48 Pixel und 96 Pixel.
Also immer die Verdopplung natürlich.
Genau, dann immer noch so. Dann iTunes 512 und ich glaube 1024 sind schon mit dabei. Das heißt wir haben 1, 2, 8, 10 verschiedene Icon Größen für zwei Plattformen.
Aber die Mac Icons sind jetzt glaube ich auch 1024 mal 1024.
Von 300 Kilobyte auf 1,4 MB, das Bild hier, das Preview Bild mit dem Think Different Text da drin. Schon krass, aber... Genau, SSD kaufen Jungs, dann geht das auch schnell.
Passt zwar nicht mehr drauf, aber... Ja, das sind schon viele Icons, die so ein Icon Designer heute total gebasteln muss.
Ist jetzt auch nicht, aber so dramatisch. Also wirklich, wenn es jetzt an 14 Icons scheitert, oder 14 Icon Größen, dann sollte man es vielleicht gleich sein lassen.
Naja, weitere Änderungen in diesen iTunes-Spezifikationen waren, dass man jetzt zu einem Feed auch noch sagen kann, dass er Complete ist. Man kann dann auch die Sortierung der Episoden im Store machen, dass er keine weiteren kommen, dass er abgeschlossen ist. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine Konferenz Recordings hast oder so. Ich weiß bloß nicht genau, was das bedeutet, ob sie das dann anzeigen oder ob sie aufhören dich zu pollen. Vielleicht beides. Was nicht so gut wäre, weil was ist, wenn sich an deinem Archiv was ändert? Ich meine, was ist schon complete? Bin mir also nicht so sicher, ob sie das wirklich zeigen werden.
Also ich muss auch sagen, diese iTunes Extensions stellen sich auf jeden Fall fast schon ein bisschen spannender als diese iOS 6 News heraus. Erzähl uns mehr davon.
Noch mehr? Ich dachte, ihr wollt so full Monty.
Ich habe mir auch jemanden geschickt, da gibt es mich noch was anderes. Ich suche mal raus, ihr könnt das schon mal ein bisschen weiter machen.
Ich habe ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass die Menschen, die mich an der YouTube-Karte und die Leute, die mir die Videos ansehen, dass sie mir die Videos ansehen, dass sie mir die Videos ansehen, haben ja heute so einen USB-Anschluss und so einen Raspberry Pi, der wird über USB gepowert. Und dass man einfach den an den USB-Port von dem Fernseher dran hängt, den mit Gaffa hinten an den Fernseher dran pappt und dass der dann sobald man den Fernseher anmacht, automatisch der Raspberry Pi angeht, dass man den nicht separat powern muss. Das wäre eigentlich schon ganz cool.
Und dann?
Wieso willst du, dass der Raspberry Pi angeht, wenn du den Fernseher anmachst?
Damit mein Media Center angeht, wenn ich meinen Fernseher anmache. Ist doch naheliegend, oder?
Das willst du auf dem Raspberry Pi fahren, dein Media Center.
Ja, natürlich.
Auf 800 Megahertz.
Ein YouTube-Video.
Der soll doch ein Problem noch schaffen. Das ist ja nun auch nichts.
Ich bin noch skeptisch.
So ein iPhone schafft ja noch auch 1080p. Und ich meine, was ist so ein Apple-TV anderes als so ein Raspberry Pi?
Da läuft kein Linux drauf.
Dass ein Apple-Logo draufklebt.
Doch, muss man.
Windows? Also ich bin sehr skeptisch, ob die GUI-Performance usw. ob das wirklich burnt, ob das Spaß macht.
Ich glaube, das kriege ich hin. Also wenn man da so ein Windows-8-Kachedesign am Start hat, in Billig natürlich, aber das soll das Ding ja noch hinkriegen. Ich meine, der kann HD-Videos abspielen.
Und das ist das, was ich von dem Windows-8 erwarte.
Also ich hab so ein Beagle-Board zuhause und hab da mal ein Linux draufgemacht und da muss man schon sehr viel Geduld mitbringen.
Was hat der für einen Prozessor?
Ein Arm. Keine Ahnung, irgendein Arm mit 600 Mhz.
Wir haben Panda-Boards wiederum bei VUGA für unsere Dashboards.
Die nächste Generation.
Ich glaube, hier meint auch gerade ein Panda-Board, da laufen unsere Dashboards quasi drüber. Die hängen da direkt am Display dran. Und da ist auch so ein super runtergestriptes Linux mit einem super runtergestripten Window-Manager. Du klickst auf den Browser und dann macht es so...
Ist das jetzt das Zeichen von langsam oder?
Oh ne, genau so macht er das. Ja, ne, das dauert ewig.
Hat der mechanischen Flash oder warum?
Ja, also es ist wirklich extrem langsam und das Ding hat glaube ich auch, hat das nicht sogar ein Dualcore, das Panda Board? Hat's, ne? Und gut, jetzt ist da auf dem Raspberry Pi noch ein bisschen mehr Grafikwumms drauf angeblich, aber ich will es erstmal sehen, bevor ich es glaube.
Ich will es auch probieren.
Ich denke, die Leute werden sich da schon was einfallen lassen. Ansonsten gibt es hier noch was anderes Schickes, das ist auch ultra klein, heißt Karambola.
Also es gibt schon welche, die haben das schon laufen lassen, hat auch jemanden im linken Chat, also das läuft natürlich schon auf dem Raspberry Pi. Es gibt auch schon eine Beta-Version von diesem OpenELEC. Das OpenELEC, das ist so eine komplette abgeschlossene Disproduktion von XBMC nur für so ein Zeug, ist wohl noch nicht so ganz optimiert, aber ist schon mal relativ vielversprechend.
Du bringst nächstes Mal ein Video mit.
Also hier ist jetzt dieses Carambola, kostet 22 Euro und ist noch kleiner als das Raspberry Pi.
Aber hat 2,4 Gigahertz da einer Schock?
Das ist auch so ein Minicomputer, also das ist jetzt halt nur so ein Modul, der Link, der ist auf der Seite, ansonsten im Chat jetzt. Das ist noch ohne Anschlüsse, man muss das auf so ein IO. Board noch mit draufstecken, das kostet auch noch ein bisschen extra, aber da kann man sich dann halt aussuchen, welche Anschlüsse man haben will und welche nicht. Und das Ding hat auch schon WLAN auf dem Teil jetzt da mit drauf, also das ist schon auch ziemlich cool. Und ich glaube, das war ein MIPS oder so, ich hab keine Ahnung.
WLAN, 22 Euro, kompletter PC mit Grafik auch, oder wie?
Das hat uns damals auch ge-
Auf jeden Fall, die Entwicklung in Richtung Kleinkomputer geht schon gerade ganz schön ab, also weil das ist echt nicht mehr groß.
In der Tat.
Ja, aber zweimal Ethernet und einmal WLAN, ich meine, wozu brauchst du ein Display?
Ja, die bei Atmel, die Jungs, die müssen sich langsam doch echt mal warm anziehen, weil die werden auch jetzt links und rechts von Armen irgendwie überholt.
Solange es den Arduino gibt, geht es denen, glaube ich, noch gut.
Ja, Arduino könnte ich auch eines Tages sagen, weil die haben ja auch ihr eigenes System so ein bisschen. Die haben ja das so ein bisschen ihr C abstrahiert, oder? Mit so eigenen Funktionsbibliotheken. Könnten die nicht eines Tages sagen, alles klar, du codest das gleich, aber jetzt halt von Armen, du merkst eigentlich gar nichts, weil du im Groben das Gleiche, wir haben unsere Lip einfach mal auf Armen umgeschrieben, würde es nicht gehen?
Naja, Lip ist übertrieben, ich meine, du schaltest eh nur Pins ein und aus.
Also ich glaube, Arduino muss sich nicht so sehr viel Sorgen machen.
Nee, aber Atmel.
Der Hersteller des Chips auf dem Arduino?
Ja, das kann...
Wobei denen wahrscheinlich die Powerbiuser auch egal sind, sondern die sowieso nur einen Millionen Stück zahlen und die verkaufen ja auch noch anderen Kram, so ist ja nicht, aber naja, ich denke mal, das macht schon auch eine Menge aus, wo die Leute halt irgendwie mit starten und so, was sie dann auch später einsetzen.
Durchaus ähm...
Ich weiß nicht, was bei Atmel gerade so läuft.
Na, das weiß man immer nicht so, ne?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch eine riesen Lude. Die machen schon auch noch anderen Kram.
Davon ist auszugehen. Ich meine, in welche Richtung die sich entwickeln, ne? Aber die machen auch irgendwie A und AVR. Also das ist halt auch der Pfad. Stellt sich die Frage, ob Intel da noch mal irgendwie eine Chance hat, da rein zu grätschen. Das ist eigentlich eher das.
Ja, die fühlen sich ja auch ein bisschen von arm bedroht, ne? Aber sie kriegen ja Atom ja irgendwie nicht an, ne?
Na, das Geile wäre halt, wenn Atom... Ich wollte mir letztens, weil diese Dashboards bei uns sind so schnarchend langsam mit dem Panda-Board, da dachte ich, alles klar, ey, wir shoppen uns jetzt Atombord mit zwei Display-Outs sozusagen, Ausgängen, ne? Also irgendwie DVI gibt's ja mit Dual-Output. Und dann fiel mir aber ein, ja, scheiße, da brauchst du ja noch so ein großes Netzteil dazu shoppen. Und eigentlich wäre, also wenn sie da so richtig nochmal kicken wollen, wäre es ja cool, wenn sie ein Atombord haben, wo das Netzteil halt irgendwie sinnvoll...
Du gleich schon mit drauf ist.
Oder zumindest nicht so ein fetter Klopper, also nicht so ein ATX-Netzteil halt, ne? Aber sowas gibt's auch gar nicht, oder? Also Chet, wenn ihr irgendwie mal so ein ATX-kompatibles Netzteil in klein findet...
Ja, es gibt diese ganz kleine, aber die sind auch wieder so offen und so. Das sind diese Pico Power-Netzteile und so. Die kosten aber auch wieder ein bisschen was, aber voll sparsam.
Okay.
Aber sowas wäre vielleicht noch mal eine Option.
Ja, von VIA gibt's jetzt auch noch irgendeinen Mini-Arm-PC, der irgendwie... Preise hab ich nicht gelesen. Ist wohl laut Heise, verbraucht er erstaunlich viel Strom. Aber alle machen so kleine PCs.
Ja, ist auch für so Dashboards super. Ich hätte ja eigentlich gerne in der Firma, weil das sind ja jetzt alles so eine großen 24 Zoll-Displays, die da überall in der Wand hängen oder noch größer. Und die machen ja ordentlich Hitze. Und dafür, dass die da nur so einen blöden Graph anzeigen... ist das natürlich eigentlich voll die Verschwendung. Eigentlich wäre geil, wenn es so große E-Ink-Displays geben würde.
Ohne Farbe?
Die gibt es jetzt mit Farbe übrigens. Wie heißt denn diese Firma? Diese Plastic hat mir heute ein Kollege erzählt. Was?
Wird Hintergrund beleuchtet oder was für ein Display?
Naja, wenn die nicht selbst leuchten, dann sieht man die doch scheiße, selbst wenn die Farbe haben.
Aber es gibt angeblich, um es jetzt mal kurz zu sagen, E-Ink-Displays mit Farbe schon, von diesem einen großen E-Ink-Display-Hersteller. Wie heißt denn der? Plastic, irgendwas?
Ja, irgendwie, wie hießen die? Bridgestone, die haben sich aus der Puderdisplay-Produktion wieder verabschiedet.
Aus der was?
Was ist das denn? Das war auch so was wie E-Ink. Bloß halt auch in Farbe und noch mal in Höhe auflösend und alles eigentlich viel besser, aber...
Platylogic...
Plaste- und Elastelogic.
Plastiklogic, genau. Und die hatten vor kurzem Farbe-I-Ink-Displays mal announced.
Was hast du gesagt? Bridgestone ist doch ein Reifenhersteller.
Jaja, die haben aber so...
Machen die jetzt auf Displays?
Offensichtlich.
Und Nokia macht bald wieder auf Reifenhersteller.
So, dann haben sie hier irgendwann mal, gibt's in biegsam und groß und weißte Teufel was, genau von Bridgestone, vom Breichen, aber haben sie eingestellt. Und mal gucken, was da so alles... Die sahen eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht aus, also ich meine so, hier so, ich hab jetzt mal, ich halte das jetzt mal hier in dem Podcast, wenn wir das auf alle im Podcast sehen, dass das jetzt beschreiben, buntes Bildchen auf dem Bilddisplay.
Aber ich glaube nicht, also mich würde das wundern, wenn die Hintergrund beleuchtet werden. Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, wie es geht, ich hab's noch nicht nachgelesen, wäre lustig, wenn das wirklich so Kügelchen mit vier Farben drauf sind und dann sie dann wirklich wie im Druck sozusagen, die Farben dann so irgendwie, oder dann müssten sie die Auflösung noch ein bisschen erhöhen wahrscheinlich.
Oder jede Kugel hat jede Farbe drauf. Achso, das meintest du gerade.
Vier Farben pro Kugel und dann wird die in die richtige Stelle, in die richtige Position. Sie könnten ja auch vier Kugel ziehen sich voneinander ab. Naja, eben nicht. Deswegen müsste die Auflösung höher sein, damit du es dann sozusagen nicht mehr wahrnimmst, dass dann eigentlich in Wirklichkeit vier Kugeln nebeneinander liegen, um einen Farbpunkt dann zu machen.
Aber das war ja sowieso schon jetzt relativ, also ich meine, die haben schon jetzt wesentlich mehr von diesen kleinen E-Ink-Dots, als sie Pixel haben auf so einem Kindle oder sowas. So ein Kindle hat ja auch nur 800 mal 600, aber diese Pünktchen gibt es ja viel mehr von.
Okay, kenne ich mich nicht so mit Ausruf zu geben.
Du hast ja so ein Ding, oder?
Ich habe ein Kindle, ja, und es ist auch super zu lesen, aber ich hätte schon gern auch manchmal Farbe und mehr Platz auch tatsächlich. Ich hätte auch gerne einen größeren Kindle. Naja, zum Lesen öfter den Kindle. Tatsächlich. Aber ich benutze auch gelegentlich mal die Kindle ab auf all meinen Apple-Geräten, um ein Buch, was ich auf dem Kindle schon habe, auch noch auf dem Mac oder iPhone oder iPad zu lesen. Funktioniert auch ganz gut, vor allen Dingen auch ein schönes Feature mit dem Fortschritt-Synken. Da muss man sich gar nicht darum kümmern und dann sagt einem das iPad, ach, übrigens hier auf dem Kindle hast du schon so und so weit gelesen, bumm, zack, Return.
Er blättert für einen weiter.
Genau. Und jetzt hab ich mir ein tolles Buch gekauft, Classic Shellscripting von O'Reilly. Und das hab ich jetzt auch auf allen Geräten schon durchgelesen. Ohne iCloud, ganz ohne iCloud, mit R-Cloud sozusagen.
Durchgekindelt.
Dieses Whisper-Sync.
Ja, was auch immer das ist. Also das ist schön. Also wenn du es halt nicht wissen musst und es einfach funktioniert, super.
Aber der macht das immer noch, das ist aber jedenfalls. Du hast auf einem anderen Gerät bereits bis auf Seite 1200 bis an Position 1539 vorgelesen. Möchtest du an diesem Gerät jetzt auch bis zu dieser Position vorsynchronisieren?
Ja klar, wenn du das gemacht hast, dann fragst du dich das natürlich.
Ja, was ich so für Whisper-Sync, doch also für... Aha, kriegst du gar nicht.
Wenn du auf dem iPad eingeschlafen bist und zufällig bis auf Position 1250 gescrollt hast mit deiner Nase, dann ist das vielleicht eine berechtigte Nachfrage.
So, haben wir den Hardware-Exkurs durch, denke ich mal, oder? Wollen wir uns mal hier über das Depri-Thema unterhalten?
Es sei denn, du willst noch über Retina-Displays auf dem Macs reden, was rumgerüchtet wird.
Was rüchtet sich denn gerade?
Na ja, es wird halt gerüchtet, dass das kommt. Ich meine...
Na ja, es geht jetzt aber auch schon eine Weile, ne?
Ich meine, wenn das käme, wäre das das einzig sinnvolle Feature von Mountain Lion, dass sie das ordentlich einbauen und unterstützen. Aber ansonsten... Was ist mit denen?
Find ich gut.
Endlich wurde Zeit. Endlich machte gut, dass das jemand vernünftig macht.
Ja, ob das wirklich so vernünftig ist, am Ende, das werden wir ja noch zeigen.
Viel schlimmer als Grow kann es ja nicht werden.
Also, du hast schon recht, Tim, man hat jetzt irgendwie echt eine sehr arg reduzierte Erwartungshaltung, wenn es da um Apple und Deliveren geht.
Jaja, das ist echt gar nicht... Also meine 10.7.4 war eine Verbesserung gegenüber 10.7.3, was die Stabilität betrifft. Könnte fast sein, dass es so die erste Version ist, die so halbwegs läuft. Ich weiß nicht, wie eure Erfahrungen so sind.
Naja, bei mir lief es ja schon die ganze Zeit.
Ich trau mich ja gar nicht zu meckern, aber bei mir auch.
Bei dir, Dennis.
Geht so.
Bist du schon auf 10.7.4?
Ja klar, der hat auch noch eine letzte Sendung gemacht.
Ich hab immer noch Abstürze, wenn ich irgendwie mein Display dran hab und dann irgendwie sage Sleep im Menü von Hand. Kommt da ja nicht mit klar, hab ich einen Crash danach.
Wir senden übrigens live aus dem Prenzlauer Berg in Berlin. Falls sich jemand, der Hörer, darüber wundert, warum hier so viel Gugogaga-Tra-La-Fitti aus Kinderkäln durch die Lautsprecher schallt. Ja, es ist warm in Berlin und wir haben das Fenster auf. Also hier schieben sich quasi die Kinderwagen-Kolonnen im Laufschritt vorbei.
Ihr wisst schon, dass das nicht der kinderreichste Stadtteil in Berlin ist.
Ja, ist auch ein Abrilchen, das wissen wir. Macht aber so Spaß. Ja, und das ist auch nur ein minimaler Prozentpunkt. Und nicht wie sie mal behaupten, hier doppelt und dreifach.
Aber Prenzlerwerk ist auch groß und hier konzentriert es sich schon.
Ich glaube, Prenzlerwerk ist weitensgehend durch mit dem Kinderkriegen.
Es ist der Teil Deutschlands, glaube ich, wo sogar die höchste Kinderquote ist, unter Akademikern. Also nirgendswo gibt es so viele Akademiker mit so vielen...
Auch diese News ist interessanter als die iOS6-Rumors. Willkommen in unserem neuen Segment Rumors, die interessanter sind als Apple-Rumors.
Wenn iOS6 wieder so Features hat wie Siri, dann ist es halt nicht so spannend, das soll man machen.
Ja, Siri wird es natürlich schon haben.
Peak-Pregnant-Siri.
Aber du hast ja auch kein A54S.
Vielleicht gibt es ein Siri-Api.
Und du weißt es bloß noch nicht.
Also alle Leute bei VUGA, die ein iPhone S mit Siri haben, fragen, was sie damit machen. Und die Antwort ist meistens ein T-Timer-Stellen. So, dass das funktioniert und das, was viele Leute machen. Und dann gibt es im Anschluss ganz viele Geschichten. Und wenn ich dann sage, ruf mal Mami an, dann kommt das nicht klar und ruft irgendwie Papi an. Also richtig so die Awesome. Hier, ich zeig dir mal, wo du so zu Leuten gehst. Und hier guckt mal hier, Future, hol dir mein iPhone-Alter. Ist nicht, also Siri ist nicht so ein Feature. Oh, ich hab hier mit meinem Erlang-Blog-Post ganz fett abgesandt. Vor vier Wochen oder so hab ich doch diesen Y Erlang, wo ich nicht im Podcast war, aber trotzdem drüber berichtet, war ich ja alleine, glaube ich, 30 Euro oder so.
Really?
Ja, aber ich mach's ja nicht fürs Geld.
Na, wenn er jeden Tag so einen Artikel schreiben würde, würde er 30 Euro am Tag verdienen.
Die fördern sich ja gegenseitig, die Artikel dann.
Genau, ich würde mein Publikum...
Dann könnten sie eventuell 40 werden.
Ich könnte mein Publikum wahrscheinlich steigern, aber ich kauf mir dann stattdessen einfach irgendwie alle halbe Jahre dann ein Gadget. Ich hab ja von meinem letzten Flattr...
Den Kindle gekauft.
Den Kindle gekauft, genau. Ist auch cool.
Ich muss jetzt von meinem Flattr ein Mischpult kaufen.
Und das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts, weil...
Das Geld ist sogar zusammen schon. Aber es ist... Ja, genau, kommen wir aufs eigentliche Thema. Das deprimierende Thema ist wirklich...
Genau, das deprimierende Thema ist schnell gesagt. Instacast hatte eine Flattr-Integration. Die hat auch sofort diesen ganzen Flattr-Markt im Sturm ergriffen. Und die letzten Updates blieben hängen. Und seit heute ist klar, dass Apple da wohl eine ganz klare Meinung hat zu Flattr und die heißt nein. Und im Wesentlichen... Also ich bin mir noch nicht so 100% sicher, wie sie es eigentlich genau definieren. Aber so wie es korreportiert wird, ist deren Einstellung erstmal die. Das ist irgendwie Spendenplattform. Und da gibt es bei uns irgendwie klare Regeln. Und da steht drin, das geht nur mit kostenlosen Apps. Und vielleicht sind die Zweifel sogar noch weitergehend. Also vielleicht ist es einfach, dass sie generell sagen, das ist ein Geldumschlagplatz und der hat bei uns nichts zu suchen. Tschüss! So, mit anderen Worten, es ist absehbar, dass es zumindest in der nächsten Zeit keine Apps geben wird mit Flattr-Integration, die über den iOS oder Mac App Store sogar auch vertrieben werden.
Man kann ja mal auf der WWDC das entsprechende Team ein bisschen beschimpfen.
Das wird sicherlich stattfinden, ob das so viel bringen wird. Da habe ich meine Zweifel und ich denke, die Zweifel teilt ihr auch. Wie es eben so ist, Apple kann Flattr total egal sein. Ihr Business wird sich für sie nichts ändern.
Ja, aber sie haben eigentlich auch nichts davon, es zu verbieten. Insofern, bei solchen...
Doch, sie zeigen eine klare Kante gegen alle Versuche, ihr Bezahlmodell auf irgendeine Art und Weise auszuhebeln. Ob das jetzt in diesem Fall gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, das sei mal offen. Ich denke, man hätte auch eine Argumentation finden können, wenn der entsprechende Goodwill da wäre. Also wenn Apple jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen seelisch erwärmt, da dem Flattr sich da an die Schulter lehnt. Aber das tun sie halt nicht.
Ich hab das Gefühl, dass gerade so bei diesem Appstore, dass da öfters mal auch Sachen schiefgehen und die müssen dann weit genug nach oben babbeln und dann werden sie plötzlich wieder gerade gerückt.
Öfter mal, würde ich sogar sagen.
Bei sowas wie Flattr-Integration in einem Podcast-Client kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das der Fall ist. Also ich hab da jetzt die Hoffnung persönlich noch nicht ganz aufgegeben, dass das da Besserung in Sicht ist, weil es totale Scheiße wäre.
Das Problem ist glaube ich, dass dieses Flattr zu nah an der Regel ist, du musst Geld, wenn du Geld umschlägst mit deiner Applikation, dann musst du es über Apple machen. Und deswegen, selbst wenn es jetzt nochmal gut geht, kommt der nächste Reviewer, der sagt, das ist aber ein Bezahl-Service und das geht nicht. Das kannst du nicht anbieten. Also das ist so, wenn ich von Tim Cook himself jetzt die Anweisung kommt, ja, Flattr ist nicht evil und jeder darf Flattr machen, dann wird das nichts.
Ne, also aus den Untiefen des Review-Prozesses wird da sicherlich nichts Gutes bei rauskommen. Da ist ja noch nie was Gutes bei rausgekommen, sondern die sind ja auch immer eher so, dass sie lieber ein bisschen mehr verbieten als notwendig. Da sieht man ja, wie so ein Polizeistaat funktioniert quasi.
Ich glaube, die haben auch ganz schön Angst, diese Reviewer, dass sie was Falsches durchlassen.
Ich stelle mir das, die haben ja, wir haben irgendwann mal überschlagen, wie viele Updates, also wie viele Reviews, die da so jeden Tag machen. Da sind wir so auf knapp 1000 gekommen. Das machen die jetzt weltweit. Aber da brauchst du schon ein paar Leute für. Wenn also an jedem Review irgendwie jemand tatsächlich so 5 bis 15 Minuten dran sitzt und eventuell dann auch Diskussionen notwendig sind und so was, dann brauchst du da echt viele Leute. Und das wäre jetzt sicherlich jetzt nicht der alleranspruchsvollste Job. Und wenn du da jemanden sitzen hast, der sich notdürftig auskennt und der alles was er für nennt. Ich meine hier gerade Instacast, da war ja auch bei der letzten Version dieses schöne Ding, dass er abgelehnt worden ist, weil der Reviewer den Apple Podcast abonniert hat und plötzlich in der App ein Apple-Logo zu sehen war. Also ich meine, da sieht man, dass da jetzt nicht unbedingt die aller, aller intelligentesten diesen Job machen.
Ja, vielleicht ist der Prozess auch einfach so, wenn du was findest, was dir die Möglichkeit gibt, die App abzulehnen, dann bist du mit dem Review fertig. Dann musst du den Rest nicht mehr angucken.
Ach, dass du dann schneller durch bist.
Das heißt, du hast dann mehr Apps geschafft, wenn du es relativ schnell schaffst, eine App rauszuschmeißen. Keine Ahnung, wie die Regeln da sind und wie viele Apps du schaffen musst, wie viel Zeit du hast, um eine tatsächlich anzugucken.
Wir wollen einen Insider-Bericht von einem Informanten aus dem Apple-Review-Bunker.
Allerdings. Nicht aus dem Deutschen. Es gibt ja einen deutschen Apple-Review-Bunker. Also man kann ja wohl auch sagen, ich möchte gern meinen Review-Prozess in Deutschland haben, wenn du Deutscher bist.
Und beschleunigt das Dinge?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Dinge beschleunigt.
Wahrscheinlich im Gegenteil.
Aber ist so für das deutsche Kulturverständnis, wenn so eine App...
Ja, wenn die auch nur auf Deutsch ist zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube auch, dass du dann zu Zeiten, ja erstens dafür und zweitens, dass, wenn jetzt wie Martin da mit Apple telefoniert, dass das dann hoffentlich zu Zeiten geschehen kann, die halbwegs...
Christlich sind.
Halbwegs erträglich sind.
Abendländisch.
Abendländischer. Wir sind ja hier. Genau. Und das ist...
Naja, die würden dann auch abends anrufen, wahrscheinlich, im Abendland. Ich frag mich, ob das wirklich christlich ist.
Nein, das ist äppelig.
Naja, also mir fällt es schwer, mich da jetzt groß zu eschophieren, weil ich das eigentlich schon immer vermutet habe und ein bisschen überrascht war, dass er überhaupt seinen Weg da rein gefunden hat. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich super schade, weil gerade jetzt hier in der Podcastgemeinde hat sich ja gezeigt, dass gerade so ein Feature in den letzten Monaten all denen, die sonst vielleicht nicht so sehr vom Flatterregen bedacht wurden, zugute kam. Also so lese ich das so ein bisschen aus den Rückmeldungen heraus.
Also bei mir war es unglaublich reingeschlagen. Das ist, also nicht mit meinem kleinen Podcast.
Ja, du bist jetzt der fünfte oder sechste oder siebte sogar schon, von dem ich das so gehört habe.
Ich kann ja mal gucken, was hier so die Transaktionen waren. Also ich hab im, jetzt im Mai haben wir, also April, Mai habe ich beide Male jeweils die 100-Euro-Marke geknackt. Im März waren es knapp 70 Euro. Und davor so immer um die 30. 30 mal 15, also so. Aber wurden denn noch mehr Podcasts gehört? Also die Zahl steigt, aber nicht so rasant. Also ich vermute mal, dass das wirklich, also ich vermute stark, dass das daran liegt, dass die Leute das Auto-Feature drin hatten. Also eine andere Erklärung hab ich jetzt nicht. Also wir haben jetzt nicht massiv dafür geworben, dass das geflattert wird.
Das muss auch nicht unbedingt das Auto-Feature sein. Es kann einfach sein, dass man während des Hörens es tun kann, ohne durch diesen bekloppten Prozess durchzugehen. Ich meine, was er immer noch machen kann, ist den reinen Flattr-Link herausholen und anzeigen, als solchen. Ob er das jetzt in seinem nächsten Release so realisieren wird, weiß ich nicht. Und dann geht man halt in Safari und hat dann an der Stelle wieder die Möglichkeit, das zu klicken und könnte dann natürlich auch ein angepasstes User-Interface bekommen. Ich vermute mal, Flattr selbst wird sich jetzt genau um sowas kümmern, um sozusagen den Apps die Möglichkeit zu geben, so nah dran zu sein, wie es irgendwie geht.
Es muss ja möglich sein, Flattr-Button irgendwie in den Feed einzubauen. Also das ist ja dann immer noch die Möglichkeit, die man hat.
Du brauchst ja deine User-Credentials oder nicht?
Die gibst du dann ein, sobald du... Du baust halt nur einen Link mit dem Bild ein auf den entsprechenden Flattr-Artikel und dann kannst du da halt... Dann wird eine Webseite aufgemacht, dann gibst du da einmal deinen ganzen User-Daten ein und dann bist du drin.
Gibt es eine Flattr-App für iOS?
Ja, gibt es. Die ist aber kostenlos.
Das heißt, die können dann Single Sign-On noch so machen, so wie die Facebook-App. Das heißt, wenn du einmal mit der Facebook-App eingeloggt bist, dass du dann in einer anderen App quasi auf Flattr-Link klickst und musst dich nicht nochmal einloggen und so.
Das ist die Frage, ob die App es jetzt auch überleben wird. Also wenn die drin bleibt, was sie jetzt, sagen wir mal, rein aus der Formulierung, wie ich die Ablehnung von Instacast jetzt wahrnehme, eigentlich bedeuten würde, dass das nicht geschehen darf. Aber wenn die drin bleibt, weil sie kostenlos ist, nach dem Motto, wir organisieren Spenden, sie ist kostenlos. Wenn man jetzt schafft, das irgendwie hintenrum die Apps miteinander zu verbinden, keine Ahnung.
Naja, also ich mein Single Sign-On und so, das macht der Twitter und so, macht das ja auch alles.
Auf jeden Fall ist jetzt natürlich erstmal die ganze Dynamik raus, weil natürlich jetzt alle iOS-Developer erstmal voll Schiss haben, überhaupt das Wort Flattr irgendwo hinzuschreiben, ohne um nicht zu riskieren, rauszufliegen. Weil das war natürlich jetzt auch gerade das Problem von dem Martin von Instacast, der musste einfach seine Updates raushauen, um einfach ganz andere Probleme zu lösen.
Ich bin auch von einem Bug betroffen, der dazu führt, dass der WMR-Feed aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf seiner Seite, ich hab ihn gefragt, ob ich da irgendwas machen kann, was nicht mehr aktualisiert wird bei einigen Usern. Und ich da so ein paar Beschwerden kriege, das scheint so ein Bug zu sein, dann meint er, ja, ja, es ist ein Bug, das ist jetzt mit der 202, aber die hängt gerade im Review-Prozess wegen scheiß Flattr-Integration. Da ist natürlich so, hey, schön doppelt betroffen, yeah, das ist ja mal geil.
Ja gut, das wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch relativ bald lösen, schätze ich mal, jetzt wo er da eine Version ohne Flattr drin hat, aber schön ist das nicht. Naja, und diese 30% von Apple lassen sich da halt eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht reinbringen, also rein technisch schon nicht, weil du ja zu dem Zeitpunkt des Flatterns noch überhaupt nicht weißt, um welchen Betrag es sich handelt, der an der Stelle transaktioniert wird.
Also ich glaube gar nicht, dass es wirklich weit oben da irgendwelche Bedenken wegen Flatter gibt oder sowas bei Apple, sondern ich glaube, das ist wirklich, da sitzen wie gesagt unten im Review sitzen da irgendwelche Leute, die, das hat was mit Payment zu tun und hier kann man spenden und spenden, habe ich hier nachgelesen, ach es geht gar nicht um die App, na egal, irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh. Und dass das eigentlich, und ich kann mir auch durch, also vielleicht kann man ja wirklich an Apple mal appellieren, wenn man da jemand vor Ort hat, dass das, wo sie ja Podcasting irgendwann mal auch so hochgehalten haben und das so toll fanden, dass das ja doch eine...
Das ist lange her, da war Steve noch am Leben.
Ach ich glaube gar nicht, ich glaube, wenn Steve leben würde, wäre dieser Scheiß hier genauso passiert. Da interessiert mich...
Da warst du.
Ach Steve war der große Podcasting-Freund.
Die schützende Hand des Stiefs, jetzt ist es vorbei. Nee, nee, nee, ist ja nicht wirklich was passiert.
Die bei Apple haben nur gelesen Podcast.
Max, du bist vor Ort, renn da hin.
Ich werd's probieren.
Und erzähl denen irgendwie, dass sie ihre Plattform demnächst einstellen können, wenn sie nicht Flattr-Support zulassen. Aber sollen sie es einfach ins Betriebssystem einbauen?
Also wenn man mal so anfängt, wenn sie jetzt die Flattr-App verbieten sozusagen, und die rausfliegt, dann hat da eine Paypal-App eigentlich auch nichts mehr drin verloren, in so einem Ding. Und wenn sie eine Paypal-App aus dem Store rausschmeißen, ich glaub, dann haben sie eins fix drei hier irgendwie, die Kartellbehörde gegen sich.
Ja, ich überleg auch gerade, was die Paypal-App eigentlich macht.
Nee, kannst du garantiert auch so Sachen wie deinen Kontostand einsehen und irgendwelche Überweisungen...
Nee, das ist ja was anderes.
Und Überweisungen machen.
So ein flatter Kontostand hätte auch keiner, was glaub ich.
Naja, und Überweisungen machen und so was. Ich weiß nicht, was man mit der App alles machen kann.
Ich kann Überweisungen auch mit meiner normalen Banking abmachen.
Naja, du kannst Payment damit machen. Also was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Flatter und du bezahlst für irgendwas und du bezahlst für irgendwas? Das ist doch jetzt...
Das Insta-Dings ist aber keine Flatter-App, sondern halt Insta-Dings.
Naja, aber nee, wenn sie die Flatter-App verbieten würden, wenn die als nächstes auch noch rausfliegen würden, dann...
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, das stimmt natürlich, ne? Was ist denn mit sowas wie Home-Banking? Nee, hab ich echt noch nie drüber nachgedacht.
eBay-App.
Gehört ja auch zu Paypal. Also bei...
Bei Apple kriegt sich wirklich bei eBay irgendwie nicht 30% von abwarten.
Ja, bei eBay passt schon eher.
Ich glaub der Knackpunkt ist wirklich am Ende dieses Donations-Ding.
Jaja, die haben was gegen Spenden, das hör ich auch schon.
Ja, auch Amazon und so, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt...
Kannst du mit der Amazon App kaufen, ja, ne?
Die haben halt dann manchmal welche auf dem Schirm. Ich meine...
Jetzt komm ich aber wirklich ins Grübeln. Was ist denn hier eigentlich mit der Amazon App?
Aber das gilt ja nur für virtuelle Waren, ne?
Hab ich einen schlechten Druckerhub gekauft?
Was gilt für virtuelle Waren?
Na diese Beschränkung, dass du damit kaufen kannst. Also wenn du bei Amazon oder bei Ebay was kaufst, kaufst du ja meistens keine virtuellen Waren.
Was sind die virtuellen Waren?
Na so was wie Programme oder das du...
Vor allem kauf ich mit PayPal, kauf ich vor allem...
Oder dass du Features freischaltest über irgendeinen Pay-Mechanismus.
Ja, aber ich hoffe, das geht aber.
Also ich meine, es wäre vermessen zu behaupten, dass das nicht geht.
Das geht nicht, aber das ist das, was sie mit dieser App Store-Ruhe eigentlich ausschließen. Sie schließen nicht damit aus, dass du physische Waren kaufst, sondern sie schließen damit aus, dass du virtuelle Waren kaufst, wenn du genau mal rein liest.
Also das heißt, aber ich kann mir ein Kindle Book auf mit der Amazon App...
Aber was sind denn virtuelle Waren?
Na, Musik, Filme, Software.
E-Books.
Also downloadable, wo sozusagen der Kauf, das Kaufergebnis... Ja gut, aber bei Flattr geht es gar nicht um Kaufen. Es geht nur um Donations.
Hey, hat halt irgend so ein Revue-Zwerg im Bonker Scheiße gebaut.
Ja, aber das hatten die doch jetzt auch mit Dropbox. Dieses Dropbox SDK, was plötzlich aus heiterem Himmel, und ich meine, die hat es jetzt richtig hart erwischt, dass das jetzt aus heiterem...
Erwischt?
Na ja, weil...
Die haben sich doch geeinigt, oder nicht?
Na, die haben sich irgendwann geeinigt, aber das war halt so, dass eine App nicht in den Store kam, wegen einem Link im Dropbox SDK. Irgendwo an einer Stelle.
Du konntest über das SDK, konntest du bei Dropbox Bezahl-Services abschließen für, na ja, halt mehr Speicher. Und das ist denen sauer aufgestoßen. Weil das Geld ja an Apple vorbei geht.
Und dann haben die, und das natürlich besonders scheiße, weil dann fangen natürlich Entwickler, die sicher ihr, die sagen, bei meiner App ist diese Dropbox-Integration eins von 300 Features, ja dann schmeiße ich das halt raus, ehe ich hier gefährde, nicht mehr durch den Re-Re-Prozess durchzukommen. Das heißt, da ist Dropbox dann natürlich richtig schnell aktiv geworden und haben dann auch entsprechend angefangen zu verhandeln. Und haben ja dann auch irgendwie wohl so was wie eine Lösung gefunden, aber ich glaube keine, also keine Antwort von Apple. Also ist nicht so, dass er dann...
Sie haben das Kauf-N rausgeschmissen, den Kauf-Link.
Sie haben den Kauf-Link, aber ohne explizit eine Ansage dafür, von Apple zu erhalten, sondern es war dann so...
Na ja, kriegste ja nie.
Ich stand da nicht, dass sie sich geeinigt hätten, das ist doch genau das.
Ja, sie sind irgendwann wieder... Irgendwann hat dann Apple genickt oder eben... Oder einfach nicht wieder rejected und danach ist jetzt hoffentlich erst mal wieder alles gut. Und sowas, das muss einfach mal langsam auf vernünftig...
Also, diese Regel, die ist so bekloppt.
Also, ich hab grad mal ausprobiert, echte Bücher kannst du in der Amazon-App kaufen, Kindle Books kannst du nicht kaufen. Da gibt's dann nur auf den Wunschzettel setzen.
Ja, aber ich kann's auf den Wunschzettel setzen. Aber nicht in den Warenkorb.
Genau. Kindle Books kannst du wirklich nur auf Wunschzettel gibt's nur in den Button, alle die normalen Bücher kannst du auch direkt in der App kaufen.
Ich hätt nix dagegen, wenn ich bei Flattr alles auf den Wunschzettel setzen könnte. Und dann gehst du zu Flattr und sagst...
Die Flattr-Vorwerkliste.
Das ist der Trick für die Flattr-Jungs.
Vielleicht.
Und dann gehst du nach Hause, Monatsende, jetzt bitte. Du flattrst aber kein Geld, sondern nur einen Wunsch.
Moment mal, eigentlich ist es ja jetzt schon so. Es ist schon so. Du machst stetig keinen Kauf oder Zahlprozess.
Nee, aber man muss sie nicht nochmal bestätigen. So gesehen ist das schon absolut final durch. Sie müssen einfach nochmal so einen Zwischenstab einführen.
Dass ich das nochmal zurücknehme?
Dass sie es halt Wunsch nennen und nicht mehr ist schon, it's done.
Ja, Apple muss ich da einfach mal bessern.
Nee, man muss sie besser austricksten.
Ja, das ist vielleicht wirklich ein interessanter, weil ich meine niemand kann jetzt Instacast davon abhalten, sich Buttons zu merken. Ich meine, das ist was anderes, als ob man dann durch die API geht. Ich meine, damit hast du natürlich immer noch eine schlechtere Experience.
Aber ein Loggen bei einem Third-Party-API, das machen ja nur alle.
Und dann bei Flattr sagen hier, der User wollte das, das und das und dann gehst du da einmal im Monat hin und klickst nochmal, kannst du Peter gleich anrufen.
Der kommt sowieso hier relativ bald. Es gibt hier einen Flattr, kann ich nichts zu sagen. Der Punkt ist, dass am 7. in zwei Wochen, das ist dann ein Tag nach unserer nächsten Sendung oder was? Nee, wann sind wir denn wieder dran? Ich glaube, wir haben noch gar keinen Termin. Auf jeden Fall am 7. Juni gibt es ein Flattr Meetup in Berlin. Und ich gucke gerade mal, ich habe das gerade eben erst bekommen. Da, Meetup in Berlin. 18 Uhr. Schön Wetter, was ist denn.
Das?
Schön Wetter? Klingt so nach...
Werden wir Berlin?
Bernauer Straße?
Ja genau, da oben am Mauerpark. Stimmt ja. Ja da war ich sogar schon mal. Da war es weiter links.
Wo der Frühmarkt ist oder was?
Ja, so ein bisschen daneben.
Ok, also da ist am 7. Juni um 18 Uhr. Hoffentlich bei schönem Wetter. Das Flattr Meetup und da wird der Linus da sein auf jeden Fall. Torwalz? Nee, der Linus von Flattr, der Linus Olsen. Und keine Ahnung, wen er noch im Schlepp hat, dann auch irgendwelche anderen Developer mit dabei sind, das kann sein oder nicht. Ja, so viel dazu. Und ich glaube, sehr viel mehr kann man nicht sagen, aber vielleicht ist das ein Weg, dass man so Wunschlisten macht. Weil ich meine, was Amazon darf... Naja, das andere Problem ist halt diese Spenden-Sache. Also es ist halt explizit Spenden heiß. Ich war auch ehrlich gesagt nie so ein richtiger Freund davon, dass das so Spenden heißt bei Flattr. Wobei es auch sehr schwierig ist, da den richtigen Namen zu finden für das, was da eigentlich tatsächlich stattfindet.
Was ist denn noch Spenden?
Na, man könnte es halt Micropayment nennen. Macht jetzt vielleicht zum Zusammenhang mit IOS die Sache nicht. Ja, das mag sein. Es gab zum Beispiel diese Diskussion, was soll der Button anzeigen, wenn noch 0 Klicks da sind. Soll da eine Null stehen oder was anderes? Eine Null ist immer so discouraging. Und man könnte ja sagen, dass man in dem Fall quasi ein Wort findet, was ermuntert diesen Button auch zu drücken.
Da ist doch die Null drin.
Wäre vermutlich auch nicht durch den Review-Prozess durchgekommen.
Ja, aber der Button muss ja auch nicht durch den Review-Prozess. Der ist ja auf einer Website. Und ich dachte mir immer, Support wäre eigentlich das richtige Wort. Also ich finde diese Gedanken, dass man über Flattr Unterstützung ausdrückt, finde ich eigentlich am besten. Und ich sag dir, hätte die von Anfang an immer nur von Support durch Flattr gesprochen, wäre dir wahrscheinlich noch nie aufgefallen. Nur als das Ding angefangen hat, groß Fenster aufpoppen zu lassen, mit hier Donate, Donate, Donate, da geht die Sache dann irgendwie in die falsche Richtung.
Ja, die sollen jetzt mal mit dem Wunsch-Titel probieren und ich glaube, das könnte klappen.
Das ist aber auf jeden Fall eine schöne Vorlage. Man muss halt nur noch gucken, dass eben diese Sache mit den Donations ist. Ich meine, wenn man diesen Flatterwunsch in die andere App hinein kanalisiert bekommt, wie ist denn das mit Interapplication? Das geht eigentlich nur über so URLs und installierte App oder was? Also wenn man jetzt von der einen App in die andere App Informationen hineinbringen will, dann kann man entweder eine Datei innerhalb der App öffnen, aber das würde wahrscheinlich wesentlich einfacher über eine URL geben.
Du registrierst einfach dein eigenes URL-Scheme. Das ist einfach gemacht.
Also wenn die Flatter-App installiert wäre und eine andere App feststellt, dass diese App installiert ist und dann könnte sie quasi diesen Klickwunsch...
Sie könnte den Button überhaupt nur anzeigen, wenn die Flatter-App auch installiert ist. Du kannst ja gucken, ist was mit dem Protokoll? Ich mache das gerade bei meinem Tabular Tab.
Und die App kostet dann wiederum nichts?
Die App kostet dann wieder nichts und dann musste ich auch nicht einloggen. Und so finde ich eigentlich insofern eigentlich gar nicht ganz gut. Und da gibt es auch ein Protokoll, dieses X-Callback-Protokoll. Dass du dann wieder ein Rückgabeparameter angeben kannst. Und dann kannst du dann irgendwie so ein Thank-you noch anzeigen und so was.
Oder die Flattr-Jungs machen ein iOS SDK vielleicht noch. Oder dann mit so einem Webview irgendwie halt dann hantieren musst im Zweifel.
Ja, aber Webview ist dann glaube ich nicht die Definition von in Safari. Die Vorschrift ist nicht, dass es im Webview stattfindet, sondern die Vorschrift ist, dass es in Safari, dass du die App verlässt. Wieso?
Aber das ist doch nur, er soll sich was merken. Ich würde da überhaupt gar nichts mehr irgendwie kompliziert machen.
Ja, nee, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt sozusagen...
Aber selbst mit dem in Safari könntest du das gut... Also du könntest ja genau diesen gleichen X-Callback-Prozess könntest du ja auch mit Webseiten machen. Du könntest in der Flattr-App oder in der Instacast-App könntest du sagen, ok, jetzt mach ich einen Weblink auf, mach den in Safari auf. Da ist der User im Idealfall schon eingeloggt, weil er eh gerade irgendwas macht. Weil man ja Safari auch eher sein Passwort anvertraut als irgendein, ich finde das sowieso doof, dass man immer seine Passwörter nochmal in jede App da separat reinhaken muss. Und insbesondere wenn man vielleicht noch in der Öffentlichkeit ist und seine Passwörter nicht öffentlich auf seiner Tastatur tippen will. Und dann bist du da schon eingeloggt, dann sagt dir alles klar, das ist jetzt so ein Flatter-Click und danach leite ich dich wieder direkt um in Instacast. Und wenn du, wenn du das gerade machst, während du den Podcast hörst, würdest du wahrscheinlich gar nichts davon merken.
Aber ist denn das, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel du da aufsagst, hier mach mal hier einen Flatter-Button hin, dann machst du diesen Flatter-Button, dann öffnet sich ein Webview, wo du im Zweifel dich einloggst, also aber in der App noch so ein Overlay quasi, ne, gibt's ja, macht ja Facebook auch so. Und da dann halt einen Web-Click und so weiter machst, dann machst du den Overview wieder zu oder automatisch, wenn du geflattert hast und so, wäre das dann auch jetzt schon problematisch quasi?
Naja, mit Webviews haben sie es ja auch nicht so, ne? Ich meine, das ist ja jeder dritte Webbrowser da draußen, das ist ja ab 18 oder ab 12 oder weißt du was? Das hatten wir jetzt bei Screenfeeder auch. Was machen wir da? Also ich meine, unsere App liefert definitiv nichts, irgendwas Schlimmes aus. Aber es könnte theoretisch sein, dass wenn man nach Porn sucht auf Twitter, dass man einen Porn kriegt und dann hat man plötzlich Pornbilder. Und darum mussten wir da halt auch irgendwie was anderes angeben.
Das ist ja nicht zu fassen, ey.
Und das ist...
Eigentlich wäre es nur zu wünschen, dass Apple irgendwann nochmal wirklich eine marktbeherrschende Stellung erreicht. Und 90 Prozent aller Telefone auf diesem Planeten verkauft. Und dann zwingt man sie mit des Kartellrechts auch andere Systeme zuzulassen.
Ich glaube, das könnte man jetzt schon problemlos machen.
Na doch, ist das nicht gegeben. Wie willst du das belegen?
Also in dem Raum hier sind die 100 Prozent.
Ja, aber wir wissen alle, dass Apple face-weit gerade mal...
Du hast das Note-Note ja nicht gesehen von Tim.
Was ist ihr Smartphone-Anteil? Keine Ahnung, je nachdem, welche Zahl man so herbeizieht.
Sie sind nicht der alleinige Monopolist, aber das ist...
Auch nicht der...
Von den Smartphones sind sie wahrscheinlich der größte Hersteller und von den Gewinnen, das sagen wir auch immer, sind sie auch der größte Telefonhersteller. Also insofern, da sind sie marktbeherrschend.
Nein, sie sind noch nicht marktbeherrschend.
Zumindest was die Gewinne angeht auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber die Gewinne sind nicht entscheidend für marktbeherrschend. Du kannst noch so viel Geld verdienen, wenn 90% aller Geräte da draußen von Leuten benutzt werden, die nicht bei... Ich meine, wenn sie ihre Telefone für 100.000 Euro das Stück verkaufen würden, ja, und es gäbe dann halt nur 100.000 Kunden, dann hätten sie auch noch viel mehr Profit. Aber es wäre halt nicht marktbeherrschend. Marktbeherrschend ist wirklich Stückzahl, Usage. Das ist das Entscheidende.
Microsoft in den 90ern.
Und solange Android halt noch so viel verkauft wird, wird es sehr schwierig sein, da eine marktbeherrschende Stellung faktisch...
Also ich glaube, wir haben alle keine Ahnung von deutschem Kartellrecht, aber ich glaube, so hart ist das im Zweifelsfall nicht. Ich glaube, dass das greift von früher und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es bei Apple schon greift. Das ist bloß noch nirgendwo aufgeschlagen.
Ja, es greift vielleicht vor 90%, aber es greift sicherlich nicht unter 50%.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch schon unter 50% greift.
Auf gar keinen Fall bei 22% oder wo sie kann.
Okay, wir schauen nach, würde ich mal sagen, vor welcher weiter noch irgendwelche Prozentscheidungen her.
Wir delegieren das an den Chat oder so.
Spätestens auf Tabletts haben sie wirklich...
Schaut doch mal kurz bitte im Kartellrecht nach, ab wann man Apple dazu zwingen kann, Flattr einzubauen.
Und spätestens beim Tabletts haben sie wirklich die Marktbeherrschungsstellung.
Ja, es kommt bloß keiner.
Crickets und Tumbleweed. Was ist das Einzige, was die internationale Tech-Industrie zu Apple als Antwort parat hat?
Also mir fällt noch ein, das hier bei Bitcoin zum Beispiel. Da hast du ja auf unserer Seite deinen Account, da kannst du auch Geld abheben und machen und tun. Und dann gibt es aber auch bei uns noch einen sogenannten API-Key, damit kannst du halt deinen Kontostand angucken, aber du kannst sozusagen nur lesen, aber du kannst nicht schreiben. Das ist nur so ein Extrakie. Und so könnte man es doch bei Flattr auch machen. Es gibt dann Key, den man halt in den Apps immer eintragen muss, der aber nur halt dieses Merkding setzen kann, mit dem du halt sonst irgendwie bei Flattr nichts machen kannst. Und so könnte man das doch prima lösen. Und dann ohne irgendwie in Safari wechseln, so das stinkt alles. Mal ehrlich, wollte ich andauernd irgendwie euer Instacast machen. Dann wieder Safari, doppelklick, wieder zurück. Und dann hat das aber inzwischen rausgeschmissen, weil Safari braucht dann irgendwie so viel Speicher und hat irgendwie die letzte App rausgeschmissen.
Nein, das wollen wir nicht, aber das wird so laufen müssen.
Ja, ne, ne, ne, das muss anders gehen. Die sollen sich dabei Flattr mal was Schickes einfallen lassen.
Also wieso muss man da nicht doppelt klicken oder sowas? Klicks einmal, geht hin und... Ach Quatsch, der wechselt einfach. Geht mal kurz in Safari und geht wieder zurück.
Du musst halt im Zweifelsfall dein Passwort erstmal eingeben.
Naja, aber dein Passwort musst du eh eingeben.
Ja, aber das kannst du ja nur einmal machen in der App und dann merkt es sich...
Du kannst ja auch in Safari merken.
Ja, aber in der App kannst du mit irgendeinem Ohr aus oder irgendeinem Scheiß kannst du dir halt einen Token merken.
Ja, aber ich will nicht in einer... Ich meine, in Safari bin ich uns aber eh schon eingeloggt.
Ja, du willst es nicht, aber anderen Leuten ist es vielleicht egal. Und die sagen dann halt einfach, so wie es jetzt ist, automatisch flättern.
Ja, es geht offensichtlich nicht.
Und wäre auch schneller dann.
Ja, aber es geht nicht.
Na, deswegen reden wir ja drüber, wie man es machen könnte.
Ja, indem man in Safari wechselt, mit irgendeiner Wunschliste und am Ende des Monats muss ich nochmal irgendwo hinklicken auf einem anderen Computer.
Das ist aber keine schöne Lösung.
Ich kriege zwei Tage vorher eine Mail. Klickst du hier?
Ja, das ist eine tolle Lösung.
Talking of Flattr und Integration, gibt es noch zwei Hinweise. Erstens, es gibt jetzt auch die erste Podcasting-App mit Flattr-Integration auf Android, die jetzt automatisch zur ersten und einzigen App.
Hat. Das ist Podkicker.
Dass da die Unterstützung drin ist, überrascht nicht so richtig, weil es kommt irgendwie auch aus Schweden. Das war wohl ein kurzer Dienstweg. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt es die App. Ich habe sie noch nicht benutzt. Ich habe aber von Leuten gehört, dass es wohl funktioniert. Sprich, mit Podkicker, wenn man Android hat und diesen Podcast-Line benutzt, dann funktioniert das sehr wohl mit Flattr. Und für die Podcast-Seite eben gerade kam das finale Release. Ich habe das schon ein bisschen länger getestet. Hier mit einer Beta-Version für WordPress. Das Flattr-Plugin hat jetzt ein Update bekommen und da verbessert sich einiges.
Dieser Scheiß-Overlay ist der denn aus?
Der Scheiß-Overlay war auch in der letzten Version schon abschaltbar, global. Jetzt allerdings kann man auch Flattr-Shortcodes machen. Also wenn man im Artikeltext so, Ecke, Klammer, Aufflatter, URL, gleich dralalala schreibt, dann kriegt man dafür einen Button. Das heißt, man muss nicht dieses HTML da reinbauen, was immer schwierig war, weil wenn du dann irgendwie mit WordPress, mit dem visuellen Editor das abgespeichert hast, dann hat er einen leeren Link erkannt und das dann rausgenommen und so ein Scheiß. Und es gibt Support für Side-Wide, Flatter und so weiter.
Alle gegen Flatter, furchtbar.
Genau, da macht er einfach Update.
Wisst ihr wofür es langsam mal Zeit wird für ein HTML-Payment-Element? Gibt's. Was denn? Na das ist genau das, was Flattr benutzt.
Wie?
Das ist atom.link rel=payment. Das ist aber nicht HTML, das ist atom. Entschuldigung, ich meinte auch.
Will ich das als Klicker?
Wie als Klicker?
Als Web-Klicker.
Warum nicht? Ist doch super. Endlich, endlich...
Endlich!
Endlich auch mal bezahlen für den Scheiß und nicht nur irgendwie drauf angewiesen sein, dass da irgendwelche Drecks Werbung dir die Seite zumacht und alles blä, und die Leute nicht davon leben können, die es machen und so. Das wird Zeit, dass sich der ganze Scheißdreck endlich mal umdreht. Das wird Zeit, dass man nicht nur jeden Content, den Müll ins Netz stellen kann, sondern das wird Zeit, dass man dafür sich auch bezahlen kann.
Also das brauchst du einfach nur mal mobilemax.de aufzurufen und da hast du dann deinen Relgleich-Payment.
Und welcher Browser kann den lesen?
Keiner.
Relgleich?
Naja, das Ding ist, du musst sowas ja überhaupt erstmal anbieten. Payment ist, ich finde das ein bisschen Quatsch. Also es gab diese Spezifikationen. Relgleich-Payment gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau seit wann, aber das ist sozusagen schon lange da. Hat bloß niemand benutzt, weil natürlich Payment läuft irgendwie anders.
Das wissen wir ja alle.
Es läuft nicht dadurch, dass das Insum-HTML drinsteht, weil eben kein System so einfach und so webnah ist wie Flattr. Du könntest jetzt einen Browser schreiben oder einen Browser Plugin, was eben einfach auf diesen Payment-Link reagiert. Und sagt, oh, da ist Payment. Aber so funktioniert das Web nicht, dass du sagst, oh, hier ist eine Webseite, die kann man kaufen. Kaufe ich die gleich?
Natürlich funktioniert das Web noch nicht so, weil es kein Payment ist. Weil es kein vernünftiger Payment ist.
Ja, aber der Kaufprozess selber ist einfach eine komplexe Geschichte. Warum? Und ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau, was so die Intention von diesem Link-Element war, aber es ist so im Wesentlichen der Link, der dich zum Kaufen davon bringt.
Ja, nee, das muss besser werden. Es muss, dass da oben irgendwas in der Menüleiste drin steht, kostet dich jetzt so und so viel. Und dass du da draufklickst, dass der Webseitenbetreiber keinen Spaß damit hat.
Ja, was kostet dich so und so viel, das ist halt komplex. Welche Währung, welches Rechtssystem, wer bist du?
Wenn das ein lösbares Problem wäre, dann wäre es schon da.
Ach Quatsch, das hat doch bisher einfach niemand Interesse daran gehabt, das zu lösen.
Du meinst, niemand will irgendwas verkaufen im Internet?
Natürlich, es gibt Leute, die wollen was verkaufen.
Du meinst, niemand will etwas kaufen im Internet?
Es gibt Leute, die wollen etwas kaufen, aber es gibt niemand, der ein Interesse daran hat, die Zahlung abzuwickeln. Und also es gibt... Was? Wer bietet vernünftige Zahlungsabwicklungen benutzerfreundlich? Ja, PayPal ist der einzige. Es ist ein unglaublicher...
Ja, aber PayPal ist nicht niemand.
Es ist ein unglaublicher Drecksladen, hat null Konkurrenz.
Ja, das wären die anderen auch. Ich meine, das ist ein Payment-Abwickler.
Ach, Quatsch, das ist...
Also du meinst, es ist alles total trivial und es macht einfach nur keiner.
Nein, ich sag nicht, dass es total trivial wäre. Ich sage, dass... Du prangerst das an. Natürlich ist es, aber ich meine, wir haben Webbrowser. Das ist Hightech. Das ist ja nicht so, als ob da jemand mit dem Kopf auf die Tastatur gefallen ist und Safari ist dabei rausgekommen. Da sitzen auch schon Mannjahre an Entwicklung drinne und viel Hirnschmalz. Die wären doch so was wie so ein scheiß Payment hinkriegen. Also das ist doch ein lösbares Problem. Das ist es.
Nein, glaube ich nicht. Weil es gibt einfach vier Milliarden Leute da draußen, die alle was anderes wollen und alle eine andere Vorstellung davon haben und alle andere eigene Interessen haben. Und es gibt da... Es wird da niemals das zentrale Payment-Ding.
Es war gar nicht das zentrale...
Vor allen Dingen, da gibt es vier Milliarden Menschen da draußen, die da drauf aus sind.
Die sind bei sieben Milliarden.
Die sind auszuhebeln und damit ihr Geld auf einen kurzen Dienstweg zu kriegen.
Ja, auch das ist ein lösbares Problem. Es ist doch...
Okay, dann wir warten einfach mal bis nächstes Jahr und dann zeigst du uns ja mal...
Vielleicht versuchen wir es vorher mit Weltfrieden.
Und als nächstes erzählst du mir, dass du ohne Probleme drucken kannst. Und Kalender mit Scrollbaren Wochen, das haben wir auch schon alles gesehen.
Dafür wird es wirklich mal Zeit, dass das endlich mal vernünftig gelöst wird. Und natürlich müssen dafür ein paar mehr Leute mal zusammenarbeiten. Das ist auch klar, aber im Augenblick... Google hat natürlich überhaupt kein Interesse daran, sowas durchzusetzen. Apple hat offensichtlich kein Interesse daran, sowas durchzusetzen. Und haben sie auch nicht... Ah, ich bin wieder im Stussmode bei jemandem im Chat, weil ich will, dass Leute bezahlt werden, dafür, dass sie Dinge machen, jaja.
Gibt's da für einen Showbot Kürze?
Apple will natürlich, dass alle hier ihr normales Bezahlsystem benutzen.
Ja, wir haben zwar ein Bezahlsystem, also ich meine, außer In-App-Purchase gibt's doch gar nicht.
Wir haben halt gar kein Interesse, dass es im Web passiert.
Das ist der Grund, warum es nicht passiert, weil es niemanden gibt, der ein Interesse dran hat. Banken sind zu doof dafür.
Aber PayPal ist nicht Teil des Problemlösens, dass irgendwie...
Also alle Dinge, wo niemand ein Interesse daran hat, passieren nicht.
Ja, außer es finden sich genügend Leute, die ein Interesse dran haben. Und dass es offensichtlich nicht irgendwelche Firmen sind.
Also du prangerst irgendwas an. Ich kann ja nicht mehr so ganz folgen, ich sag nicht, du hast nicht recht, ich sag nur, es wird alle seine Gründe geben. Diese Link-Rell-Payment-Sache ist so minimal, dass es auf jeden Fall für nichts wirklich ausreicht. Zu behaupten, es gebe keinen Ansatz, ist damit auch irgendwie nicht gesagt. Also wie auch immer.
Die Banken sind leider gar nicht so doof, meint ihr? Was denn?
Ist gut jetzt.
Also wenn hier irgendjemand doof ist, dann wohl Banken. Die kriegen nicht mal Online-Banking. Also Online-Banking halten die immer noch für was Neues.
Lass uns über Online-Banking reden.
Lass uns lieber über Kalender reden.
Das ist doch mal ein berechtigtes Thema, um sich zu berufsberügen.
Nein, das ist ein scheiß Thema.
Was ist mit Online-Banking?
Also mich wurde gefragt, ob wir das nochmal thematisieren können auf dem Mac.
Ja, was gibt's da zu thematisieren?
Nicht viel, was wir nicht schon thematisiert hätten. Es gibt lediglich nur ein paar Updates.
Outbank? Ich hab ja Outbank auf dem Mac. Wie viel hat mich der Scheiß gekostet? Irgendwie um die 20 Euro?
Ach, auf dem Mac.
Ich glaub, ich hab die für billig gekauft. Aber auf jeden Fall ein Schweinegeld. Die kann nicht Copy and Paste. Du kannst Daten, kriegst du da nicht mehr raus.
Selbst so große Firmen wie Apple hat da ein Jahr gebraucht.
Mach ich den ganzen Tag.
Aus Outbank? Wie?
Deswegen benutze ich Outbank, weil es geht.
Also ich hab mit deren Support gequatscht, den solltest du sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, was du mit Copy und Paste kopieren willst. Vielleicht willst du was anderes kopieren als ich.
Ich möchte, dass Daten, die ich, dass ich hier eine Suche mache, nach Überweisung, und dass ich die auswähle.
Du willst dann diese Listen, Items selber?
Ja, natürlich. Egal, ich möchte diese Daten raushaben. Ich möchte die Daten, die da in Outbank drin sind, möchte ich gerne irgendwie rausbekommen.
Ein Export.
Ist ja klar, dass der nicht geht. Da könntest du deine Daten ja in die Konkurrenz importen und deren Programm nicht mehr benutzen. Wie kann man das gut finden?
Die Konkurrenz kann sich das ja selber holen. Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Die alten Daten könnt ihr sich nicht holen.
Dann hab ich den Support angeschrieben. Angeschrien? Wie sieht das aus mit Datenexport? Ja, das ist ein Feature für die Version 1.3 geplant. Wir wissen aber noch nicht, wann die kommt.
Das ist immerhin eine ehrliche Antwort.
Ich kann jetzt einfach keine Abrechnung. Die bieten auch keine Alternative. Ich könnte mir ja sagen, wie ich an die Datenbank ran komme.
Aber die aktuelle Version ist 1.2.9. So weit scheinen wir davon nicht entfernt zu sein.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, dass sie bald kommt. Sie haben gesagt, wir können nicht sagen, wann die kommt.
Ich hab auch nicht gesagt, dass sie bald kommt. Ich hab nur gesagt, so weit können wir davon nicht entfernt sein.
Na ja, ihr könnt auch beliebig viele Versionen hinten dran hängen.
Na ja, aber das ist ja dann wohl doch eher ein... Na ja, wie auf einmal. Also, keine Ahnung.
Copy and Paste in so einer Zahl-App, wenn ihr das habt, bin ich sofort dabei. Also immerhin geht's.
Hier, 23.05, jetzt 1.3.0 mit Copy und Paste. Nee, war nur ein Spaß. Immer mal nachgucken.
Diese C-Taste auf deiner Tastatur, er hat endlich wieder eine Funktion.
Ich bin ansonsten eigentlich ganz happy mit diesem Outbank.
I-Outbank, 6,99 kostet die im App-Store.
Keine Ahnung, 7 Euro.
Also das ist hier auch...
Outbank, nicht I-Outbank.
Aber sind zwei unterschiedliche?
Hallo. iPhone-Version und iPad-Version. Welchen Grad an Datenauswurf würde dich schon glücklich machen? Also geht es dir darum, einen XML-Export zu haben, der dann irgendwie jedes Detail enthält? Oder geht es dir darum, wo wesentlich...
Summedatum.
Okay, dann besitzt du einfach Money-Money, da geht das.
Und da kriege ich jetzt meine Outbank-Daten rein?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Deine Outbank-Daten sind die Daten der Bank. Du startest Money-Money und es holt sich das von der Bank.
Ja, aber nicht ewig zurück.
Nö, ewig nicht.
Du siehst aber, wenn du das jetzt seit drei Jahren benutzt, hast du doch da voll viele Einträge. Und die kann sich Money-Money eben nicht mehr holen. Das ist das Problem, weil die Banken so blöde sind, die haben irgendwie so ein paar Bites, die sie sowieso haben, weil sie gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet sind. Aber mir liefern können sie die komischerweise nicht.
Wem erzählst du das? Hängt eigentlich auch so ein bisschen von der Bank ab.
Money-Money kann das. Okay, dann hol ich mir jetzt hier noch mal zusätzlich.
Aber Money-Money kann Copy und Paste auf den Elementen. Und macht das dann in so Text. Und dann hast du so Datum, Name, Beschreibung und am Ende der Betrag.
Ich mag ja Paypal auch nicht, aber bei Paypal kannst du über die API tatsächlich deine gesamte Historie seit Erstellung des Accounts runterladen.
Wie sich das auch gehört.
Dauer zwar ewig, aber es geht.
Jaja, das ist ganz toll. Vielleicht noch ein paar allgemeine Anmerkungen zu Outbank und zu Money-Money. Ich verwende ja beide Programme und bin immer ganz hinterher. Wer denn jetzt das Näschen vorne hat? Ich muss sagen, im Wesentlichen ist das Outbank. Outbank ist immer noch zumindest für die Konten, die ich habe. Also andere Banken etc. Aber bei Outbank passiert relativ viel in Richtung Anpassung an Sachen. Und kürzlich, das letzte Update, ich glaube es war genau dieses 129-Update von Outbank, hat es mir jetzt ermöglicht über meine Sparkassenkonten dann auch nicht nur alle Kreditkartenkonten überhaupt anzusprechen, sondern auch die Buchungen, die getätigten Buchungen auch noch zu bekommen. Vorher war es nur möglich, die Pending Buchungen, also das, was bis zur nächsten Abbuchung dann von dem Hauptkonto angefallen ist, zu holen. Und jetzt geht es eben auch so. Außerdem hat Outbank PayPal, das hat allerdings jetzt auch Money-Money dazu bekommen. Also man kann auch PayPal damit machen. Das geht auch besser als mit den Apps von PayPal. Diese PayPal-Anwendung auf dem iPhone zum Beispiel, die ist einfach broke. Und so mit Outbank oder mit Money-Money dann eben. Also Outbank gibt es ja auch auf iPhone. Money-Money gibt es nur auf Mac. Geht das ganz gut. So, für meine Zwecke funktioniert Outbank besser, crasht allerdings auch von Zeit zu Zeit mal seit den letzten zwei Updates. Aber da geschieht auf jeden Fall was.
Money-Money kann auf jeden Fall auch, das kann Outbank auch hier diese DKB-Kreditkartenkonten einlesen. Was ja viele reine HBCI-Banken-Apps nicht können. Und die können das.
Dieses ganze HBCI-Feld, das ist ein Schlachtfeld. Also man kann es diesen Anwendern, diesen Anwendungsentwicklern überhaupt nicht vorwerfen, wenn sie irgendeine Bank nicht unterstützen, weil diese Banken sich dermaßen dagegen wehren, unterstützt zu werden, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Ich sag's ja, Banken sind doof.
Also zum Beispiel, was sehr gängig ist, dass Banken keine Testkonten für Entwickler bereitstellen. Das heißt, du kannst das nur testen, wenn du dann bei der Bank auch ein Konto hast.
Und Überweisungen vornimmst.
Ja, und die haben alle ihre Ereignisse.
Ja, und Überweisungen vornimmst, etc., Also es gibt einfach kein Simulationskonto, was man einfach mal anwirft, wo man alles tätigen kann, wo vielleicht per Random irgendwelche Überweisungen reingebucht werden.
Ich kann Copy and Paste, ich kauf sofort Money Money.
Ja, ist auch nicht so teuer.
15 Euro.
Hast du auch im Mac App Store kaufen direkt?
Kann man im Mac App Store?
Klickst du jetzt und hast du.
Boah, mach ich sofort hier.
Bis zum Mal.
Money Money ist meins.
Hier werden sie geholfen.
Geil, so muss das sein, 14,99.
Jetzt hab ich dir gar kein Affiliate-Link gegeben.
Leidest du wieder drunter. Mach mal jetzt in den Podcast rein. Kauf alle Money Money im App Store und klick auf unseren Affiliate-Link.
Ja, wenn er dann da mal ist.
Wenn die den Podcast haben, dann ist er ja da.
Ja, jetzt hast du mich unter Druck gesetzt. So schnell wie möglich, um die paar Kröten-Pfennige da auch noch abzugreifen.
Heute auch eine Pfeiltransfer-Manager-App, so ähnlich wie Transmit, für 79 Cent statt 29 Euro.
Ja, rufen Sie jetzt an.
Wählen Sie eine Nummer unter oder neben Ihrer Landesflagge. Forklift heißt die. Irgendwie, früher fand ich ja Transmit auch immer ganz toll, aber in den letzten Monaten und Jahren hat es mich dann doch immer angenervt. In letzter Zeit benutze ich ein bisschen mehr Forklift als Transmit. Ich habe die ganze Zeit die Try-Version benutzt. Ich muss ehrlich zugeben, weil mir 29 Dollar zu viel war.
Du meinst, wenn du nur die halbe Datei hochlässt, reicht auch? Oder was war die Einschränkung?
Nach so ein paar Tagen 30 Tage Trial musst du so einen Pfeil löschen. Aber jetzt wo es das für 99 Cent oder sogar 79 Cent im App-Store gab, habe ich doch direkt mal zugegriffen.
Jahrelang Benefit gehabt.
Nein, solange habe ich es noch nicht. Ich habe es erst zweimal extended.
Zweimal gelöscht meinst du?
Einmal extended, also ich benutze 60 Tage statt 30 Tage.
Wir empfehlen dir wieder das kleine Tool FS-Eventer, da kann man schön nachgucken.
Ich habe gehört, dass bald Cheater-Nobgets gedreht werden beim Übertragen.
Aber ein kleiner Tipp ist auf jeden Fall ganz nett und kann auch alles, was Transmit eigentlich kann.
Nee, kann ich alles, was Transmit kann. Ja, ich gucke hier gerade mal so und so.
Also das, was ich brauche, kann Transmit.
Ja, so ein paar Sachen, die ich hier daily mache, die gehen jetzt nicht so ganz so out of the box, aber es sieht schon mal ganz ordentlich aus.
Was machst du denn, was du...
Ja, zum Beispiel kannst du bei Transmit an die Favorites auch noch eine URL, eine HTTP-URL, rangeben, sodass ich auf einem beliebigen File auf meinem Server Kontextklick machen kann und sag mir, gib mir die public HTTP-URL von dieser Datei. Klassischer Fall, Podcast hochladen, zack, bum, irgendwo eintragen und so. Und hier kann man zwar eine Base-URL angeben, aber er generiert mir dann nur eine SFTP-URL. Also nur so aus dem Kontext, wie ich sie hochgeladen habe und nicht wie sie sich öffentlich darstellt. Das ist so eins der schickeren Sachen bei Transmit. Ich benutze ansonsten SSH-Support hier mit Keychain etc. Das funktioniert alles genauso, wie das soll. Also das ist schon eine ganz ordentliche App so auf den ersten Blick. Macht auch Web-DAV, Amazon S3.
Macht auch, also ich weiß nicht, Panic.
Macht auch AFP.
Die machen halt, das Ding ist halt bei Panic, die machen halt ewig lange keine Updates. Da gab es irgendwie ein halbes Jahr keine Updates und ich hab irgendwie bei denen schon diverse Issues mal gefeilt. Und dann gab es irgendwie so Mails zurück, ja, kümmern wir uns drum, nie wieder was von gehört. Dann haben sie sogar manche Issues noch verschlimmert mit Updates und ich weiß nicht, irgendwie diese Panic-Jungs, die machen zwar immer alles so fancy, schick und bunt, aber ich finde die Apps eigentlich am Ende des Tages doch nicht so geil. Also dieses Coda ist aber auch von Panic, ne? Also die erste Version ist so ein Riesen-Bohaj und die Webseite sieht schick aus und du denkst dir, boah geil, ja, und ich will es benutzen, dann benutze es und denkst dir, nee. Naja, ich weiß nicht, für bestimmte Anwendungsfälle mag das vielleicht alles ganz schön und gut sein, so für Leute, die jetzt gerade anfangen, vielleicht mit ihrem ersten PHP-Projekt oder so, aber für...
Also Coda probiert halt so das Ding für alles zu sein, also so eine für alles und das ist halt nicht so richtig super geil. Vielleicht wird es jetzt mit Coda 2 besser. Also sie haben da so ein Terminal drin und was die Notwendigkeit daran ist, nochmal so ein Terminal, noch mal zusätzlich...
Ich bin das.
Mach mal höher. Bist du aus dem Kanal raus.
Und was da jetzt vielleicht daran spricht...
Hört man mich nachher?
Warum man jetzt nochmal so eine Terminal-App noch mal in Coda einbauen muss, ich versteh's nicht. Das ist ja nun wirklich mal ein gelöstes Problem. Und jeder, der ein Terminal nutzt, der wird wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ich möchte mein I-Term oder mein Terminal oder was auch immer haben. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich finde, dass man sich bei ihnen durchaus... Sie machen sich im Usability halt eine Menge Gedanken. Man würde vielleicht nicht zwangsläufig an jedem Punkt zum selben Ergebnis kommen wie sie, aber auf jeden Fall machen sie sich viele Gedanken und haben immer interessante Ergebnisse, finde ich zumindest.
Sie haben interessante Ergebnisse.
Sie versuchen halt so ein bisschen die Grenzen von diesem Coco so ein bisschen nach vorne zu schieben. Also man sieht immer so Sachen, die man woanders einfach noch nicht gesehen hat. Ob das jetzt wirklich irgendwie ein Benefit bringt oder nicht, das ist nochmal dahingestellt. Aber zum Beispiel halt hier dieses irgendwie ein Transmit hier, wenn du so editierst, so diese Art von Dialoge und so, die gab es irgendwie so gefühlt auch, weiß nicht, irgendwie so diese Interface-Elemente das erste Mal da.
Genau.
Und ich glaube, die waren auch die ersten auf dem Mac, die dieses Zweigeteilt haben. Ich nutze ja Transit niemals im Zweigeteiltemodus, aber es gibt viele Leute, die schwören darauf.
Die waren auch die erste ab mit Helvetica Neue.
Das heißt der Norton Commander.
Der Norton Commander Modus.
Sag mal Tim.
Ja, in dem muss man sich manchmal befinden.
In deinem Transmit, wenn du gerade auf dem Server connected bist, geht bei dir Apfel, Alt, G.
Budre sehr zack weg ist es.
Ich bin verbunden.
Und was soll dann gehen?
Apfel, Alt, G.
Sollen wir dann Autocomplete machen?
Und dann Go To oder was?
Geht da bei dir ein Dialog auf? Mal gucken, es gab kürzlich wieder ein Update. Das ging gefühlte zwei Jahre nicht. Bei mir geht es immer noch nicht.
Was Universal benutzt du denn?
Ich hab noch nicht geupdatet. Ich hab noch nicht geupdatet, mal gucken.
Ach, beschwerst dich, dass hier nie Updates kommen und dann installierst du sie nicht mehr.
Die kamen wirklich ungelogen. Innerhalb eines Monats haben sie mal wieder drei meiner Versions rausgeschoben. Aber davor ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr nicht.
Also ich find ja noch so, wenn man so SFTP macht und dieses ganze Zeug, dann bin ich leider, war jahrelang irgendwie so der Standard, Interarki, beziehungsweise ganz ganz früher noch Anarki, so mit FTP Client und SFTP.
Aus den späten 70ern der, ne?
Genau, und der gibt's jetzt Inter, also die sind dann irgendwann leider total nach hinten gefallen. Dann gab's dann irgendwann Interarki 7 und der ist jetzt wieder, also too late, too little halt, der hat auch irgendwie den Besitzer gewechselt zwischen Interarki 10, also 10, die sind schon viel, viel weiter, aber auf jeden Fall ist es trotzdem die Version, die ich meine. Und das sieht auch ganz cool aus. Die haben vor allen Dingen auch so ein paar schöne Sachen, wie die können dir einen Gzip direkt auf dem Server erstellen. Also die machen einfach eine SSH-Verbindung auf, wechseln den Ordner, machen Gzip draus und so was. Was leider zumindest in der Version, die ich damals getestet habe, noch nicht ging, dass man dann auch eigene Befehle da oben ausführen konnte auf dem Server und so was. Aber ansonsten war das ein extrem mächtiges Tool. Also mit dem man wirklich, also was einen wirklich unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten, ja mächtig viel, toll. Guckt euch mal an, wenn ihr mal, wenn ihr, wenn ihr Transmit nicht wollt, dann guckt euch mal Interarchy an.
Und wenn euch Interarchy nicht gefällt, dann gibt's noch den uralten Fetch, dann haben wir sie alle zusammen.
Fetch? Gibt's den auch noch?
Ja, den seh ich gerade. Also den gibt's seit 23 Jahren. 159 Dog-Years, meinen sie.
Und der hat auch noch ne Floppy-Disc im Maul.
Das ist auch noch der hässliche 3D-Hund.
Unter Mac OS 9 sah der Hund noch richtig cool aus.
Der hat sich animiert.
Da hat die auch im Cursor, während er downgeladen hat, sich animiert.
Oh Gott, sieht der scheiße aus.
Naja, und der sieht halt scheiße aus.
Die haben halt irgendwann mal...
Das Interface, das ist ja zum Teil...
Da gibt's auch Mac App Store Menschen.
Da sieht der Cyber Duck schicker aus.
Aber da war damals cool, die hatten so ein ganz, ganz simples Interface und als dann Mac OS 8 kam oder so, oder bei Sieben schon, als alles bunt wurde, wurde deren Programm einfach auch bunt, weil sie sich wirklich an den Standard gehalten haben und sie mussten sozusagen nichts umkoden, weil alles weiter lief, wo alle anderen erst mal neue koden mussten, weil sie meinten, sie müssten ihr eigenes Kuri machen.
Ey, was nicht alles heutzutage im Mac App Store ist. Also sogar Cyber Duck ist Mac App Store und ich bin ja fast...
Das ist doch Open Source und das kann man sich kostenlos runterladen.
Ja, aber ich bin fast gewillt, tatsächlich da drauf zu drücken, weil ich schon so oft dank Cyber Duck irgendwie, weil ich mal gerade nicht irgendwie für irgendjemanden Geld ausgeben wollte für einen SFTP-Client, da kostenlos davon gekommen bin, ja.
Aber ehrlich gesagt wäre ich mir hier nicht so sicher, ob es bei dem Richtigen ankommt, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Aber es ist David Kocher, das ist doch der Typ hier, oder nicht?
Dem habe ich tatsächlich mal Geld überwiesen irgendwie. Aber weil der in der Schweiz sitzt, hat irgendwie... Hat von den 30 Euro sich die Bank einfach erstmal 10 Euro genommen.
Na gut, das soll bei Apple jetzt im Store genauso sein, leider.
CyberDuck hat sich auch weiterentwickelt, kann jetzt mittlerweile Amazon S3. Das war damals, Fans mit war das auch das erste, was Amazon S3 konnte.
Aber ist das nicht Java gewesen?
CyberDuck?
Ja, doch, CyberDuck war Java. Es ist vielleicht sogar immer noch Java, keine Ahnung. Es ist nicht der tollste Programm, aber es ist gratis und kann schon extrem viel. Und zum Beispiel, ich hatte halt mit Transmit echt weirde Probleme teilweise irgendwie, wo, obwohl die Leitung frei war und ich auf der Konsole zum Beispiel irgendwie vollen Durchsatz bekommen hat, hat der nach 5 Minuten einfach nur noch 4 Kilo bei die Sekunde durchgelassen oder irgendwie so eine komischen Sachen. Und CyberDuck immer am Start.
Ich benutze seit Jahren CyberDuck und das ist so ein so ein klassisches gut genug Programm. Also es ist gut genug, als dass ich nicht irgendwas anderes einsetzen müsste. Und mich an irgendwas anderes gewöhnen.
Na das hängt natürlich immer davon ab, wie oft man es dann tatsächlich braucht. Wenn man es nur sehr selten braucht, dann reicht es wahrscheinlich schon. Ich hab eine Zeit lang hab ich sehr, sehr oft einen SFTP-Client gebraucht und da war ich dann immer schon auf der Suche nach, was ist da das Beste, was jetzt gerade noch so geht.
Ganz früher hab ich ja Fugu benutzt.
Fugu, stimmt, das gab's ja auch noch mal.
Ich guck hier gerade noch. Aber CyberDuck kann zum Beispiel auch Google Drive, kann Windows, Azure, Dropbox. Also die sind auch total am Start.
Ich such grad nach dem... Es gibt ja auch so ein paar Clients mit Finder-Integration mittlerweile, die ja alle auf MacFuse basieren, also die dann quasi das Remote-Laufwerk als Platte mounten.
Ja, das macht Transmit und Forklift glaube ich zum Beispiel auch.
Transmit macht das mittlerweile vernünftig? Oder die haben das eine Zeit lang, war das irgendwie sehr scheiße gelöst, dass das eigentlich nur ein Ordner auf deiner Platte war, der dann gesyncht worden ist oder sowas? Was natürlich auch sehr geil sein kann, also quasi eine Art Dropbox-Mode, was natürlich ganz gut ist. Expand Drive, genau, das ist es ja. Mal gucken, das habe ich jetzt auch schon seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr offen gehabt. Weil, ui, ist nur eine kleine Version von 2.3.0 auf 2.3.1 das Update gekommen. Und das kann dann so Sachen wie, das hat sozusagen SFTP Client mit Minimalfunktion, nämlich dass man einfach mal sagt, mountet das im Finder und dann kann man den Finder drauf zugreifen. Ist ganz geil, wenn man in beliebigen Programmen bearbeiten möchte. Also, wenn man für unterschiedliche Dateiendungen unterschiedliche Editoren haben möchte.
Ich sehe gerade dieses Forklift, das kann sogar mit unserem CDN ordentlich sprechen. Oh, da kriegt nämlich Transmit total die Krise. Nee, richtiges CDN. Und die haben halt, wir benutzen deren Origin Server und die haben halt nicht so einfach Standardport 22, username, Passport, sondern...
Ja, aber welches Protokoll ist das jetzt?
Oder R-Sync. Und da kriegt Transmit halt bei denen total die Krise, weil das halt alles so Custom-Settings sind. Also auf der Command Line musst du da irgendwie noch 23 Options an einen SFDP ranhängen. Und irgendwie Transmit kackt da total ab. Ich brauch's grad mit Forklift und das rockt da einfach so durch. Der hat mir gerade wieder die Arbeit ein bisschen leichter gemacht.
Gibt's hier einen Forklift?
Für 80 Cent.
Und du kaufst das nur für 80 Cent?
Ja, jetzt fühl ich mich schäbig toll.
Ja, kaufst du's morgen gleich nochmal.
Kannst du's ja mir kaufen.
Schenken.
Ich würd's ja nicht kaufen, ich bin ja ein Commandline Nutzer.
Nicht mal für 79 Cent.
Nicht mal für 79 Cent, also echt nur.
Man muss sich ja nur kümmern und trallala, ein Commandline ist einfach irgendwie, auch wenn was nicht klappt, ich will noch mal mal einen Cursor hoch, Zack, Boom, Return und dann geht das nochmal.
Kann man dem dann hier irgendwie mal sagen, dass er nur eine Pain macht? Also dass er Switched to Single Pain.
Nur eine Pain in der Welt.
Single Pain ist gut, ja.
So, du willst ja bestimmt jetzt gleich ein neues Thema anschneiden, ne, Timme? Weil dann würd ich jetzt hier, wenn wir schon mal bei so Sachen dabei waren, und AFP hab ich jetzt zwischendurch auch gehört. Gestern kam nämlich von dem Neta-Talk, weil es ja jetzt, seit dem ZDF erst tot ist, muss ich mir ja was Neues einfallen lassen. Ich hab jetzt mal Neta-Talk genommen. Gibt's eine neue Version, 2.2.3. Und ich hab ja schon mal berichtet, dass ich da das Send-File für FreeBSD korrigiert hab. Und sie haben es ja gestern rausgebracht, die Version, wo das mit drin ist. Und er hat sogar meinen Namen erwähnt, ich bin ein bisschen stolz.
Und was war das Send-File, was?
Na, dass Neta-Talk auf FreeBSD auch Send-File unterstützt.
Das Send-File war nochmal was genau?
Na, dass das Programm nicht irgendwie das File von einer Platte einliest und dann blöckchenweise das Programm wieder rausschickt. Das heißt, die Daten müssen durch den Kernel zum User-Land und das User-Land sagt dann dem Kernel, ok, jetzt schickst du sie wieder raus. Sondern das Programm sagt dem Kernel, schick mal folgendes File direkt raus. Das heißt, die Daten, die du verschickst, landen gar nicht mehr erst im Programm, sondern der Kernel schickt es gleich von alleine raus. Dadurch sparst du halt ein bisschen Memory hin und her schieben, ein bisschen CPU-Cycle, könnte eventuell auf einer lahmen Kiste irgendwie schneller gehen, besonders wenn viel los ist. Ja, die anderen machen es auch, Linux macht es auch, aber da hatte das Netatalk halt bei FreeBSD irgendwie einen Fehler, weil das ist ein bisschen anders implementiert als bei Linux.
Hast du hier nicht die My Little Server FreeBSD Ultra Edition installiert, sondern nur das normale FreeBSD?
Ich? Ne, das Netatalk hatte den Fehler, nicht das FreeBSD. So, jetzt kommt aber noch das Wichtige für alle Leute, die halt FreeBSD und Netatalk mit Time-Maschinen benutzen. Die hatten bei Netatalk da irgendwie einen komischen Fehler, an den der ist bei mir auch mal vorgekommen. Da poppt so ein Fenster auf und dann sagt mir mein Time-Maschine, er konnte irgendwie das Backup nicht verifinen. Und ich sollte doch jetzt mal nochmal starten. Und nochmal starten heißt das, alles was da ist, wird gelöscht und du fängst frisch von vorne an. Ja, voll toll, denkst du dir?
Ja, das finde ich geil. Damit kommt dieses Teil auch gemäßig hoch.
Diesen Fehler habe ich aber auch von Time-Capsule-Usern gehört, die das alle zwei, drei Monate haben.
So, und jedenfalls bei Netatalk ist das auch. Das hat irgendwie einen Grund, dass da war irgendein Fehler und Netatalk meldet den auf eine bestimmte Weise zurück. Damit kam das Time-Machine auf dem Clienten nicht klar und hat dann gesagt, alles klar, du musst neu machen. Und diese Fehlermeldung haben sie jetzt leicht abgeändert, so wie sie es gehört. Anscheinend haben sie mal Specs gewesen oder was auch immer. Jedenfalls ist dieser Fehler jetzt wohl weg. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte den auch. Und ich hoffe, er kommt jetzt dann auch wohl nicht mehr vor. Also wie gesagt, Netatron 2.2.3. Weil sonst läuft es nämlich eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Und ab wann ist das dann durch das gesamte Portsystem von FreeBSD durch?
Ja, kommt doch an, wie schnell die da sind. Also kann ich nicht so genau sagen. Man kann ihn aber bei FreeBSD, ich hab's gestern gemacht, gleich runterladen, auspacken, Configure, Make, Install, Schub, fertig. Und danach irgendwie Sudo, Service, Netatalk, Restart, und dann bist du wieder voll dabei.
Das ist auch eigentlich so eine Sache, die auch bei den vielen Linux-Distributionen mich total anpisst. Dass die, wenn du da Software installierst, egal ob es jetzt aus einem Package kommt oder manuell gebaut, dass die sich nach User bin oder so installieren, die gehören alle gefälligst schön nach User Local bin. Und dass du ja dann in einer FreeBSD auch so einen Package baust, dann ist das halt da drin, wenn du irgendwann mal sagst, so Full Sweep irgendwie, fang mal von Scratch an, dann machst du halt nur User Local weg und musst nicht noch in Userlib und User, hast du nicht gesehen, nachgraben?
Dass das alles so durchmixed ist, ja?
Ja, die haben da überhaupt keine Konsequenz, so keine Hackordnung in ihren Distributionen.
Ein Kalender mit wochenweise Scrolling.
Nein, ganz einfach. Du kannst da wie im Finder sagen, Calculate all sizes und dir mal von diesen Scheißordnern auch die Größe anzeigen lassen. Das gibt es im Transmit nämlich nicht. Das erzeugt zwar ein bisschen Last, aber ist mir ehrlich gesagt scheißegal, wenn ich dafür weiß, wie viel da drin ist. Das ist immer so das große Rätsel. Wie groß ist die Scheiße eigentlich da auf dem Server? Und now I know. Hammer.
Gleich auch im Mac Absolute.
Ja, dann können wir nochmal nach Folder-Size sortieren und so und feststellen, dass der Mobile-Macs-Ordner der größte ist.
Natürlich.
Selbstverständlich.
Aber verpflichtet.
Wollen wir schon mal ein bisschen Fußballgesänge auch üben, ne?
Du mit deiner Stimme halt dich mal vielleicht ein bisschen zurück jetzt.
Ich komm mir selbst vor wie ein Alien. Wie ist das mit euch?
Es geht so. Du klingst zwar nach Fußballgesang, aber...
Ist schon schlimmer als gleich.
Ich komm mir nicht vor wie ein Alien.
Ist noch nicht wie Tim Wates.
Vielleicht können wir auch mal so ein paar Schunkel-Fußballgesänge so für die...
Ich meine...
Einfach mal so ein paar unterstützende Chöre so aus der Chat-Kurve wäre ja auch mal ganz gut, ne?
Und wer verschießt den Elfmeter?
Hauptsache, ihr schmeißt keine bengalischen Feuer durchs Fenster.
Heute das Google-Doodle, das war schon schön. Habt ihr gesehen?
Mit dem Moog, ich hab's bloß noch nicht zum Laufen bekommen.
Bei mir spielt's.
Welche Browser?
Safari 5 Beta hier.
Chrome ging auch super.
Warte mal, das machen wir hier gleich mal richtig.
Muss ich mich schämen, dass ich heute nicht gegoogelt hab?
Also ich benutze ja auch DuckDuckGo, aber gelegentlich muss ich mal. Hier kommt nichts.
Wie muss man das anschalten?
Also ich benutze einfach Safari 5 2 Beta 4.
Oder schmeißt Chrome an.
Oder Chrome, ja.
Ja, Moment.
Ach, hast du auch kein WebKit, verstehe.
Mit Chrome geht das.
Na was, jetzt haue ich die Tasten, Alter.
Und du kannst da oben einen Dreh knüpfen, kann man auch die ganzen, äh, Dings so verdrehen.
Was ist das für ein Teil? Ist das der Vorgänger der Hammond-Orgel oder was?
Nein, das ist der allererste Synthesizer.
Also der Vorgänger der Hammond-Orgel.
Nein, Hammond... Die Hammond-Orgel funktioniert anders. Die Hammond-Orgel...
Jetzt, lass doch mal jeden Rotti erzählen, der kennt sich da aus.
Die Hammond-Orgel musst du dir so vorstellen. Du hast eine große Welle, die wird von einem Motor angetrieben. Und auf dieser Welle sind lauter Zahnräder. Und an jedem Zahnrad ist mit einem Klappmechanismus so eine Art Gitarren-Elektro... So ein Gitarren-Tonabnehmer. So ein Elektromagnetischer. Wenn du eine Taste drückst, wird der Tonabnehmer in die Nähe des Zahnrads geklemmt, geklappt. Und dadurch, dass sich das Zahnrad an dem Tonabnehmer vorbei dreht, entsteht eine Schwingung.
Wie schnell dreht sich die Welle?
Weiß ich nicht. Aber das hat zur Folge, dass die Teile verdammt schwer sind. Weil es ist halt verdammt viel rotierendes Metall.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Rotierendes Gedöns.
Also nix ist SD.
Die sind scheiße teuer, die Dinger heutzutage, oder?
Ich glaube. Ich weiß es nicht. So, und der MOOC ist tatsächlich nur Elektronik. Ist zwar alles analog.
Verstehe, also der Hammond Orgel war wirklich vorher.
Hammond Orgel war Mechanik, Elektromechanik.
Hammond Orgel wurde erfunden 1960 irgendwann.
Und Wikipedia hilft uns weiter. Ich sehe schon die Welle da und den Abnehmer. Ich bin ja Fan der Hammond Orgel. Ich finde den voll geil.
Ganz groß.
1935.
Verstehe. Sag es gleich, die Nazis haben damit ihre U-Boote irgendwie in die Kommandos rüber geschenkt.
Und Henry Ford hat sich gleich sechs gekauft.
Wie immer.
Seit 1936 wurde das Instrument erfolgreich in Deutschland angeboten in Konkurrenz zu Edwin Weltes letztendlich erfolgloser Lichtton-Orgel. Gab schon ein paar ganz abgefahrene Geräte, aber MOOC ist halt jetzt wirklich sozusagen der Beginn der Synthesizer-Ära.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das Trautonium nicht noch älter?
Gute Frage.
Weil das ist ja mal so ein abgefahrene Musikinstrument, anbelangt nicht zu toppen, oder?
Und die Hörer können es dann gar nicht klicken, wenn sie die Sendung morgen hören, richtig?
Vielleicht gibt es ja so ein Preserve-Google-Doodle-Project.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt schon eine Seite, wo die alle aufgelistet sind.
Ja, es gibt so eine Seite.
Naja, so oder so ist einfach das...
Dann können wir die Seite mal verlinken....
ist halt MOOC, ist einfach ein Name in dem Bereich.
Ja, so wie Fender halt als Erfinder der elektrischen Gitarre gilt, so gilt halt MOOC als Erfinder des Synthesizers.
Dabei stimmt beides nicht meins.
Doch, doch, das ist schon alles bewegbar.
Das ist wahrscheinlich hier diskutierbar, so genau kann ich das jetzt nicht sagen, aber...
Elektronik gab's einfach noch nicht 1930, also konntest du da auch kein elektronisches Musikinstrument bauen.
Na doch, es gab's.
Das waren elektrische.
Nee, nee, es gab Röhren. Diodentrioden? Also keine Ahnung, ob da auch Röhren drin waren im MOOC oder...
Was meinst du, was der Turing da gemacht hat?
Der Turing? Hat der auch Musik gemacht?
Nee, aber Krypto. Mit Elektronik.
Ja. Das will ich mir auch gar nicht absprechen.
Also ich meine, auch das erste Radio war ja Elektronik. Also es ist ja keine Elektromechanik gewesen.
Das erste Radio.
So Funkwellen und dann spricht da jemand raus aus so einem Kasten.
Ja, würdest du das als Elektronik bezeichnen? Elektronik ist für mich Elektrik, die mit Informationen agiert. Das ist das, was die Elektrik von der Elektronik unterscheidet.
Genau.
Und wo ist da die Information?
Der Content, aber das stimmt, das ist ein bisschen ein Unterschied.
Ja, die wird übertragen. Von Schall über Funk wieder zurück auf Schall.
Das ist keine Digitalelektronik.
Lass uns das nicht vertiefen.
Das können wir später ausfechten.
Auf jeden Fall war das das Google-Doodle. Wie kam man dazu? Wir kamen nur über das Google-Doodle dazu oder gab es da?
Hokel hat das mal so reingeworfen und wir haben zugeschnappt.
Verstehe, einfach so kommt ein Thema, geflogen.
Kommt ein Thema. Genau, das dachte ich auch gerade.
Ich hab noch eine App zu vermelden. Und zwar, genau genommen sogar zwei. Wo wir schon hier so beim Empfehlen sind. Ein von mir ja schon seit Ewigkeiten verwendetes Tool, JustNotes, lag ja ewig brach, weil der Developer, glaube ich, anderes zu tun hatte, im Sinne von mal irgendwie Uni zu Ende bringen oder sowas. Und ich hatte ja immer geklagt über das Programm, weil es zwar an sich ganz schön war, aber so ein paar Dinge nicht so gemacht hat, wie ich das wollte. Und ich hatte schon so ein bisschen die Hoffnung aufgegeben und dann erreichte mich vor ein paar Wochen so die ersten Mails mit ja, hier, neue Beta-Versionen und ich dachte mir so, dann tat sich dann doch was. Und jetzt ist das Ding vor einer Woche oder so, glaube ich, in den Upstore gekommen, kostet 5 Euro und macht das mit dem Simple Note gut. Bisher keine nennenswerten Issues damit, es ist definitiv eine Verbesserung. Es gibt auch eine zweite Macintosh-App, die als Simple Note-Client arbeitet, die heißt Metanota. Klingt zwar erstmal ganz charming für mich, aber hat sich dann für mich nicht ganz so gut angefühlt. War schon wieder so ein bisschen komplizierter und legt Wert auf Text und so. Aber das ist dann eben die Frage, wer was lieber mag. Und kann man beides mal evaluieren. Also Just Notes funktioniert gut und der Name ist an der Stelle auch Programm. Das ist einfach Just Notes. Das ist für mich einfach der Ort, wo ich mal eben schnell einen Gedanken reinschreiben kann. Und ich weiß, dass der sich dann einfach über diesen Syncing-Service auf alle meine Devices verbreitet. Und seitdem jetzt dieses unsägliche Zurückscrollen nach Sync nicht mehr drin ist, kann man es jetzt auch für längere Dokumente wunderbar benutzen. Okay, das ist jetzt keine Revolution im Notizhimmel. Aber es ist jetzt erstmal so, wie es sein muss. Ich hab noch so ein paar Detailissues, aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann man das Fenster nicht ordentlich resizen. Also es gibt da eine maximale Größe, was ich vollkommen bekloppt halte, weil ich hier einen 27 Zoll Bildschirm habe, dann will ich auch das Fenster so groß machen können.
Ne, 80 Zeichen pro Zeile ist genug für jeden.
Ja und man kann dann aber auch diese Liste links mit den Dings, hat auch ein Maximum, wie breit es sein kann, aber das ist einfach alles Quatsch. Also mit Minimal kann ich erleben, aber Maximal sind einfach Blödsinn. Wenn ich das größer haben will, dann will ich das größer haben und fertig. Ich kann ja auch meinen Font größer machen.
Du Tim, hier gerade im Chat, da klicken wir auf den Link, da gibt es eine iOS-Podcast-App mit Flattr-Integration. Dort hier gemeldet. Hat sogar ein Flattr-Logo im Icon. Ist schon...
Ja, das ist sehr interessant. Ist eigentlich kostenlos.
Achso, das war ja das Problem.
Ja, das ist und zwar arbeitet die zusammen. Flattr-Pod heißt das Ding. Die arbeitet auf der Basis, dass es die manuell mit iTunes gesüngten Podcasts in der Music-Up sich anschaut. Davon über die Namen, glaube ich.
Ja, okay, brauchst nicht weiter sprechen.
Versucht ein Match zu machen. Und dann das flattert. Aber soweit ich weiß, geht das auch auf die Webseite. Da gibt es keine API-Integration. Das Ding ist ein bisschen älter noch als die API.
Wie gesagt, sorry, ich hab blind auf den Chat-Link geklickt. Das ist ja in Ordnung.
Ich hatte das auch nicht mehr so richtig in Erinnerung. So sieht es aus. Ja, das war das hier mit den Editoren. Wenn der Entwickler hier von JustNotes zuhört, bitte macht das Fenster, diese Fensterbegrenzung raus. So, wollen wir nochmal ein Update bringen zu Editoren? Wie häufig habt ihr eure Default-Editorin gewechselt in den letzten Wochen?
Einmal.
Es gibt keinen Default-Editor bei mir so richtig.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Irgendwie nerven sie alle. Also bei Xcode hab ich momentan das Gefühl, oder das Problem, dass Xcode mit diesen im Betriebssystem eingebauten Versions nicht richtig klar kommt und mir immer wieder meint, hintenrum hätte sich eine Datei geändert und er möchte jetzt die, die ich gerade editiert habe und speichern will, möchte er jetzt entweder nicht speichern oder überschreiben oder von hinten irgendwas, ich hab keine Ahnung, das nervt irgendwie mindestens fünf bis sechs Mal am Tag. Und ich dachte, es wäre ein Xcode-Problem, aber es ist leider auch in Chocolate aufgetreten. Genau das gleiche Problem, weswegen ich das Gefühl habe, es ist ein Leilen-Problem.
Was ist das Problem?
Das Problem ist, dass du in Xcode irgendwie eine Datei editierst, dann sagst Bild und dann sagt er dir, die Datei hat sich geändert, weil verschiedene Teile von Xcode der Meinung sind, sie hätten verschiedene Versionen von dieser Dings, die du da gerade offen hast. Und dann kannst du nur trotzdem Speichern oder Revert sagen und je nachdem, wo du draufdrückst, hast du dann entweder die uneditierte Datei wieder oder die, die du editiert hast, aber es ist immer so ein bisschen ein Ratespiel, welchen von den beiden Buttons du drücken musst, damit du dann hinterher die Datei kriegst, die du haben willst. Ich weiß nicht, wo es herkommt, keine Ahnung.
Mit Sim wäre doch nicht passiert. Das kenn ich gar nicht. Hat eigentlich jemand von euch dieses, da gibt's doch dieses Eclipse-basierte, also bei uns hier gibt's da so ein paar Developer, die jetzt statt Xcode für IOS dieses App-Code benutzen. Und das ist aber für euch keine Option.
Ja, dann müsst ihr ja vorher erstmal Eclipse lernen.
Ist das nicht Eclipse-basiert oder so?
Das ist IntelliJay.
Ach, IntelliJay, naja.
IntelliJay ist um einiges besser als Eclipse. Eclipse ist pain in the ass. IntelliJay und die ganzen Derivate kann man gut mitarbeiten. Wie gesagt, ich hab ja schon mal von PHPStorm oder WebStorm vorgeschwärmt. Und das funktioniert soweit ganz gut. Hat ein paar schöne Features drin, die Xcode auch so nicht hat. Haben wir glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Hier guck mal, da schreibt einer im Chat, er hätte mein Problem schon mit Coda gehabt. Also es scheint ein Betriebssystem-Problem mit diesen komischen Versions zu sein. Weil wie gesagt, ich hatte es auch schon in zwei Editoren. Es ist irgendwie ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Das haben die bei Apple halt nicht bedacht. Ein Dokument in zwei Sachen offen. Wie soll denn das gehen bei einem User?
Na ja gut, also Xcode. Ein Schlachtschiff, dann haben wir dieses Appcode. Schlachtschiff Nummer zwei.
Also Chocolate benutze ich jetzt seit einiger Zeit für, wenn ich mal was in Erlang mache. Ähm, Subether Edit benutze ich eigentlich immer dann, wenn ich eine Datei vom Terminal aus öffnen möchte.
Warum das denn?
Weil ich das erstens schon seit Jahren benutze. Und zweitens, weil dieser Befehl, also es tut halt einfach das, was es soll.
Ja, aber das gibt es auch für Chocolate auch. Da gibt es auch dieses Choc-Command.
Ja, aber Chocolate will mir irgendwie auch immer so, weiß ich nicht, andere Sachen unterjubeln, keine Ahnung. Mit Chocolate hab ich es jetzt noch nicht so ausprobiert. Hab es eine Weile mit Text-Mate probiert, aber das nervt irgendwie auch, wenn man das von der Kommandozeile aus macht.
Warum, da muss man Marta eintippen.
Ja, das mag für dich irgendwie...
Was musst du denn eintippen? Du musst einfach ETA... oder was ist denn der...
Und was macht das anders jetzt als ein Maid?
Also du könntest die eigentlich in Alias setzen und alles wäre gut.
Ja, also das verwende ich vor allen Dingen, wenn ich sowas mache wie Rebase in Git und dann irgendwelche Konflikte kriege, dann mache ich halt das auf der Kommandozeile schnell in SubEtherEdit auf und suche nach den Dingern da. Was auch sehr schön ist bei SubEtherEdit ist, du kannst dieses Ding aufklappen, wo er dir die ganzen Methodennamen auflistet, wo die sind, also zumindest in einem Objective-Stick-File. Und da zeigt dir dann da zwischendrin an, hier ist ein Konflikt und da ist ein Konflikt und dort ist ein Konflikt. Das funktioniert nicht immer hundertprozentig gut, aber meistens ist das ganz okay. Also dafür verwende ich Sub-Ether-Edit. Sub-Ether-Edit ist wieder blöd, wenn du so eine Art Projekt hast, weil du musst dann doch tatsächlich jede Datei einzeln aufmachen. Dafür finde ich Chocolate wieder ganz gut. Da kannst du halt irgendwie ein Verzeichnis als Projekt abspeichern und dann holst du dir per Doppelklick dieses Projekt hoch und dann ist da irgendwie alles drin, was du brauchst.
Und Chocolate kann im Vergleich zu manch anderem GUI-Editor sowas wie Split Views.
Ja, Split View interessiert mich überhaupt nicht, was mich an TextMate zum Beispiel total nervt, dass es so langsam ist. Mir ist es viel zu langsam, es ist total sloppy.
Wie Textmater im Vergleich zu Chocolate oder allen.
Im Vergleich zu allen Editoren ist es total...
Also TextMate 2.1.
Mach mal ein großes XML-File in TextMate auf, sowas wie ein Xcode-Projekt-File, was ja eigentlich nur ein großes XML-File ist, wo du halt manchmal Konflikte drin hast irgendwie durch deine Versionskontrolle. Und das schnarcht sich da eins zurecht. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Also...
Ja, naja, also...
Mit TextMate 2 wird bestimmt alles viel, viel besser, aber darüber reden wir nochmal, wenn's da ist.
TextMate 2, die Alpha, ist schon auch einigermaßen sluggish. Also der schnellste Editor, der gerade so... Also der schnellste GUI-Editor, der gerade so auf dem Markt ist, finde ich, ist Sublime Text 2, der ist einfach performant ohne Ende. Also wirklich super snappy. Egal, wenn du da einen riesen Projekt-File drin hast und du machst das Passive-Finder-Command-T, weißt schon, fängst an irgendein Wort zu tippen, wo du weißt, das kommt in dem Feilnamen vor, ja? Und dann irgendwie ist er so zack sofort da.
Was ist das für ein scheiß Name?
Ja, der Name ist scheiße, aber der Editor ist eigentlich...
Der hat den neulich spontan... Also ich hab mich ja immer damit mit... Ja, ich nehme immer noch die Shareware-Version und ja, ich bezahle immer noch nicht durchgedrückt, bis ich dann jetzt auf das Sublime Package Control gestoßen bin. Das ist so ein Package Manager für Sublime Erweiterungen. Und da ist alles dabei. Da ist echt... Also ich hab mir auch so was gesucht, wie weil ich diesen R-Made Befehl, einen Text-Made sehr geil finde. Also das ist so ein kleines Skript, installiert man sich auf dem Server. Und dann ruft man auf dem Server halt R-Made Dateiname auf und dann macht er einem über eine SSH-Verbindung auch eine Datei auf in Text-Made. Und das hätte ich gerne... Das war das, was mir noch fehlte, zu meinem Glück. Und dergleichen habe ich für Sublime gefunden. Und der Befehl ist auch, heißt R-Sub. Und das lässt sich halt über diesen Package Control installieren. Und das ist eine Riesenauswahl an Tools und Erweiterungen und allem möglichen Scheiß, mit dem man sich sein Sublime je nach Wunsch perfekt zurecht konfigurieren kann oder komplett zerschießen. Also es hat so ein paar Sachen nachgerüstet, wie ich mag es ja ganz gerne, wenn in dieser Projektansicht, die man drin hat, wenn immer die Datei, die man gerade offen hat, auch da ausgewählt ist, weil ich meistens eine Datei als nächstes im selben Ordner bearbeiten möchte. Und dafür gibt es eine Erweiterung. Also es gibt wirklich unglaublich viele Erweiterungen dafür. Es gibt so Sachen, dass du irgendwie, wenn du eine Datei unter Versionskontrolle auf GitHub hast, dass du einen Textbereich auswählen kannst und sagst, mach mir einen Link draus, der auf GitHub genau diesen Bereich auswählt. Und so eine Spezl, du kannst Gists direkt daraus machen. Also es gibt eigentlich nichts, wofür es nicht irgendeine Erweiterung gibt für Sublime.
Und das Schöne ist auch noch, es ist halt Cross-Plattform. Also wenn wir dann irgendwann alle auf Linux wechseln müssen, wenn man dann sich mit Sublime angefreundet hätte, müsste man sich nicht groß umgewöhnen und hätte trotzdem einen schicken, schnellen Editor. Und für Windows gibt es das sogar auch.
Also ich hab mir Sublime angeguckt, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, warum es nicht verfangen hat. Vielleicht muss ich nochmal gucken.
Na es gibt ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob es so lange her ist, dass es noch Sublime Text war oder schon Sublime Text 2. Also ich bin ja dann jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich, weil ich ja gerade am so meinem Farbschema für Terminal und so weiter alles mögliche schraube. Da hab ich ja dann Eat Your Own Dog Food. Wenn ich schon Vim und Terminal Theme mache, dann muss ich natürlich jetzt auch Vim benutzen. Und jetzt bin ich gerade so hardcore wieder auf Vim drauf. Hab erstmal meinen ganzen Dot Vim Folder weggeschmissen und hab von From Scratch meine VimRC und so alles nochmal neu sauber geschrubbt. Auf GitHub natürlich auch alles gestellt, für die Nachwelt erhalten. Und der Vim hat auch einfach schon coole Features. Der hat auch Features, die hat auch kein anderer Editor. Das ist wie bei Emacs natürlich. Die Emacs-Freunde können sich gleich beruhigen. Alles, was ich über Vim sage, trifft auch fast natürlich und noch viel mehr auf Emacs zu. Ich benutze TextMate 1 als mein neues Text-Edit. TextMate ist mein neues Text-Edit. Immer wenn ich mal kurz ein Snippet weghacken muss, in Plain texte ich dann mal in TextMate auf. Für Code-Brausen, Sublime und für Editieren oder Mac-Wim besser gesagt. Und das war's, glaube ich, an Editoren, was ich benutze gerade.
Es gibt noch einen Punkt, für den ich, ich bin ja großer Freund von BB-Edit, lange gewesen. Ich hab den auch noch heute immer drauf. Und wofür ich den heute immer noch aufmache, ist, wenn ich mal einfach eine HTML-Datei, so eine Boilerplate dafür brauche. Weil der hat so Templates drin, die ich mir nie, die so ein HTML-5-Template, wo ich nur auswählen brauche, Dateiname eintragen, dann kann ich anfangen. Und ich brauch den ganzen Scheiß nicht jedes Mal zu tippen. Und das vermisse ich, also es gibt garantiert irgendwelche Texts, Snippets, Tools, 100.000er, auch für Sublime, aber einfach mal so ein... Kennt da jemand irgendwas wirklich Geiles, wo man einfach mal sagen kann, okay, ich mach eine neue Datei auf, mach mir so ein HTML-5-Skelett rein und dann kann ich anfangen und direkt abspeichern, wenn das jemand hätte.
BBLit ist einfach extrem abgehangene Software. Also das ist...
Gibt's auch schon ewig, oder? War mal ein R3-Editor.
20 Jahre oder so bestimmt.
Ja, aber als ich dann nach OS X gewechselt hab, irgendwie war damals BBLit noch scheiße.
Ja, aber die haben die Kurve echt gekriegt. Und dann irgendwie sukzessive sind sie dann so auf diesen OS X-Weg gekommen.
Ich wurde damit noch nie warm und ich werde wahrscheinlich auch nie warm werden.
Ich hab's mir aber immer noch nicht gekauft.
Also womit ich nicht warm geworden bin, ist mit Emacs. Es gab mal auf dem Amiga, das wurde irgendwie mitgeliefert, gab es ein Programm, das nannt sich Micro Emacs. Und da konnte man dann halt irgendwie wie im Emacs tippen. Und dann hatte einem im Pulldown-Menü diese ganzen abstrusen Emacs-Befehle angezeigt, wo man immer doppelt mit Control irgendwelche Sachen tippen musste. Eine Weile wusste ich auch noch die Befehle. Das Schlimmste an Emacs ist ja, du wirst reingeschmissen und kommst nicht mehr raus, weil du nicht weißt, wie du da...
Ja, das ist bei Vim ja auch erstmal so.
Bei Vim oder VI ist es natürlich auch so, das ist richtig.
Aber also mein erster Editor auf so Terminal und so war ja glaube ich tatsächlich... Mein erster Editor... .war auch Emacs tatsächlich, weil hier der Aaron, der war ja schon immer so ein Lisp-Coder und so und so ein Scheme-Coder und der hat mir irgendwie dann Emacs verpasst und dann mir die grundlegenden Befehle gezeigt und dann war ich auch erstmal eine Weile... Nee, damals hatte der Emacs halt auch, das fand ich, das ästhetischste Code-Highlighting und so weiter. Der war irgendwie so out of the box, hatte der dann in der GUI-Variante einfach schon einen ordentlichen Fond, ordentliche Farben und sah irgendwie nach was aus. Und deswegen, ich als Ästhet, ja, bin da erstmal so ein bisschen deswegen da hängen geblieben. Weil wenn du so ein Vim erstmal aus der Box holst, dann kriegst du ja, also da brennt ja die Retina quasi. Das ist ja...
Auch bei Nicht-Retina.
Ich benutze ja immer noch gerne VI.
Kein Vim, sondern VI.
Ja, also ich fand Vim schon total bloated und hatte lange, lange Zeit. Na Vim war einfach nie so richtig VI-kompatibel, das hat mich immer extrem gestört.
Aber ich finde VI auch echt, also das ist einfach zu, da ist zu wenig. Also da gibt es ja nicht mal, da gibt es ja nicht mal Block-Select, also so Vertical-Select und so. Das sind ja so essentielle Coding.
Das ist einfach der Editor für Asketen.
Asketen? Asketen?
Das coole ist beim VI halt, du hast ein neues System eingerichtet und du hast halt den VI schon.
Ja, das gibt es auf jedem System außer FreeBSD. Gibt's Vim.
Ja, weil die alle so bloated sind.
Ja, aber Vim lädt länger als VI.
Als VI stabil läuft.
Kannst du mir nicht erzählen, mein Vim ist eins, zwei fix oben.
Ja, mit der SST, klar.
Mein Vim ist eins, zwei fix oben.
Ich sag dir, ich hab den Unterschied bemerkt, auch noch unter UST in den ersten Jahren.
Standard Vim?
Mittlerweile ist die Zeit, das war nicht immer so. Bist du sicher? Ja, da bin ich mir sehr sicher, weil ich das genau weiß.
Aber bei USTX ist es mittlerweile Standard Vim.
Ja, mittlerweile ist das alles verschmolzen und ich prangere das auch an. Aber ich konnte VI so bedienen, dass ich sofort gemerkt habe, dass ich in einem Vim bin, weil es sich anders verhalten hat. Dafür dürft ihr mich jetzt einerseits bewundern, andererseits als alten Scheißer.
Also mir ist es total egal.
Das ist das Schlimmste. Ich geh mal und bring mich um.
Aber ich weiß noch, wie du mir Shift-J im VI beigebracht hast.
Hab ich dir beigebracht?
Ja, hab ich letztens erst wieder so einen alteingesessenen Hacker gezeigt und der kannte das auch nicht.
Aber Vim, da gibt es auch...
Zwei Zeilen zusammenfügen.
Da gibt es schon echt viele coole Commands. Ich hab letztens... Viele coole Commands. Ich lese ja nicht nur das Classic Shell Scripting-Buch jetzt gerade von der Rare Design, ich hab natürlich auch zwei VI und Vim-Bücher, die ich so gelegentlich mal durchstöbere. Das kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, der auch nur manchmal in diesem Vim hängt, weil so das erste Kapitel von jedem dieser Bücher, wo so grundlegend mal erklärt wird, wie das überhaupt mit diesen Commands funktioniert und wie das gedacht ist, das öffnet einem die Augen und danach hat man erstmal 100% mehr Spaß. Also wenn man dann so liest irgendwie, du kannst hier mit eine Nummer vor deinen Commands und dann wird es uns so oft wiederholt und solche Sachen. Oder die Movement-Commands und damit hast du dann plötzlich und dann auch Makros und...
Ja, ich finde das auch kulturell eine extreme Hilfe. Also selbst wenn man von den Commandos selber nichts hat, allein schon mal zu wissen, was das so mit HJKL auf sich hat, da stößt man doch immer wieder an ganz anderen Stellen da drauf.
Da gab es doch dieses Spiel, dieses Net... NetHack, das hat doch auch diese HJKL verwendet.
Ja, das ist einfach mal die Cursor-Steuerung. HJKL ist einfach Cursor-Steuerung. Als es noch Tastaturenstandard waren, die geile Cursor-Tasten hatten. Irgendwie musste man doch dieses scheiß Cursor steuern. Deswegen gibt es ja ja diese ganzen Mumpets mit Escape und diesen zwei Modi beim VI überhaupt. So diesen Edit-Modus und sonst wie Drüberflieg-Modus.
In dem Wim-Buch wird einem das auch ganz gut nahegebracht. Warum das auch immer noch eine gute Idee ist mit diesem Escape, weil du dann halt immer jeden Schritt einmal so terminiert hast und dann deinen Repeater-Möglichkeiten halt auch sagen kannst. Ja, genau jetzt den Schritt oder den davor oder Ando. Du kannst halt genau immer sozusagen den Punkt setzen, wenn jetzt ein Schritt in deinem Editier-Vorgang zu Ende ist.
Das Spiel heißt übrigens, es war NetHack, aber das Original heißt ja Rogue. Das NetHack war ja auch schon nachgemacht.
Was ja richtig nervig ist dann nämlich bei diesem Ando.
Also erst kam Rogue, dann kam Hack und dann kam NetHack.
Ich seh schon, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich krieg hier nochmal ein bisschen ein Mani-Mani-Rom.
Den Source als Rogue, den gibt's übrigens und kann man sich halt selber kompilieren und dann das Amulett von Jendo versuchen, sich zu kriegen. Hatte ich zu Hause mal auf meinem Freebase gelaufen, da gab's dann einen Telnet-Port, konntest du mit Telnet irgendwie auf einem Port 5.000 einloggen und dann konntest du da Rogue spielen bei mir mit HighSquare.
Könntest dich mal wieder an den Start bringen.
Was mich bei NetHack, ich weiß nicht, haben wir jemals darüber schonmal hier gesprochen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was ich so geil fand, ist, dass das so unfassbar cool mit diesem Betriebssystem verzahnt war. Du warst so in deinem Unix, hast NetHack gespielt. Also für die Leute, die jetzt überhaupt noch nicht verstanden haben, wovon wir eigentlich reden, NetHack ist so Dungeon Adventure.
Kann bestimmt ein Hörer im Chat schonmal einen Rechner rausfinden, wo man mit Telnet irgendwie NetHack macht, dann verlinken wir das. Gibt's auf jeden Fall.
Da bin ich mir auch ziemlich sicher. Man machte das alles natürlich auf der Kommandozeile, weil was anderes gab es nicht. Und im Wesentlichen sah man irgendwie nichts. Man hatte quasi so eine leere Karte. Und während man dann eben so durch so einen Dungeon, so ein Labyrinth, so ein Kellerlabyrinth lief, von Level zu Level, naja, entfaltete sich so langsam die Karte vor einem.
Und alles, wo man schon mal war, das lief auch da.
Alles in ASCII, muss man dazu sagen. Und das Coole war, dass die Welten auto generiert wurden.
Das war noch nicht normal damals. Das war das erste Game, wo sich die Welt selber generiert hat.
Müsste sie sogar, weil...
Gab's ja nichts anderes.
Hätte man gar nicht wegspeichern können irgendwie. Hätte alles viel zu viel Platz gebraucht. So, und dann lief man da halt irgendwie rum und musste halt irgendwie Monster bekämpfen und dann halt dieser übliche Schnas mit irgendwie Zauberei und special Sachen, die man finden kann und anwenden kann und Dinge, die man kaufen und verkaufen muss und irgendwie im Shop und so. Also nichts, was man nicht heute bei World of Warcraft irgendwie auch hätte, bloß mit viel, viel, viel mehr Aufwand. Aber dann kam dann irgendwann so ein Bote dann auch mal im Spiel zu dir und sagte Hey, I've got a scroll of mail for you. Und der Grund war, dass man halt gerade Mail bekommen hat.
Also richtig Unix-Mail.
Ja genau, du hast halt irgendwie eine Mail erhalten und während du halt NetHack spielst wurde das halt ins Spiel eingebaut und es kam dann so ein Männchen, so ein Bote und hat dir dann die Mail gebracht.
Wahrscheinlich weil die ganzen Bovhars, also die, wie heißen die, was heißt Bovhar? Genau, die haben alle NetHack gespielt und wollten natürlich irgendwie nicht andauernd beim Spielen Mail nachgucken.
Genau, die haben das gleich eingebaut.
Ich glaub, so was gab es damals noch nicht.
Nein, ich spielte auf dieses Video an, wo der Typ eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit nur am ballern ist und nur bei Bedarf wieder auf seine normale Admin-Ebene runterschaltet.
Da können die Chat-Leute auch gleich mal raussuchen.
Wäre doch gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man so Customer Support auch gleich in so einen First-Person-Shooter mit einbauen könnte.
Da kommst du ja so hin und kannst dich gleich in den Kopf schießen.
Als Supporter kannst du dich gleich in den Kopf schießen und so. Task completed. Vielleicht ist das dann wie Second Life irgendwie.
Beziehungsweise ist das so Second Life.
Sind die alten Männer endlich tot und wir können wieder auf vernünftige Themen rennen?
Da sagt grad einer Tellnet-Kommando nicht gefunden. Auf Linux wird kein Tellnet gebundelt.
Was? Aber Tellnet kannst du wirklich langsam mal rauslassen.
Das ist ein Netzwerk, die Backtool, was immer am Start ist.
Das braucht man.
Wenn du mal Plain Mail sprechen willst, um zu gucken, ob dein Mail-Server funktioniert.
Ja, mach mal SSH-Localhost werden versus Tellnet. Damit SSH kannst du dich nur auf SSH-Server verbinden. Mit Tellnet kannst du dich mit allem verbinden. Mit deinem Mail-Server, mit deinem was weiß ich-Server, mit deinem Chat-Server.
Und das braucht man ungefähr wie oft?
Wie laufen? Ich benutze das regelmäßig.
Schon wenn du wissen willst, ist der Port offen oder nicht, zack, Tellnet.
Oder ob überhaupt der richtige Prozess lauscht oder was auch immer.
Ob da die richtigen Kommandos erkannt werden. Das ist die Realität. Verstehst du, das ist eben genau das Ding. Also ich meine, wenn man das alles so wegignoriert, dann versteht man irgendwann das Internet auch nicht mehr.
Wenn man kein Tellnet benutzt.
Also wie gesagt, ich brauche, also wenn ich mir gucken möchte, ob eine Verbindung offen ist, dann schreibe ich dafür raschen Skript.
Ja, ja genau.
Tellnet ist einfach ein universelles Tool irgendwie.
Das ist kein universelles Tool.
Das ist ein Extrem, das ist überhaupt vielleicht mit das universellste Tool überhaupt.
Auch HTTP kannst du nicht machen.
Also zum Beispiel den Studenten in der Uni, wenn ich denen das Web und das Internet erkläre, dann ist Tellnet immer…
Dann zeigst du denen mal ein Get-Lehrzeichen, Slash-Return und dann oh Gott und dann passiert was.
Aber das ist doch cool.
Ja, aber sorry, dafür braucht man das nicht bei einer Installation mitzuliefern. Ja, darum geht's. Nee, die Leute sollen SSH benutzen und die kann Tellnet benutzen.
Darum geht's doch überhaupt nicht.
Und das haben sie damals nicht gemacht.
Was heißt, sie sollen es nicht benutzen? Du kannst natürlich auch mit Tellnet dich auf den SSH-Port connecten.
Ja, es wird dir bloß nicht viel bringen. Die Leute haben unverschlüsselte Verbindungen genutzt und keine verschlüsselten Verbindungen.
Das liegt aber nicht daran, dass sie den kleinen benutzt haben, sondern es liegt daran, dass sie ihren Tellnet-Server laufen haben. Den können sie gerne rausschalten.
Ja, darum haben sie beides einfach rausgeschmissen und gut. Das ist doch okay.
Nein, Tellnet.
Und wer das unbedingt installieren will?
Genau, das ist diese Linux-Leute. Das ist einfach Unix-Tellnet. Das gehört einfach dazu.
Hab ich ja auch schon mehrfach darüber aufgeregnet.
Ja eben.
Genau.
Da merkt man es wieder.
Die sind total shit zufrieden. Aber da hab ich mich auch schon mehrfach darüber aufgeregnet.
Ja, wir prangern das an, außer Max.
Linux-Tellnet.
Ja, das meine ich extrem ernst. Also wenn man das Internet verstehen will, dann hat man einfach Tellnet installiert zu haben.
Am besten benutzt man auch ein Betriebssystem.
Das ist ein Betriebssystem, wo das vorab installiert ist.
Oh Gott, das ist die CCC-Sicht, auf Internet verstehen.
Das ist nicht die CCC-Sicht.
Das fragt man deine Arbeitskollegen.
Du bist schon überstimmt.
Das mag ich sehr gerne.
Also, sorry, Tellnet.
Ich will nicht in die Vergangenheit eingehen mit dem Statement, dass man auf Tellnet verzichten könnte.
Also, um auf Tellnet zu connecten, benutzt natürlich niemand mehr. Aber als Debugtool ist das irgendwie super.
Genau. Also, als Debugtool würde ich was sagen. Wir können uns jetzt noch weiter streiten oder ein weiteres Thema aufgreifen, was wir nicht auf der Liste haben. Genau, ihr meint auch gerade einer ganz passend, mit Tellnet eine Mail geschrieben haben. Das muss man mal gemacht haben.
Och nee, muss man nicht gemacht haben.
Wenn man einen Mail Server betreibt, muss man das neu gemacht haben.
Das muss man wirklich mal gemacht haben. Das sind echt die Details.
Man hat einen unsicheren Mail Server, wenn man es gemacht hat, weil das heißt, dass man keine Verschlüsselung verwendet.
Bist du bescheuert? Du kannst doch mit deinem Tellnet genauso Verschlüsselte Verbindungen sprechen.
Jeder Mail Server meldet sich erstmal unverschlüsselt.
Was wickelst du in OpenSSL drum? Fertig.
So, wie auch immer. Jetzt halt ich noch ein paar langweilige Themen, die uns eigentlich überhaupt nicht betreffen. Ich weiß nicht, hat jemand Facebook-Aktien gekauft?
Okay, das ist ein langweiliges Thema.
Ich kenne jemanden, der Facebook-Aktien gekauft hat. Allerdings ist seine Order nicht durchgekommen.
Hat er Schwein gehabt?
Und die ist halt tatsächlich erst heute durchgekommen. Deswegen hat er erst mal ein bisschen Geld gespart. Aber er hat nur 10 gekauft, glaube ich. Also es war nicht so spektakulärer Fehl.
Chat kann ja mal ein paar Themen aufbringen.
Hier dieses Cheat-Sheet, das wir gerade bringen, das ist doch ganz lustig.
Das war in der Tat ein interessanter Hinweis. Cheat-Sheet ist eine kleine App, die, wenn man sie startet, einfach so läuft. Dann kann man an einem beliebigen Programm die Kommando-Taste, Apple, Blumenkohl, Ventral, sie wissen schon, Taste, gedrückt halten, Propeller, Blume. Dann fallen uns noch mehr Worte ein.
Und dann zeigt er einmal Tastenkürze an.
Und dann blendet er so ein Overlay ein, wo alle Tastenkürze die... Ich deute das jetzt mal als...
So hab ich das ja noch nie gesehen.
Auch nicht schlecht. Die Quattrocopter-Taste drücken. Und ich muss mir noch mal genau anschauen, ob ich es richtig sehe, kann er natürlich nur die Shortcuts, die im Menü verankert sind, anzeigen. Oder? Da holt er sich das her. Oder greift er wirklich eine interne Ressource an? Ich nehm's mal.
Mach doch mal und zeig mal hier.
Wer für das gleiche Geld ausgeben kann, kann sich auch KeyQ kaufen. KeyCue kostet 20 Euro. Sie macht das Gleiche.
Und warum sind so Fenster so riesengroß?
Das könnte ruhig ein bisschen kleiner sein.
Er zeigt das leider immer nur auf dem Main-Screen an und nicht da, wo die Maus ist.
Voll geil. Und vor allem riesengroß und davon so klein, dass man nichts sehen kann.
Auf jeden Fall sieht mir das sehr nach den Menüs aus, weil er das hier auch gruppiert nach den Menünamen.
Ja, aber das könnte schon ein bisschen mehr zusammenschieben und das Fenster auch ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Ja, könnte man, müsste man mal. Aber immerhin gibt es das schon mal.
Was mich etwas verwirrt hat, war, dass ich dieses Programm irgendwie 3- oder 4-mal doppelt geklickt habe und nichts passiert ist. Und dann sogar noch mal runtergeladen habe. Und dann, dass die zweite Version auch doppelt geklickt habe. Und dann hat er kurz zum Start so ein Startmenü gezeigt.
Das zeigt er doch an, so er holt halt die Command-Taste gedrückt, um zu cheaten oder so.
Ja, das hat er nur beim zweiten Mal gemacht oder so. Keine Ahnung, hab ich beim ersten Mal vielleicht nicht gesehen. Das Teil hat ansonsten kein Interface irgendwo. Also es ist nicht mal irgendwie oben so im Menü, als Menü-LED drin oder so.
Ja, finde ich aber auch sehr gut, dass das so ist, weil diese Menu-LEDs da oben, die nerven langsam echt mal.
Ja, aber ein Programm, was keine sichtbare Oberfläche hat, ist irgendwie... Entweder ein Unix-Daemon oder hat irgendwie auch ansonsten auf der GUI nichts zu suchen, finde ich.
Das hier.
Na ja, wie auch immer, eigentlich ist das etwas, was dieses Betriebssystem selber leisten sollte. Das Thema hatten wir ja schon mal.
Wobei mir bei der Benutzung heute aufgefallen ist, wie oft ich die Command-Taste drücke, ohne irgendwie direkt was zu machen. Also einfach, dass man so in Vorbereitung für irgendwas schon mal die Command-Taste drückt, und dann geht plötzlich dieses Fenster auf.
Clemens schlägt noch vor Autobahnkreuz für die Tasse. Clemens, kannst du vielleicht auch nochmal was zu dem Telnet-Thema sagen? Das würde mich ja mal auch aus deinem Munde sehr interessieren. Talkshow-Desaster, ist das ein Thema für uns?
Ich hab nur davon gehört, dass da irgendeine Desaster gibt, aber ich weiß nicht, worum es geht. Kennst du mal kurz eine Management oder eine Executive Summary?
Elevator-Pitch.
Also unser Herr Gruber, John Gruber von Daring Fireball, hat ja auch einen Podcast bei 5x5, ne, wir haben es gemeinsam mit Benjamin, den sie vor vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren schon mal sehr unregelmäßig begonnen haben, dann ausgesetzt haben und dann quasi mit der Geburt von 5x5, also diesen richtigen, so auch genannten 5x5, vorher gab es diesen Namen meines Wissens nicht, regelmäßig gemacht haben seit 2010. Und wohl 90 Ausgaben bereits erschienen sind. Nur? Na gut, in zwei Jahren 90 Ausgaben muss man erst mal hinkriegen. Wir sind jetzt bei 88. Viel dazu. Aber wöchentlich ist halt wöchentlich.
Aber wir sind mehr und machen länger.
Das stimmt.
Wir können länger.
Wir können länger. Wir können auch länger die Luft anhalten.
Aber ich kann länger als du.
Ja, naja, jetzt ist der Counter auch erst mal wieder resettet, weil mehr oder weniger mir nichts, dir nichts, nach einer zweiwöchigen Pause. Oder gibt es noch ein 5-Minuten-Statement, das hab ich noch nicht gehört, von dann, wenn der Gruber sagt irgendwie gar nichts und dann ist er gewechselt. Macht jetzt die Show ähnlich, aber anders, bei Mule, Radio Syndicate, warum auch immer. Irgendwie sieht es sehr danach aus, als ob Mr. Gruber irgendwie gepisst war von irgendwas und davon getrottet ist. Jetzt bin ich leider nicht ganz up to date, weil ich dieses Special da noch nicht kenne, was hier gerade erwähnt wird. Worst Broad, kannst du da vielleicht mal uns ein Executive Summary in den Chat? Da ist er schon unterwegs hier. Denn Benjamin ist etwas enttäuscht, dass Gruber so schnell weg war und das Talkshow-Label mitgenommen hat. Ja, das ist in der Tat. Und es tut ihm leid und alles Gute. Also unklar, es wird allgemein vermutet, dass es da Auseinandersetzungen gab im Bezug auf T-Shirt, Kram oder was die abgekostet hat. Also es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob Geld da so ein bisschen den Katalysator gespielt hat. Was da im Busche war und was dazu geführt hat, weiß ich nicht. Das ist insofern jetzt sehr interessant. Aus meiner Sicht, weil die beiden sich meiner Meinung nach ganz gut ergänzt haben. Also man merkte zwei sehr unterschiedliche Typen, aber er hat seine Moderatorenrolle an der Stelle ganz gut ausgefüllt und hat dann eben diese Katalysatorenfunktion übernommen. Also so sich gegenüber dem anderen einstellen, dass man bestimmte chemische Prozesse in den Gang setzt. Und ist die Frage, ob so ein Grummelkopf wie Gruber da das alleine so reißen kann oder mit wechselnden Gästen so kann. Der würde noch in der Lage sein, seine Punkte da rüberzubringen. Das sehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ach der ist jetzt plötzlich Moderator quasi und...
Das ist noch eine Zusammenfassung. Es war Zeit, etwas Neues zu versuchen.
Ich habe es noch nie gehört, deswegen...
Was noch nie gehört?
Ich habe noch keinen einzigen Den Benjamin Podcast in meinem Leben gehört.
Na ja, schon etwas entgangen.
Ja, die sind immer ein bisschen gemütlicher, finde ich.
Auch kann man sich schon ganz gut anhören.
Schöner als wir. Ja, wir sind ja auch bewusst ungemütlich.
Ungestümmt.
Was ich noch für alle iOS-Entwickler, die es noch nicht gehört haben, empfehlen kann, ist Crashlytics. Das ist geil. Als iOS-Entwickler hat man ja immer dieses Problem, dass man nicht so direkt den Kontakt zu seinen ganzen Usern hat. Und wenn irgendwo eine App abstürzt, und die sagen, hier ist die App abgestürzt, dann kriegst du davon nichts mit und hast keine Ahnung, wie du das Problem reproduzieren sollst. Crashlytics macht etwas, was auch Testflight machen sollte, nämlich einen die ganzen Abstürze abzufangen und die dann entsprechend dir auf einer Webseite schön zu präsentieren. Also wenn dir irgendwo eine App abstürzt, dann kriegst du darüber eine Mail. Und der macht dir dann auch schöne Statistiken darüber. Also bei dem, was ich jetzt mache, ist es im Augenblick noch alles so, dass die Bugs im Wesentlichen einmal auftreten. Er zeigt dir an, wie viele User davon betroffen sind, wie viele Crashers es insgesamt gab, also ob es zum Beispiel bei einem User 10 Crashers gab, welche Betriebssysteme davon betroffen waren, welche Versionen, welche Devices, und arbeitet das Ganze sehr schön auf. Zeigt einem sogar an, wie viel Prozent der User, bei denen das Problem aufgetreten ist, einen Jailbreak hatten, womit man vielleicht schon mal einige wesentliche Bugs doch los, also so Bug-Quellen einfach einschätzen kann. Was unglaublich Geiles ist der Installationsprozess von dem Ganzen. Also man lädt sich da, so dieses Framework einzubinden, das ist wirklich, das machen die einem extrem einfach und man hat leider wieder so ein Menu Bar App, aber von wo man aus jeder Zeit auf die Seite drauf zugreifen kann und das greift einem so geil unterm Arm beim Installieren von diesem Framework.
Das greift einem so geil unterm Arm.
Wie soll man das jetzt sagen?
In Schritt.
Also bei Testfly, zum Beispiel, habe ich bis heute nicht dazu gebracht, wenn eine neue Version da ist, diesen Dialog anzuzeigen, ist eine neue Version da, willst du die installieren? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da falsch mache. Also ich habe das Testflight SDK eingebunden, aber es macht wesentlich gar nichts. Also es zeigt mir die Checkpoints an, es scheint zu funktionieren, es zeigt mir auch an, wenn ein User die App gestartet hat, aber es collectet keine Crashes und es zeigt auch nicht an, wenn irgendjemand was installiert. Crashlytics macht das ganz fantastisch.
Gibt es da hier gar kein Interface-Demo?
Nee, kriegt man keins so sehen.
Dein sieht ja ganz schick aus, aber ich würde es ja gerne vorher mal.
Kostet es was oder ist das kostenlos?
Nö, erstmal ist es kostenlos. Bevor man sich das auf einen Produktiv-Einsatz loslässt, unbedingt mal angucken, sind die Datenschutzerklärungen von denen, weil die werden bestimmt nicht jedem schmecken. Also vielleicht nur in einer Debug-Version einsetzen oder sowas, was natürlich dann auch wieder den Wert mindert. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie irgendwann mal dafür Geld nehmen werden. Also im Augenblick ist das noch in der Beta und die sind auch... Also bei mir haben sie ein ziemliches Bohai. Wir können ja mal andere vielleicht ein bisschen Feedback geben. Bei mir haben sie ein ziemliches Bohai drum gemacht. Hey, wir haben ja noch einen Slot frei, und da ist jemand abgesprungen, wenn er ganz dringt. Und wenn du wirklich was hast, dann sag jetzt Bescheid, dann können wir dich ja noch irgendwie in eine Beta-Version reinschieben und dann kriegen wir alles hin. Kann natürlich sein, dass das so ein Standardprozedere bei denen ist.
Wir haben uns sowas tatsächlich jetzt mehr oder weniger selber gehackt. Das ist wahrscheinlich bei weitem nicht so advanced und schick und schnuffig wie das hier. Aber ja, so eine Tools kann es gerne mehr und auch mit mehr Datenschutz geben.
Ja, und irgendwann könnte Apple sich gerne auch mal davon irgendwas einfach aufkaufen und vernünftig ins Betriebssystem zu integrieren. Weil das ist ja wirklich so, wie gerade auch dieses Testflight, so eine Schicht von Benutzbarkeit um dieses iTunes Provisions Center drum herum legt, ist schon auch dramatisch wie...
Ja, aber nur eine Schicht.
Ja, und die ist auch nur sehr, sehr dünn. Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich einen Beta-User hinzufügen muss, das ist so wirklich, also ich teste die Abbeta, Device hinzufügen, ins Profil die Person mit aufnehmen, noch ein Profil die Person mit aufnehmen, in Xcode die Profile neu laden, warten, bis er die Profile neu geladen hat, in den Build-Settings jetzt nochmal sagen, ja, jetzt nimm das Profil, was du vorher schon hattest, jetzt nimm das auch wieder und das ist wirklich...
Ja, Hockey-App ist angeblich da ein bisschen besser. Allerdings hab ich es auch noch nicht im Einsatz gesehen. Aber ich kenn eigentlich nur Leute, die sagen, Hockey-App ist viel besser als Test-Flight.
Da kenn ich durchaus auch anderes. Ich hab mit Hockey-App noch nicht so aus der Entwicklersicht gesehen, was bei Test-Flight in letzter Zeit eine totale Katastrophe ist, ist die Uptime bzw. die Geschwindigkeit des Servers. Die sind echt lahm. Hockey-App kostet von der ersten Sekunde an Geld. Das wäre jetzt nicht das Schlimme für mich oder das Negative. Ich fand aus der User-Sicht das Interface relativ scheiße. Vom Setup her ist Test-Flight wesentlich entspannter. Ich weiß nicht, ob Hockey-App das drinne hat. Der User muss dir immer diese Device-ID mitteilen. Das ist ja in iTunes irgendwo rumklicken und kopieren, bis du dem das erklärt hast. Bei Test-Flight ist das, du klickst einen Link an, dann musst du da so ein Profil installieren. Danach haben die deine UDI-ID. Du kriegst die als Entwickler automatisch übermittelt und kriegst eine Mail, sowieso hat sich jetzt angemeldet und hat folgende Device-IDs. Dann kannst du die Datei direkt runterladen und direkt bei Apple hochladen und das Device ist drin. Also das ist zum Beispiel sehr angenehm. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Hockey genauso angenehm ist.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Und ich auch nicht. Ich schon, das ist recht nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Was habt ihr denn so für Themen hier?
Netzgeb, IPO, Facebook. War das nicht das Gleiche?
Ein schöner Versprecher, ein sehr schöner Versprecher. Ich finde auch ein super Vergleich. Irgendwie finde ich es ein super Vergleich.
Gibt es da irgendwas Interessantes zu erzählen, außer dass das passiert ist, was alle dachten?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das passiert ist.
Nix ist nicht passiert. Das ist mehr als nichts passiert.
Ich hab nicht darüber nachgedacht, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Mir ist immer noch so egal, wie nur irgendwas.
Hast du nicht schon so eine Ahnung, ob das jetzt irgendwie voll das riesengroße Ding wird?
Das ist so das riesengroße Ding. Es sind immer noch 88 Milliarden gestern gewesen. 88 Milliarden was? Dollar. Wert, Aktien.
Vielleicht die Blase ist nur leicht angestochen, hat ein bisschen Luft abgelassen, aber vielleicht kommt ja der Platzer noch.
Also wird jetzt interessant sein zu sehen, wie sich Facebook jetzt unter den neuen Bedingungen einer aktiennotierten Firma verhält.
Ja, haben sie ja schon, oder?
Da weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest stellt es natürlich eine gewisse Vergleichbarkeit her zu anderen Unternehmen. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das könnte die Sache interessant machen.
Ich glaube, das Feature haben sie noch nicht eingekündigt. Aber, nee, es sind sogar zwei Feature. Ich glaube, ich darf noch nicht darüber reden.
Aber, wenn du darüber reden könntest, dann könntest du uns sagen, dass...
Dann auch nicht über das Gerät was dabei ist?
Also, sagen wir mal so, hab ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt, aber von diesen ganzen Social Networks, die es gab und gibt, sind die schon einfach am allerweitesten, wenn es darum geht, auch echte Knete halt da rauszuziehen. Also nicht nur über Advertisement, sondern eben auch über ihre Apps und ihre Spiele. Und Spiele sind halt schon extrem groß. Also ich alleine sehe, was VUGA da so einnimmt mit Facebook-Spielen und sehe, dass es da noch Publisher gibt, die fünfmal größer sind. Und Facebook da von 30 Prozent abkriegt, das ist schon ein ordentlicher Stapel Geld, wird man ja dann wahrscheinlich durch diese Aktiengeschichte auch bald nachlesen können. Und die sind halt, also das, was ich jetzt nicht erzählen kann, aber die bleiben halt auch nicht stehen, sind halt auch noch mehr Features in der Pipeline, um noch mehr Geld zu machen, die auch alle total sinnvoll klingen. Und das habe ich halt von einem anderen Social Network in der Form einfach noch nicht gesehen. Also ich glaube schon, dass sie das erst mal eine Weile ganz gut aushalten und wahrscheinlich auch noch mehr Asche machen können in nächster Zeit.
Ja, aber sie müssen halt für den Aktienkurs, den sie da gerade haben, sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr Asche machen. Bist du das Problem?
Weiß man halt nicht.
Doch weiß man.
Warum müssen sie das machen?
Na, weil...
Eine Milliarde Gewinn machen sie im Jahr?
Nee, vier waren es, glaube ich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon eine kleine Ecke mehr.
Aber hat man ja so gelesen, dass alle sagen, dass wenn Google, wenn sie diesen Wert so darstellen wollen, müssten sie viel, viel, viel mehr Gewinn machen, sonst würde es demnächst sinken.
Also, gut, also sagen wir mal so, die haben auf jeden Fall Sachen noch in der Pipeline, wo ich mir schon vorstellen könnte, dass sie auch noch mehr Asche machen.
Also, Google macht, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe, im Quartal, jetzt hier so letztes Jahr, irgendwie drei Milliarden. Welches Quartal war das? Im ersten Quartal 2012 haben sie knapp drei Milliarden Gewinn gemacht. Wenn das jetzt so, lasst die im Jahr so zwölf Milliarden machen, dann haben sie dreimal so viel wie Google, aber dann ist der...
steht im Chat wieder, der Chat weiß es wieder besser, eine Milliarde Gewinn bei vier Milliarden Umsatz.
Also...
Ja, aber wie gesagt, so... Ich rechne den eigentlich ganz gut, also ob jetzt der Aktienkurs wirklich gerechtfertigt ist, die haben ihn ja auch noch kurz vorher teurer gemacht, weil sie auch nicht so ganz verstanden haben, so was dieser...
Ein Aktienkurs sagt auch, was über das Vertrauen und die Erwartungshaltung für die Zukunft aus.
Ja eben, sonst könnte es ja nicht so schnell steigen und so schnell platzen, wenn es irgendwas Reales dahinter stecken würde.
Auf gut Deutsch, die Leute haben überhaupt keine Erwartung, dass es irgendwie anders wird, als es bisher ist? Weil der Kurs hat sich ja nicht wirklich bewegt, also...
Er ist nach unten gegangen bisher.
Ja, aber auch nur so ein bisschen.
Na ja, von 42 auf 32 Dollar ist jetzt schon minus 25 Prozent.
Das ist nicht ein bisschen.
Aber ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, was das bedeutet, weil ich keinen Verständnis davon habe, wie ein Kurs überhaupt festgelegt wird vor seiner Ausgabe. Also was da sozusagen die Denke dahinter ist, was es bedeutet, wenn er höher oder niedriger ist, etc.
Wenn er höher ist, nehmen die mehr Geld an. Darum geht es ja bei diesem Aktien-Auswurf. Also Facebook selbst erstmal.
Ja, aber wie bestimmst du diesen Wert? Was steckt hinter der Überlegung von 42 Dollar?
Die Banken, die diesen Epo da machen, die setzen sich hin und denken sich aus, was es wert ist.
Also das sind nur die Banken?
Ja, ich denke schon. Und zwar auch immer mehrere, glaube ich.
Wahrscheinlich setzen sie sich da auf Facebook selber hin und sagen, was wir gerne dafür haben wollen.
Wir sind gerade auf dünnem Eis, der dünne Eisdetektor hier. Ihr werdet totalen Stoß reden.
Ich würde ja denken, dass sie den Ausgabepreis mal die tatsächlich verkauften Aktien dieses Produkt maximieren wollen. So wie man halt jedes Produkt einpreist. Genau.
Und dann gucken sie halt, wie wären sie am meisten los von dem Scheiß? Oder wie wären sie das, was sie loswerden wollen?
Und dann musst du halt den Markt richtig einschätzen können, wie viel sind die Leute tatsächlich bereit zu zahlen?
Und Angebot und Nachfrage, nicht? Also ich meine, wenn die keiner kauft, dann...
Ja, das Angebot setzt du ja.
Aber der Markt bestimmt den Wert. Der Markt bestimmt den Preis. Das ist natürlich auch wie so ein Pokal. Der Pokal hat seine eigenen Regeln.
Aber wenn sie keine Aktien verkaufen, sinkt dann der Kurs automatisch?
In der Nachspielzeit kann noch alles passieren.
Der Kurs bestimmt sich ja dadurch, dass an der Börse Leute sagen, ich verkaufe die Aktie zu dem und dem Preis. Und es gibt Leute, die sagen, ich würde die Aktie zu dem und dem Preis kaufen. Und der Broker, der guckt, wo hat er die größte Übereinstimmung und macht dann den Handel zwischen den Leuten, die anbieten und denen, die verkaufen. Die anbieten und die, die kaufen. Und dadurch ergibt sich dann immer der Preis zwischen den Leuten, die sagen, so viel ist es mir wert, und die anderen, die sagen, so viel will ich haben.
Kauf und Verkauf gibt es ja gar nicht, sondern es gibt ja nur noch Tausch. Also immer da, wo verkauft wird, wird ja auch ein anderer einkaufen. Ja, weil manche sagen, naja, der Aktienkurs geht nach oben, weil so viele gekauft haben. Das heißt aber auch, dass viele verkauft haben.
Facebook, die am Anfang, oder die Banken, die am Anfang alle hatten. Und Google hat ja auch, Quatsch, Microsoft hat ja wohl auch ein Viertel ihrer Facebook-Aktien abgestoßen.
Auf jeden Fall ist das Drama jetzt halt deshalb, weil er runtergegangen ist, gleich bei so etwas total aufgeblasenem wie Facebook, wo alle erwartet haben, die Zukunft in Reinform, da kaufe ich mal ein paar Aktien.
Ich glaub da ja nicht so dran.
Ja, du glaubst da nicht dran, aber du glaubst sicherlich, dass verschiedene Leute daran glauben und da jetzt Geld reingeschmissen haben. Und das erste, was passiert ist, dass sie Geld verloren haben. Ja, Ausgabekurs genau, dass sie jetzt vielleicht zu diesem Initialpreis mal gekauft haben und alle anderen haben Däumchen gedreht und sich gedacht dumm die dumm.
Also wenn sie Glück haben, dann dauert es ja auch ein Jahr und dann sind sie in einem Jahr bei 50 Dollar, wer weiß.
Ja, vielleicht, aber ich glaube, die haben ja gedacht, dass da...
Ja, aber noch ist es nicht die Telekom-Aktie. Da gab es immer so einen schönen Text von jemanden, der gesagt hat, wenn man zum Ausgabepreis der Telekom-Aktie nicht für 1000 Euro nicht Telekom-Aktien, sondern Bier gekauft hätte, dann hätte man irgendwie ein Jahr lang jeden Woche einen Kasten trinken können und hätte am Ende des Jahres mehr Pfand, als die Aktie nach dem Jahr dann noch wäre.
Mehr Pfand.
Ach ja, aber Facebook, die sollen endlich mal ein bisschen was von dieser Scheißkohle, die sie eingenommen haben, nehmen und in ihre Mobile-App investieren. Das ist so eine Katastrophe. Facebook beherrscht die Kunst, dass ihre iPhone-App noch schlechter wird, obwohl sie gar kein Update dafür rausbringt. Das ist die Magic von Web und Deployment und Server und weiß ja teufel was, dass das immer noch schlimmer werden kann. Und das ist, wie lange ich mittlerweile auf diesen Loading-Balken bei diesem iPhone starte, nur weil mir wieder mal jemand eine Nachricht zugeschickt hat und das irgendwie wirklich 30 Sekunden dauert, bis dir mir eine so eine fucking Nachricht anzeigt.
Also ich hab neulich die, wie soll ich sagen, die Meinung gehört, da hat jemand die Meinung vertreten, dass die Facebook-App deswegen so schlecht ist, weil Facebook gar kein Interesse daran hat, dass du die App benutzt. Du sollst auf die Website gehen.
Ja, aber die Website ist, ich war auf der Website, und die Website ist ja genau das Gleiche und ist exakt genauso scheiße. Das ist...
Aber mit mehr Werbung.
Warum sollte sie kein Interesse daran haben, dass die Leute die App verwenden?
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Die haben es gerade nicht braucht.
Keine Ahnung, ich nix Facebook.
Ja, wir alle nix Facebook.
Ich schon manchmal gezwungenermaßen Facebook, weil die Welt um mich rum leider Facebook, aber... Wobei, das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Früher war es immer so, dass die meisten Leute so, ja, ich bin auf Facebook, also so eine Egal-Einstellung zu Facebook hatten, so ich bin auf Facebook, weil da auch alle anderen sind. Also ich kenne jetzt nicht viele Leute, die wirklich so yeah, Facebook! Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass das mittlerweile in Hass umgeschlagen ist. Also man ist da gezwungen noch da zu sein, weil darüber halt alles läuft. Aber mein Eindruck ist schon, dass die meisten Leute wirklich Facebook mittlerweile relativ offensiv hassen. Und das könnte ihnen auch mal was für sie zum Problem sein.
Aber so lange soll es ja benutzen, also was nützt das?
Also ich habe über Facebook erfahren, dass ein Freund von mir nach Japan gezogen ist und eine Japanerin kennengelernt hat. Das habe ich auf normalem Wege nicht erfahren, solange sowas dann noch funktioniert.
Ja, ich meine, das ist auch das Ding. Mittlerweile teilt sich ja die Welt so ein bisschen in Twitter und in Facebook. Und dann gibt es noch so ein paar Verirrte, die bei Google Plus schreiben.
Nee, das ist schon was anderes.
Verirrte Bots, die auf Google Plus schreiben. Das war sehr schön zu sehen auf der Republika. Ich weiß nicht, wer mir das erzählt. Auf jeden Fall war das so die Wahrnehmung, ich habe es jetzt nicht selber überprüft, aber ich glaube es sofort, also klang plausibel, sagen wir es mal so, dass so auf Twitter eine Verdopplung der Timeline-Aktivität so zu verzeichnen war. Weil natürlich alle wie die Bekloppten in Twitter reingegossen haben, was sie gerade auf der Republik erleben oder beobachten, aber es auf Facebook einfach keine nennenswerten Ausschläge gab.
Ja, das ist schon auf jeden Fall auch so, ich beobachte das ja auch, das ist schon so ein bisschen Asynch. Also nicht nur, dass da auf Facebook die lustigen Bilder, die ich vor einer Woche oder zwei oder einem Monat vielleicht schon auf super.io oder im Twitter geklickt habe, kommen, sondern auch so bei Events ist das ganz unterschiedlich. Im Twitter Scrolls, im Facebook geht es um ganz andere Sachen.
Facebook ist irgendwie das...
Aber hat alles geschworen.
Dass ich Ärger kriege. Facebook ist das TV für bestimmte Leute.
Ach, ist ja auch alles egal, wie gesagt. Ich sage nur von dem, was ich so da bei VUGA an Einblicken habe, würde ich schon sagen, dass sie ja eigentlich einen ganz ordentlichen Job so machen.
Das hättest du aber auch nicht gesagt, wenn du nicht bei VUGA arbeiten würdest.
Naja, ne, jetzt wo ich auch noch so ein bisschen Zahlenmaterial hier und da mal sehe.
Sind die jetzt cooler, weil die viel Geld verdienen oder?
Ne, also ich sehe halt auch, was sie tun, was sie so für Features einbauen, wie sie so ihre Plattformen ausbauen. Und es macht schon Sinn. Also das habe ich halt einfach bei keinem anderen Social Network oder Plattform in der Form so stringent durchgezogen gesehen. Also es ist schon, also es mag halt langsam sein, es mag halt auch hässlich sein oder was auch immer, aber irgendwie so das, was sie dann so rausbringen und was die Leute da benutzen für ihre Apps, um auch selber Geld zu verdienen und so, das mit der Werbung. Sie haben ihre eigene App-Plattform halt, bist da auch Feature-mäßig noch besser eigentlich dabei als bei Google, weil da haben die Leute wirklich alle ihre Daten reingekippt und kann sagen, das 13-jährige Mädchen mit roten Haaren aus Berlin aus dem Westbezirk mit drei Freunden und spielt irgendwie im Bubble Island oder was auch immer, kriegt jetzt die Werbung eingeblendet, kannst halt machen. Und natürlich finden das Leute toll, die Werbung schalten wollen oder kannst sagen, Leute, die My Little Pony gespielt haben, die sollen jetzt bitte die Werbung für Mobile Max eingeblendet kriegen und so. Das kannst du ja bei Google auch machen.
Geile Idee, das sollten wir machen.
Ja, und schon alleine als App-Plattform ist Facebook einfach da echt potent.
Meinst du, wir sollten Facebook-Werbung machen für Mobile Max?
Ich glaube, es wäre tatsächlich effektiv.
Sollte dir My Little Pony shouten, sollten wir auch.
Ich glaube, das ist ja auch bei Google jetzt schon der Effekt. Du kannst mit relativ wenig Geld schon genau deine Zielgruppe erreichen und einen Effekt erzählen. Bei Facebook kannst du das meines Erachtens auch mindestens genauso gut, wenn nicht noch viel besser.
Aber dann muss ich ja Facebook-Seiten pflegen.
Egal.
Da springt uns Max sofort ab.
Ich sag ja nur, dass das so ein Punkt ist, den sie halt schon mal richtig machen. Und dieses ganze Payment, was sie da gebaut haben, funktioniert halt und benutzen viele. Und die kriegen halt auch 30% davon. Und dann kommt halt noch mehr von diesen Payment-Features und Facebook-Credits. Und hast du nicht gesehen, ich würd's ja gerne erzählen. Also auch so, auch ihre Vermarktung sozusagen von den Apps, die sie da auf Facebook so anbieten. Also für so ein Otto-Normal-User, den oft zitierten, ist ja momentan, sind ja diese Apps noch relativ versteckt. Also man sieht sie vielleicht so in der Sidebar, so in den Werbungen halt durchscrollen, aber von sich aus wird man jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommen, vielleicht nach Apps zu suchen. Und das wird sich vermutlich auch in der nächsten Zeit da sowieso auf der Plattform noch ein bisschen abzentrischer abspielen.
Ich hab ja, ich bin ja auf Facebook ganz furchtbar sauer, weil früher hatte ich da halt so eine, auch so eine Menü-Leisten-App laufen, so die Facebook-Notifier direkt von Facebook haben sie irgendwann mal gebaut. Und das hat halt immer einem die ganzen Notifications angezeigt, sodass, also für mich ist ja so eher so ein Facebook eher so eine Inbox. Also ich geh da ja nicht aktiv drauf, sondern es ist so, da kontaktieren mich halt Leute und dann gehe ich da auch mal drauf und klicke da irgendwas an und antworte da drauf. Und dafür war es halt ganz gut. Und diese App haben sie nicht mehr aktualisiert und jetzt funktioniert die bei mir plötzlich nicht mehr. Und seitdem kriege ich nicht mehr mit, wenn da irgendwas auf Facebook passiert. Und das ist so die einzige Notification, die ich noch kriege, die sind auf dem iPhone, die sehe ich aber nur alle Jubiljahre mal. Nervt wie Sau. Sollen wir mal jemandem was vernünftiges machen, aber die Facebook-AP ist auch so scheiße. Über die kannst nicht mal du was Gutes sagen, oder?
Naja, sagen wir mal so. Also api-technisch, also wir müssen ja auch... Okay, du gibst dir Mühe. Da wir auch mit Apple zu tun haben, weil wir auch iOS-Spiele machen, muss ich schon sagen, dass die Apple-Jungs da in der Ecke fitter sind, auf jeden Fall. Also wo Facebook irgendwie alles durch das arme HTTP durchprügelt, dann macht Apple halt im Zweifel auch einfach mal eine Socket auf und dann spricht man da ein effizientes Binärprotokoll und die akzeptieren einfach alles mit super geringer Latenz. Bei Facebook ist halt alles so...
Und die API ist von denen halt kaputt, schlichtenweise. Jedständig kaputt, also jede Woche an einer Stelle kaputt.
Ja, aber sie bleiben halt nicht stehen, trotz alledem. Auch wenn dann so ihnen auffällt mittendrin, ach, wir haben das neue Feature nur auf die Hälfte unserer Server deployed, ja gut, dann schieben wir es jetzt halt nach. Also sie bleiben halt nicht stehen. Das muss man ihnen zumindest zugute halten. Also sie schieben schon konstant ihre Plattform nach vorne auch.
Das ist ja ihr Motto.
Durchaus.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ihnen das auch irgendwann noch mal zu einem echten Problem wird für sie. Aber an sich gebe ich dir total recht. Schnell machen ist gut und ist super. Und ist, wenn man eine Website baut, auch super. Aber irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, sie kriegen es gerade alles nicht mehr so richtig zusammen.
Das ist auch so bei uns zum Beispiel. Wenn sie uns jetzt hier oder den großen Developern geben, geben sie halt irgendwelche API-Features zuerst, um mal rumzuspielen. Und das ist halt auch so, dann sagen sie, okay, nächsten Mittwoch geht es los. Und dann ach nee, wir brauchen noch eine Woche. Und wir brauchen noch eine Woche. Und wir brauchen noch eine Woche. Und dann dauert es halt vier statt zwei Wochen. Aber es kommt halt so. Wie gesagt, sie bleiben in Bewegung.
Dieses Timeline-Feature hat damals ewig gebraucht, bis es wirklich kam.
Oder?
Haben sie angekündigt?
Aber das ist ja auch okay.
Und jetzt hassen sie alle. Oder haben sich die Leute mittlerweile dran gewöhnt?
Also von den Zahlen, die wir so sehen, haben sich die meisten scheinbar dran gewöhnt. Anscheinend.
Offensichtlich genug, dass Google Plus das so kopiert hat.
Facebook genug gecovert jetzt wieder mal. Ist ja auch jetzt schon fast fester Bestand in unserer Sendungsreihe geworden. Fast jede zweite Folge gibt es die große Facebook-Abhandlung. Ja, Apple ist ja... Du hast lange nicht mehr deine PING-Seite geupdatet.
Aber ich kann auch mal dreinhalten.
Ich sag doch, PING ist ein Netzwerk, das kurzer gelebt hat als Google Wave.
Ja, also echt, was für ein...
Was ist PING?
Von Apple das. Kommt man da irgendwie raus? Weil ich krieg da hin und wieder mal noch Anfragen. Die krieg ich dann immer... Du kannst es irgendwie wieder abschalten. Hey, wie peinlich.
Wie peinlich auch. Ist echt so...
Wicked in Tumbleweed sag ich nur.
Aber hier Google Plus...
Nicht mal das.
Die haben es ja auch irgendwie drauf, so einen Creepiness-Faktor einzuführen. Ich hab neulich irgendwo gelesen, dass jetzt die neue Google-Plus-App draußen ist. Und... Ich hab die erst mal installiert, weil die ja viele Leute für sehr, sehr schön hielten. Und danach hat man wieder nix von gehört und hab die mal ausprobiert. Und plötzlich so zur Mittagszeit bin ich mal auf Google Maps und diese übliche rote 1-Bar, die da oben drin ist, die man einfach hin und wieder mal... Kennt ihr ja auf den Google Seiten diese 1-Leiste, die da oben drin ist? Die man dann wegklicken muss und dann hab ich da drauf geklickt und dann zeigte mir das irgendein Foto von mir an und meinte, hey, wir haben ja ein Foto von dir, willst du es nicht mit deinen Freunden teilen? Woher habt ihr dieses scheiß Foto? Und dann hab ich festgestellt, dass diese Google Plus App, die stellt nämlich beim ersten Start so ne dämliche Frage, also ich hab sie so verstanden, sollen wir Bilder nur über WLAN hochspielen oder auch über 3G? Und ich hab gesagt, ja, auch über 3G ist okay. Das hieß aber so viel wie, übrigens, wir laden im Hintergrund dein gesamtes Album zu Google Plus hoch. Und die Frage war wirklich so formuliert, also ich würde sagen bewusst so, damit man es versehentlich hoch will.
Sie haben ja die Bilder per WLAN, oder?
Genau, sie haben mal deinen Adress per WLAN. Wo hatten die das? Und ich war halt auch nicht auf Google Plus, ich war nicht darauf vorbereitet, sondern ich wollte nur rasch eine Adresse raussuchen, weil auf der Suche da war es komplett anders. Und plötzlich halten die mir so auf Google Maps und Foto von mir in die Fresse, was dazu geführt hat, dass ich auf der Stelle diese Google Plus App gelöscht habe. Ich hab dann nochmal so auf Twitter mich darüber ein bisschen ausführlich beschwert, und dann frag doch, und dann hab ich davon nochmal einen Screenshot gemacht. Es ist wie so andere Apps, wie Instacast fragt, soll ich auch über 3G runterladen oder nur über WLAN? So ist halt die Frage bei denen auch formuliert. Und sie haben irgendwie nicht dafür... Ich meine, Facebook will ja an genau die gleichen Daten ran und irgendwie stellen die sich dabei wesentlich geschickter an. Die machen das irgendwie so hin, dass man das Gefühl hat, sie freiwillig rauszurücken. Wohingegen ich gerade bei Google Plus jetzt schon sehr oft das Gefühl hatte, da wird mir irgendwas ins Gesicht gedrückt, was ich gar nicht möchte. Und das kann Facebook auch sehr gut.
Tja, mal sehen, wie lange der Larry da noch durchhält mit seinem Google Plus. Und irgendwann schalten sie Google ab und man muss einen Google-Account haben, um überhaupt noch googeln zu können. Und ja, dann ist es vorbei.
Aber ich finde auch die Seite so hässlich. Die haben diese neue Seite gemacht und die ist so unglaubfassbar.
Ich dachte auch nicht, dass es noch jemand schafft, eine unattraktivere Seite als Facebook zu bauen, aber...
Sie ist vor allen Dingen dabei auch so unglaublich egal.
Ich hoffe nur, dass Apple das alles dicht macht. Kein Adressbuch mehr, keine Bilder hochladen, kein gar nichts, geht mir auf den Sack.
Außer in die Cloud.
Ich mag Bilder hochladen prinzipiell eigentlich ganz gerne.
Ja, man kann ja fragen, das App-Feuer. Dann geht es halt über eine spezielle App. Aber dass die einfach so rankommen, finde ich nicht gut.
Bei Mountain Lion gibt es da irgendwie eine extra Preference für.
Also ich finde es da echt scheiße, dass da wegen jedem Müll gefragt wird. Ich finde den Ansatz, den Apple da wählt, dass sie probieren, die Abfragen wirklich auf ein Minimum zu begrenzen, eigentlich ganz gut. Weil dieses, wie bei Windows Vista oder wie es bei Android ist, dieses, du musst eine Latte von Aktionen zustimmen. Und das will das und das will das, die sich dann eh niemand durchliest, das ist auch kein guter Weg.
Auch bei Programmen, die an meine Bilder ran wollen, die können ruhig schon mal fragen. So viele wollen ja da auch nicht ran, also so viele Fragen sind es doch eigentlich gar nicht, oder?
Also ich fänd's okay, wenn man einfach so, was Google ja macht, die gehen ja wirklich, das war so ein Standard-Picture-Chooser, so ein Image-Picker, bei dem brauchst du ja nicht, das ist eine explizite, und auf alle Bilder zugreifen, da kann man schon ruhig mal eine Abfrage stellen.
Ja, ich finde auch, das wäre schon eine gute.
Und Adressbuch genau das Gleiche. Also, wenn die alle meine...
Irgendein Adress-Picker und...
Wie ein Adress-Picker.
Aber die Diskussion hatten wir, glaube ich.
Kommt noch nichts bisher bei Apple. Das soll ja ein bisschen mehr Drog machen.
Mit iOS 6 wird alles besser.
Das ist so traurig.
Streng dich an, Apple. Streng dich an. Wir sind einfach nicht mehr gerockt.
Ich hab jetzt übrigens auch Windows 8 ausprobiert.
Und bist du gerockt?
Das erklärt einiges.
Die größte Challenge, das war so ein bisschen wie in so einem Grafik-Adventure, war das System runterzufahren. Das hat mich echt Zeit gekostet, das zu finden.
Hast du keinen Button in deiner Hardware?
Nee, dann schläft da wahrscheinlich nur ein.
In der Virtual Box? Nein. Ja gut, da gibt's vielleicht so ein Per-RP-Ausschalten. Aber so dieses einfach per Betriebssystem den zu sagen, jetzt fahr mal runter und dann ist gut.
Nachdem man's gefunden hat, ist es eigentlich gar nicht mehr total bescheuert. Obwohl doch eigentlich schon noch. War das irgendwo eine Ecke wieder oder was?
Ein Bildschirm ran?
Also es gibt ja die zwei Modi in Windows 8. Also einmal diesen Klassik-Modus, nenn ich's mal, das Desktop-Windows und dann gibt's diesen komischen Kachel-Modus, dieses Metro-Zeug. Und das hat ja Max schon erzählt, dass man das wissen muss, dass man in der linken unteren Ecke mit dem Maus-Cursor in die Ecke fahren muss, dass da der Button aufgeht, dass man, also um vom Desktop-Modus in den Kachel-Modus zu kommen, dass man unten in die Ecke, was bei einer Virtual Box, die in einem Fenster läuft, nicht ganz einfach ist. Weil man natürlich sofort raus ist aus dem Fenster und dann diese Ecke irgendwie nie trifft, aber das nur am Rande. Also du musst in den Kachel-Modus und in dem Kachel-Modus gibt es rechts oben den Namen des Benutzers.
Und da klickt man drauf und dann ist man...
Da klickt man drauf und wenn man da draufklickt, bekommt man so ein hübsches Bild, da ist so ein blühender japanischer Kirschbaum drauf, große Uhrzeit und das Datum und sonst ist da nichts. Und da denkst du so, ok, Kirschbaum. Genau, dann klickst du da drauf rum und denkst dir irgendwie, ich muss nur den Spot finden, wo ich hinklicken muss, dann passiert irgendwas.
Wahrscheinlich ist das ein japanisches Symbol für Ende des Lebens und das ist jetzt wie runterfahren.
Du, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall musst du mit dem Rollrad rollen, dann rollt der Kirschbaum nach oben weg.
Du sagtest, es soll ein Grafik-Adventure, ne?
Ich sagte Grafik-Adventure. Benutze Kirschbaumblüte mit Benutzernahme.
Windows 8 ist sozusagen das Nethack des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Also du musst den Kirschbaum mit dem Rollrad wegrollen und dann bekommst du so einen klassischen Log-in-Screen, wo halt so User sind, die du anklicken kannst, um Passwort einzugehen.
Da hab ich aber noch einen zweiten Walkthrough.
Moment, und dann kannst du unten rechts ist auch ein Ausschalt-Button, also so ein Ein-Ausschalt-Symbol, so ein Kreis mit zum Strich. Und wenn du da drauf klickst, geht ein Menü auf, wo einmal Neustart und einmal herunterfahren drin steht.
Man könnte ja sagen, naja, runterfahren ist ja nicht so schlimm, aber ich nehme um an, das ist nur exemplarisch und alles ist so kompliziert.
Was, es gibt einen Button, der aussieht wie ein Ein-Ausschalt-Button und wenn man draufklickt, kriegt man tatsächlich die Wahl zum Neustart? Ich meine, das ist doch relativ intuitiv oder nicht?
Ja, man muss diesen Button halt finden.
Ist er immer da?
Nee, wie gesagt, du musst erst Kachelmodus, Kirschbaum, nein, Kachelmodus, dann auf den Benutzernamen klicken, dann bekommst du den Kirschbaum, dann musst du den Kirschbaum hochrollen und dann musst du auf den Ein-Ausschalt-Button klicken.
Ach, der kommt erst nach dem Kirschbaum. Das wäre jetzt eine Alternative dazu.
Nee, nein, aber es geht noch was. Was noch geht, ist unten rechts in die Ecke die Maus bewegen und dann erscheint so eine Baby-Systemeinstellung. Und da ist dann auch irgendwo noch ein Ausschalt-Button gewesen, wenn ich nicht alles täusche.
Geil. Wahrscheinlich kannst du auch dem average Windows-User alle möglichen Prozeduren einreden, wie es noch schneller geht. So wie wenn du deinen Finger anfeuchtest und den ins Ohr steckst und mit der anderen Hand irgendwie in die Hose 10 Sekunden vor dem Bildschirm stehen bleibst.
Dann fährt er sich auch automatisch runter.
Das ist eine Alternative für Doppelklick.
Aber nur, wenn du hier von Xbox dieses Ding, dieses Kinect hast.
Ja, ja, also wie gesagt, dass Dale da schon vorwarnt, dass sie vermutet, dass von Windows 8 jetzt man sich nicht auf ganz große Neuverkäufe erhoffnen muss. Ich glaube, diese Warnung ist schon durchaus berichtigt. Die haben es gesehen.
Hat eigentlich nicht Microsoft so ein Support Center auch?
Willst du da jetzt anrufen?
Nein, aber ich meine, wir müssen uns doch so ein bisschen Gedanken machen. Bei Apple habe ich immer das Gefühl, die machen alles so, damit möglichst niemand anrufen muss, weil es kostet halt Geld und so, oder? Bei Microsoft, ich meine, deren Support Center, die brechen noch zusammen, wenn das rauskommt.
Es kann auch sein, dass es da einfach schon so eine Art genetischen Anpassungsbezirks gegeben hat bei Windows, der sich uns nicht erschließt. Ja, dass da einfach...
Ja, die benutzen alle immer noch XP.
Ja, das sind alles Mutanten. Die haben sich einfach schon so an diese Logik gewöhnt, einschließlich der Entwickler bei Microsoft, dass die das einfach...
Ne, Rolli hat recht, sie benutzen einfach das alte weiter.
Aber von wem war denn dieser Song? War das von Mike Krüger mit dem Nippel durch die Lasche ziehen? Ja, das wär doch eigentlich als auch ein schöner Ausspieler dann noch.
So, wollen wir jetzt mal über die Facebook- finanziellen Details von Facebook ganz im Geheimen weiter reden und diese Sendung langsam zum Ende führen? Ich muss nämlich ganz früh aufstehen und in den Zug springen. Und würde langsam gerne zum Ende kommen, zumal wir keine Themen haben. Ja, und uns jetzt schon über Kirschbäume auf Windows unterhalten. Was meint ihr?
Oh, da klingelt mein Telefon. Wer ruft denn da an?
Na ja, vielleicht ausnahmsweise, na gut, dieses eine Mal.
Die Sendung ist schon sehr lang. Na ja, eineinhalb Stunden.
Schaut mal den Start-Button.
Ja, das ist einfach lang.
Lange Sendung ist lang.
Lange Sendung ist lang. Haben wir's? Das bleibt mit dem Raum, Max, Puckel, Roddy, Dennis und ich. Und alle anderen.
Oh mein Gott, ist es so weit hin, als ich für Hitler.
Sagen wir Tschüss.
Das war's für heute. Wir sehen uns bald wieder.
Das heißt ja nicht umsonst.
Ah, ah.
Nope, nope, nope.